bookstore in washington d.c is 50
minutes
while dick cheney has been in the
political arena for years there has been
a noticeable lack of information
available about his background
luckily mr nichols has stepped to the
plate providing a well-researched and
humorous biography shedding light on one
of the most influential men in the
current bush administration
while john nichols previous work
includes it's the media stupid our media
not theirs and jews for pre-canon
currently mr nichols runs the editorial
page of madison's capitol times
newspaper and is a correspondent for the
nation magazine i have a quote here that
i think you guys will enjoy
of all the dragon slayers now afoot in
the american desert john nichols sword
is the sharpest from gore vidal
please help me welcome john nichols
[Applause]
thank you very much
i will i will keep
i will keep my sword sheathed through
most of the evening
and i am uh honored to be on the
politics and prose stage
where only a week ago john stewart uh
was present were any of you there at
john stewart's reading
i i see some folks who were and and
i promise i will not call anyone on cnn
a dick
tonight um
well i i think i think the case has been
well established and it's pretty well
pretty well finished but uh
i do you know i was very pleased that he
did use the book's title in that moment
um
we're going to talk about dick cheney
for a little bit tonight i will talk for
about 20 minutes and then uh we'll take
some questions and i'm i am uh just i
want to make sure everybody gets a
chance to see the debates
yeah and i just i say if you note to
young authors
if you want to write a book about
somebody in administration take the vice
president and hope for a debate pattern
like we had this year
because
after that first debate i felt uh i
didn't really need to make much of a
case about who was in charge of the
country
george bush came on and
you all but said you know geez president
is really hard
and i didn't say it once probably about
a dozen times and then you know he kind
of struggled through through debate
after debate he finally got down to the
one thing he was very very good at which
was explaining how to get a flu shot
and then uh and a good description of
how to pray which i thought he did
rather well but but when you got down to
the nuts and bolts of running this
administration you really needed to go
to that second debate and watch dick
cheney because dick cheney sat there you
know
cool calm i know people often ask why
does he talk into his shirt like that
the answer is
this is a guy who has never had to
enunciate in in his life you know he's
used to having hundreds of terrified
minions leap to their feet and run out
and do whatever he tells them to do
so he doesn't have to yell very loud but
in the debate he did make the basic
effort to communicate
and it is true that much of the
communication was lies
but uh at least he went for it and and i
want to focus on that one wonderful
statement that uh that
uh our vice president made as regards
his opponent
in which he said you know i will
paraphrase here but essentially you know
i go up to capitol hill every tuesday to
preside over the senate and i'm and this
is the first time that i've ever met you
john edwards
well of course
that was a a lie
but um but it was actually a wonderful
lie it was one of the one of those
multi-tiered lies that you don't hear so
often in our politics and and so i just
want to take it apart for a little bit
as all of you i'm sure know uh john
edwards and dick cheney had met not once
but many times in fact they had sat in
tim russert's green room they had been
to prayer breakfast forever they have
tapes of dick cheney talking about john
edwards but
the best part of it was that that wasn't
the only lie
the other lie is i go up and i preside
over the senate every tuesday well if
you go to the senate's website you look
at who was the presiding officer on all
the tuesdays of this administration
you'll find i believe that there were
only two times that dick cheney actually
presided over the senate so here he was
saying you know boy john edwards you
don't show up you're irresponsible well
the the guy who's the boss of the senate
wasn't there except for two times and
then the final part of the lie my
favorite part is why dick cheney does go
up to capitol hill on tuesdays it isn't
to meet with the whole senate it's not
to say you know why my noble loyal
opposition let us discuss you know
politics and prose
no he goes up he goes up there to meet
in private session
with the republican caucus to give them
their marching orders for the week so no
he wouldn't have met john edwards unless
john edwards switched parties
in fact the only time he actually
interacts with members of the opposite
party on capitol hill is of course to
give friendly greetings to patrick leahy
but i
the fictions of dick cheney's service as
our
so-called vice president are are nothing
compared to the actual broader fiction
the one that that so few of us talk
about and that is the structure
of this administration and i always
remind people that if you just step back
from the current process and take a look
at it if you would if you had landed
here the proverbial martian and took a
look at this administration you would
have no question who was in charge it's
not a very complicated scenario
in july of 2000 dick cheney selected
himself to be the vice presidential
candidate on the republican ticket
then after
the florida debacle of 2000 but before
the supreme court had actually chosen
the next president
dick cheney flew into suburban virginia
and set up the transition office bush
was down there on the ranch and i do
believe that george bush actually
uttered the most honest statement of his
political career when during the florida
recount process a reporter asked him
well you know you must be very tense and
he said no not really you know if i if
if it doesn't work out i'll just come
back down here to texas and have a good
life and i think bush totally meant that
but you never heard any such line from
dick cheney he was up
in washington area you know kind of
bringing they said there was one
description dana milbank from the
washington post wrote a wonderful
description of cheney in the office i
believe it was moving where he was
sitting at a desk and he had a pile of
cell phones in front of him several land
lines computers all around i mean
because he was so con he was like in
constant motion and this was after he
had had one of his frequent heart
attacks
and yet no problem at all no slowdown
because this was a man who was taking
charge
choosing cabinet members
peopling the sub cabinet with folks who
he had worked with over 30 some years in
politics making this administration so
he picks himself to be vice president
then he does the transition ten days
into the administration what does he do
in the most energy obsessed
administration in the history of this
country
dick cheney becomes the head of the
energy task force
and of course meets in secret
but you know runs you know what is a key
initiative of this administration and
now we find out also that you know
goodness me what what a quirky
unexplainable thing they had maps of
iraq's oil fields that they were
reviewing for the energy task force who
would have thought
and so once they got done doing the
energy task force then he's up on
capitol hill the lead lobbyist for the
bush economic agenda the tax plans all
the the trade initiatives other deals
that they're working on always went bush
you know down on vacation you know on
vacation more than any president in
american history
uh campaigning more than any president
american history works out up to two
hours a day looking have you seen bush
recently
guy's in fabulous shape now cheney right
eating at the desk you know like always
on the run not getting to the gym as
much i mean let's let's be clear who's
got the the free time in this
administration
and then you get down to the heart of
the matter you know which is why don't
we know this why don't we why aren't
americans talking about this in a much
more detailed and invigorated and
engaged way well
far be it for me to criticize the media
i think jon stewart did that well last
week but but let me suggest you that we
have a media in this country that is you
know i'm telling you if they were by the
parade route
they would be the ones turning to the
little kid and saying no the king the
emperor he is clothed
honestly look that you just can't see
his lovely garments
and and it comes home in two recent
incidents during on the campaign trial
dick cheney is out campaigning as many
of you may be aware now he campaigns in
much the manner of brezhnev back in the
old soviet union
it's a it's a flight out to a very loyal
sort of uh you know well-organized state
in which he meets with the members of
the party central committee in a quiet
comfortable setting and has the you know
loyal toss and pravda traveling along to
take their notes uh no tough questions
the new york times by the way not
allowed on the
campaign plane they had a wonderful i
hope you saw it the wonderful story
about the new york times writer who
tried to keep up with cheney with planes
trains and automobiles because cheney
would let him on the plane
uh so very friendly press very friendly
audiences traveling around the country
and making you know the the reasoned
thoughtful pronouncements of of of a man
of state you know for instance um you
know
i don't trust john kerry to stand up for
our national security
i don't think he's committed to keeping
america safe
he has you know this incredible line
right you know it's like but of course
in a journal oh yes well the vice
president must have it's been sitting
around you know kind of going through
some paperwork analyzing things and come
to the conclusion that kerry just wasn't
trustworthy really that you couldn't
count on this guy to defend the united
states
and i thought you know this would have
been a for a somewhat more engaged media
it might have been an interesting point
at which to review
the track records of the two people in
play
you know i think john kerry
volunteers to go to vietnam then he goes
gets over there and he says no you know
i'm not in enough combat on this ship
off the shore i want to get on a swift
boat and go straight into the the enemy
fire i'd say that's john kerry okay you
know what this now he apparently vice
president's view is not committed enough
to defend the country but then here you
got our vice president who i mean you
know i assume any enterprising reporter
would ask as we do in the book um you
know
what did dick cheney do during the
vietnam war
and let me tell you something there's
nobody who's more committed to the
anti-draft movement than dick cheney
not actually for other people but for
himself uh
dick cheney had five deferments
during the vietnam war which is a pretty
pretty good track record there three of
them were student deferments and you
know he wasn't the first guy to get a
student deferment um not the best
student he did get kicked out of yale
and then he didn't finish his graduate
work at the university of wisconsin but
still you know kind of keep it in school
there and getting those deferments but
things got a little some of you who may
have somewhat of white hair may recall
that vietnam was not the most convenient
war
didn't work out perfectly kind of kept
needing more troops and as they needed
more troops they got a little tighter on
the student deferments and so the word
came down you know it might be a little
more convenient if you were married
you know student and married probably
less likely to get sent over and what a
wonderful coincidence within months
after the announcement that being
married would help you to get a a
stronger deferment
dick and lynn cheney succumbed to the
passions of their 10-year long
relationship and decided to marry
now war can do that to people
but
the the the final deferment that dick
cheney got was the most remarkable one
it was a child deferred it's a deferment
for a married individual who has a child
certainly very legitimate you don't want
to be sending fathers off to die in wars
and um
it was interesting because that the
announcement that that parents were not
likely to be drafted that that was going
to be one of your strongest performance
came on a particular day you know but
mid 60s there and nine months and two
days later
lynn cheney delivered their first child
coincidence you say
well maybe not the biggest coincidence
because two and a half months after lynn
cheney got pregnant when she was in her
first trimester dick cheney trooped down
to the draft board and requested the
child deferment
so
while we we now know two things that are
important about dick cheney he favors
preemptive war
and he also favors preemptive draft
evasion
that story was missing in this long
discussion about john kerry's vietnam
record why
because dick cheney doesn't like to be
covered by the media and he isn't
covered very often he isn't even covered
when he makes pronouncements
about
the physical danger that america will be
in if john kerry is elected this is a
big you know he said you know if john
cares i'm really kind of scared again
thoughtful reason analysis comes to the
conclusion if john kerry is elected i
think you know we're going to really
face the risk of attack once again his
reporters are out there taking their
notes oh the vice president has come to
the conclusion if john kerry is elected
we're going to be attacked in fact this
week he was out talking about nuclear
bombs if the other guys win it's getting
it was getting pretty serious
and you know the problem with that is
you would hope that some journalists and
and some do and i give great credit to
some wonderful journalists in fact so
many of them inform this book but you
think that a lot of our broadcast media
might want to take a little look at dick
cheney's judgment i mean is this the
kind of guy who could really reason
through these issues and come to the
conclusion that if the other guys win
we're really endangered and i always
like to remind folks of the pinnacle of
dick cheney's uh judgment which came in
the 1980s the late 1980s when the
congress of the united states was asked
to vote on a resolution urging the
reagan administration to do everything
in its power to
force south africa to release nelson
mandela from the apartheid prisons of
that country
and you know this was in the late 1980s
at a time when jack kemp
was calling nelson mandela a freedom
fighter when newt gingrich was referring
to him as a hero
and only a handful of mostly southern
members of congress voted against the
resolution calling for mandela's release
they were joined by dick cheney
not once but on every single resolution
calling for the united states to work
against apartheid or to work for the
release of nelson mandela dick cheney
voted no
why did he vote no because he said in
his reasoned judgment that this almost
70 year old man who had been in prison
for 27 years 28 29 30
was uh you know his terrorist and that
the the anc was a terrorist organization
and you had to you know you can't go
slack on it now man this is a very
serious fight
and that was not the only example of
bizarre misjudgment by dick cheney when
he was secretary of defense he didn't
like the fact that that schwarzkopf
schwarzkopf was a wimp in cheney's view
schwarzkopf didn't want to go into
baghdad so cheney spent millions of
dollars setting up a secret team within
his office to develop operation scorpion
the plan to invade baghdad it was a
detailed plan it was actually done
entirely by civilians there were no
military people involved and one of the
pr right about this book is one of the
one of the prime movers on the plan was
a guy who said he got a lot of his ideas
from lawrence of arabia
and so they come in with this big plan
and roll it out schwarzkopf is there
right before the war starts and um you
know all the generals are around getting
their first look at dick cheney's plan
to invade baghdad
and schwarzkopf and some of the others
say well you know it's a really
interesting plan there dick but you see
problem here is you'd get the entire you
know whole sections of the u.s military
out in the iraqi desert
um
without water because there's no supply
lines in this plan
i see it that that's not a good idea
wouldn't work and so they started all
the generals started explaining that how
it would be a total disaster it would be
one of the worst military moves ever and
so slowly that the plan is rolled up and
put away and dick and schwarzkopf writes
in one of in his uh autobiography that
working with dick cheney reminded me
of the danger that occurs when the
civilians try to out general the
generals
and again and again through his career
dick cheney's judgment has been
exceptionally questionable most recently
as regards the war in iraq
and in this book which uh which by the
way is reading on the way out you know i
was on the plane and i got to tell you
fine fine text you me
i don't know how the election's going to
turn out but i think it'd still make a
good christmas present um
but anyway so i'm reading through that
i'm reading through the book here and i
can't tell you how how much i enjoy
doing so um
but i closed the book off with an
analysis of the war
and i spent a lot of time talking about
how dick cheney was of course the prime
point man for this war not just the
prime point man in once the
administration came in power i invite
you to look back at the debates of 2000
when george bush
appeared in the debates and he said uh
you know i don't go in for this
nation-building stuff i don't think we
should be the policemen of the world
running around invading places you know
i we and bush actually said wonderful
statement says you know i really don't
think we can go to other countries and
tell them how to do things just because
we do them that way
all these statements they say well
that's the infinite nicest thing i heard
the guy say in all the debates
cheney on the other hand the vice
presidential debate talk for the better
part of 10 minutes about the need to do
something about iraq and to use deadly
force remarkable dichotomy so ask
yourself which guy got elected president
the one who didn't want to do nation
building didn't want to be the policeman
of the world or the guy
who
said we might have to use some deadly
force in iraq cheney
appeared just before the start of the
war
on
meet the press which is of course our
our official program for making public
pronouncements
and
i closed the book with a little section
as regards that appearance i meet the
press
again and again during the hour-long
interview
cheney said of the iraqi people they
will welcome us as liberators
this was cheney at the peak of his power
revealing as he had only briefly on
september 11
and during the days that followed that
he was fully in charge
he had the plan and he had the power to
implement it and for every sincere
concern that might be expressed he had a
false promise at the ready as the
interview progressed cheney made fewer
mentions of president bush he kept
saying we
with the hour winding down there were no
longer any mentions of bush and that we
was sounding more and more royal
finally russert asked whether fiscal
sense might argue for suspending a
proposed tax cut for the rich in order
to pay for the war
we don't believe that's the right course
of action tim this is one of those times
when as important as the war on terror
is
as important as the problem of iraq is
we've also got a lot of other balls in
the air cheney said and an american
president these days doesn't have the
choice of focusing on only one thing
dick cheney was by now the machiavelli
of his age having beaten his only
serious rival the pretender rumsfeld for
a place at the elbow of a boy king who
would ever defer to his regent
yet chaney had never bothered to develop
the knowledge or the ability to honestly
assess information that would have
allowed him to rule wisely
the fatal flaw in cheney's schemes had
turned out to be cheney
34 years after he had arrived in
washington as barely an intern
he had made himself the most powerful
man in the city and the world beyond
he had the authority to decide between
peace and war and he had chosen war
not because it was necessary not because
but because it satisfied his needs
politically economically and emotionally
now people would die
soldiers contractors civilians
the violence would over time swell
those who were supposed to greet
americans as liberators would take up
arms
and the promise of greater security from
terrorism which cheney had made with
such assurance
would come to be seen as the absurd
boast of a man so desperate to begin a
war that he never stopped to consider
its consequences
there would need to be an accounting and
in the spring of 2004 it was demanded
having heard richard clark's charge that
the administration had been more
obsessed with regime change in iraq
than with taking the necessary steps to
combat terrorism which was again
surfacing in the form of bombings that
had left more than 200 spaniards dead
the members of the national commission
on terrorist attacks on the united
states had prevailed upon the president
to meet with them in secret
but the president would not appear on
his own he would come with dick cheney
at his side
it was a necessary pairing white house
aides acknowledged and the commission
accepted that george w bush could not
provide answers to the most basic
questions about the rationale for the
war on iraq let alone how it related to
the war on terrorism
iraq was not his project
he was to be sure responsible
as the war had been waged in his name
but how could he explain that which he
had not conceived and had never fully
understood
for that the commission would need to
hear from dick cheney
of all the powers afforded to the man
who occupies the oval office
none is more awesome than the authority
to lead the most powerful nation in the
world to war
yet george w bush who had campaigned for
president as a reluctant warrior who did
not want to be the world's policeman
had only placed a seal of approval on
another man's plan to launch a
preemptive war against a distant land
this was not bush's war this was
cheney's war
and because of that this was not george
w bush's presidency
it was dick cheney's
when school children go to the backs of
their american history books they
encounter charts that list the
presidents and vice presidents of the
united states
but the facts of america's decision to
go to war with iraq in the spring of
2003 made a lie of those charts and
history itself is threatened
so let it be recorded here that in the
first years of the 21st century
at a time when american faith in itself
had been shaken
the white house became a place of dark
and dangerous intrigues
the oval office was occupied by a weak
and disengaged president in name only
but the authority of the presidency
up to and including the power to plan
and wage war
was gripped by an unrelentingly
ambitious yet tragically ill-prepared
man named richard bruce chaney
dick
the man who is president
thank you i entertain your questions
or i'll stand here uncomfortably
let me turn to this woman first and then
i i believe we're asked to use the
microphone if we can because we have
our friends here filming do you
anticipate
no matter which
of the candidates wins the election that
there may be any investigations
after
after the election that might lead to
any criminal charges against
uh against cheney and others in the
administration it's a wonderful question
and and you know one thing to be aware
of is there are already many
investigations in play
dick cheney has been investigated by the
sec and in halliburton as well there
have been all sorts of other other
investigations into aspects of his
service henry waxman who is to my mind
one of the handful of members of
congress who actually takes seriously
the duty that the founders of this
country
laid upon members of congress which is
to keep an eye on the executive has if
you go to his website and i recommend it
it's just packed with information that
would form the basis for a terrific
investigation but i have to tell you in
the ugly partisan period in which we
live
it is unlikely that there will be any
serious investigations of this
administration
unless we have a change in the control
of the united states senate it is really
as simple as that and and that's a
tragedy because i will tell you i i mean
you can criticize republicans democrats
i think there are some wonderful
republicans in congress i have high
regard for lincoln chafee for richard
luger uh even for people i might
disagree with on some issues like hegel
and mccain there are republicans there
who are willing to do an investigation
unfortunately
they are not in the positions of power
to advance it and this senate is so
controlled i don't see that happening i
will tell you why it is such a tragedy
though
remember that the vietnam war
was investigated by the senate i mean
that that senate tore that war open
particularly fulbright's foreign
relations committee and it was democrats
who were in the lead of investigating
the wrongs of a democratic president
the crime the tragedy in this country
today is that republicans have at least
up to this point been unwilling to hold
their own president and vice president
accountable for acts that any good
american citizen knows deserve
investigation i'll close off with one
final point on this too hope folks have
been noticing the endorsement pattern of
newspapers around the country many of
the most conservative newspapers in the
united states ha that that endorsed
george bush in 2000 have refused to
endorse him for reelection this time
out in the countryside there are many
conservatives who see the flaws in this
administration this is not a liberal or
conservative thing this is not a
republican or democrat thing this is an
administration that has gone
far far astray both of its duties and
also
of the laws and traditions of this
country and republicans should be in the
forefront of investigating it
could you say a little bit about
cheney's relationship with the
professional military particularly the
chairman of the joint chiefs and the
joint chiefs and also with the
professionals in the central
intelligence agency sure they don't like
them
oh no you had a little more detail i
appreciate that all right
now some of the best sources for this
book are our military folks um and some
of the most wonderful quotes in it you
know dick cheney served as secretary of
defense
and when he served as secretary of
defense
uh he had one of his first acts was to
tell colin powell you stay in your place
and in fact it was very blunt
uh message from cheney that he was going
to be in charge of the department of
defense and that paul over at joint
chiefs you know that was you know you
just keep out of my way and it was a
very it was a tense relationship it
remains a tense relationship to this day
you know that if you read robert
woodward's book which i you know if you
have to um
but if you read robert woodward's book
you will see in it that there are
uh there's a lot of detail about the
terrible relations between cheney and
powell to this day
and that's rooted back to the the late
1980s early 1990s uh one important thing
to understand uh cheney as secretary of
defense
used that position in some absolutely
troubling ways that troubled the
generals they were very very bothered by
what was going on with his secret
planning for extending the war in iraq
but also that satisfied an awfully lot
of people in the business community
because dick cheney was in the forefront
of efforts to privatize the military in
the latter days of his service the
secretary of defense he put out bids for
proposals for analysis on how to
privatize a lot of military activities
things that were done by soldiers and he
hired a fascinating
who
take a guess what company hired to to do
the
crazy but brown and rude a subsidiary of
halliburton right brown and road yeah
and they and you know amazingly enough
they came back with a report that said
it's a really good idea to privatize a
lot of the military
and the first contracts were let to
brown and root subsidiary of halliburton
and we now if you look at iraq right now
and you want to understand a lot of the
crisis in iraq it is that all sorts of
things that used to be done by soldiers
who were armed and who were trained to
do serious work
has now been taken over by contractors
who are paid a lot of money to do really
awful things
and you know war costs more
it is less efficient it's a bigger mess
because of privatization of the military
i'm not the one saying this there are
generals and colonels and lieutenant
colonels saying this very bluntly i've
got a lot of them quote in the book and
that privatization process routes back
to cheyney so there's an awful lot of
people in the military who have real
objections to how this guy has related
them to them for a long time finally
just on the cia reference
the folks over the cia actually
complained about cheney
they they complained to the house
intelligence committee they said look
cheney keeps coming over here requesting
different briefing officers because he
can't get one of them to tell him that
there are weapons of mass destruction
and uh an iraq al-qaeda connection he
wants certain things to be told him and
when he doesn't hear it he demands
another briefing officer and i've got in
the book the letter that was sent to
cheney by a number of members of the
house intelligence committee telling him
to back off the cia
i'm amazed it still amazes me that that
wasn't a front-page story broadly
covered all over this country i wish i
could tell you this great investigative
report i'm not it's easy to find this
stuff it's all there
the problem is that cheney has been so
little covered that most people don't
know that members of the congress
demanded that he back off in these
unreasonable demands on the cia to make
up
information about iraq
sir
thank you very much for wonderful talk
uh if the unthinkable happens and cheney
and bush are re-elected
what ambitions do you think cheney will
have for the next four years what what
what
ambitions
very good
people often ask me you know it's like
after they read the book they become
convinced that cheney really is going to
run for president in 2008
i don't think it's going to happen i i
think dick cheney throughout his entire
career has been exceptionally satisfied
to play precisely the role that he is
playing
he you know when he was in the ford
administration they called him backseat
because he always got in the back seat
with the powerful guy and sat next to
him if it was ford he was right there
next to him and and i think that's
always what he's like to be he's like to
be the guy next to the powerful figure
making things happen now cheney did
briefly run for president in 1993 1994
and to the immense credit of the
republican party
they took a serious look at him and said
we're not running you we want somebody
exciting like bob dole
[Laughter]
but uh but the fact is you know cheney
knows he's not running for president he
pulls way below
right below george bush and i think he's
very satisfied with the role that he's
in now his ambition for a second term
though is very blunt
and i know people i can't believe this
debate we got going on whether the
republicans are in favor of privatizing
social security of course they are it's
in their platform you know they're like
saying oh that's unfair to charge us
with it no it's in their platform this
is their program give dick cheney and
george bush another term and they will
spend immense amounts of money on iraq
and other foreign ambitions they will
lower taxes for the rich and they will
have no money left to
run anything else in the government and
so then they will say you know hey we've
got this crazy idea for how to balance
the books let's privatize social
security
and that will become an immense pressure
in the second term i mean this is again
it is only in some sort of fantastical
alice in wonderland moment that anyone
would debate whether that is part of the
agenda of course it is because
we're broke
and uh they have been dipping into the
social security funds forever not them
the democrats do so i mean the pressure
there in the second term is going to be
pretty clear
sir connection with the last question um
during the vice presidential debate mr
senator edwards said that
it's true that kerry voted against some
weapon systems but those were the same
ones that
secretary of defense uh
the secretary of defense cheney uh
sought to uh kill is that one of the
reasons that generals didn't like him um
actually no that wasn't that wasn't the
core reason the reason that the generals
uh had a real objection with dick cheney
was that he didn't really seem to work
very well with generals remember he
wasn't a man he's not a military man he
had no background in the military he had
as we noted before been very meticulous
about avoiding contact with other
soldiers during the vietnam war
and and their problem with him was that
he seemed to be more passionate
about sort of the business aspect
of of running the military than the
military aspect of it and so you had the
privatization stuff you also had you
know i got to tell you i spent i grew up
in a military family i've spent my
father served in the in the air force
for decades and and i spent a lot of
time around military folks they're not
happy warriors
most people in the military are very
sensible about you know when
particularly career military about when
we ought to go to war and what we ought
to do and an awful lot of military folks
are exceptionally uncomfortable with the
project for a new american century and
all of these sort of adventure plans for
how you know we're going to assert
ourselves around the world and cheney
when he was secretary of defense was so
engaged with this way of thinking that i
think he really did put off a lot of
military folks and and i think it was
very much to their credit again i think
if the generals were in charge uh we
would not be fighting in iraq today
sir
how do you explain that cheney and the
administration have gotten such a free
shot
at not having to explain
why they were unprepared for 9 11
and why they had to give secret and
joint testimony to the 911 commission
yeah i know look i you know come on it's
only louis carroll must be raised from
the dead to explain you know how the
media the united states said oh cheney's
going to appear with bush that's cool
you know i mean what this is an
absurdity i mean and do you know that
gerald ford and gerald ford was not
exactly viewed as the rocket scientist
president of all time but gerald ford
went to the congress of the united
states to explain the nixon pardon he
sat there on his own in front of a bunch
of angry people at a time when it was
exceptionally unpopular and he took the
heat in public with the television
cameras on
this guy
bush won't even do it in private
and he brings his vice president with
him so i i think it's a it's an
exceptionally problematic situation and
the bigger problem to me is again the
the failure to look seriously at how
this administration is structured i
think that's an american problem not a
not just a media problem or not just a
bush administration problem
we are far less comfortable in this
country with looking at the allocation
of power and and realizing that it that
it's not always in the hands of the
person we elected
it makes us very uncomfortable because
we're taught and i was in my little
school in union grove wisconsin we're
taught that this is a democracy we
choose our leaders and so it's
discomforting to us to see that the
power may rest elsewhere and in
different places and yet
it does
and so as a people we have a
responsibility to be much more
aggressive in looking at you know who
holds what power who's doing what and i
will tell you something this book is out
in europe and in canada and other places
when i do interviews on with european
interviews i was on austrian radio the
other day and i've done cbc in canada a
whole bunch and you know when i do
foreign folks they get it completely
they're used to a cabinet form of
government they say yes of course we
understand sometimes you'll have a weak
but attractive prime minister but then a
really powerful chancellor of the
exchequer behind him or you know someone
else this is how it works it's
understand americans we still live in
the fantasy that our presidents are
these superhuman figures who are in
charge of everything that goes on we
ourselves need to break that fantasy we
need to recognize that that just is not
the reality and then we need to demand a
media that reports to us in detail on
reality rather than on you know this
lingering fantasy of the strong man
president who can do everything
my friend
hi thank you very much for your talk in
your book uh i picked it up about three
four days ago
and was musing over this book because
i've been saying for probably three
years that i wanted to create a bumper
sticker you've heard it here first if
you ever see it that says bush a
heartbeat away from the presidency
and i feel vindicated now
[Laughter]
you know you're not supposed to upstage
the author at the reading
but um uh in any case be that as it may
um
one thing that you didn't touch on here
and i hadn't had a chance to read in the
book yet
is
there not one of those people who stayed
up all night reading all the way through
no because i have other really good
books that i probably would be
recommending i'm just glad i didn't
write about bush so you know because
there's like a hundred of them but like
just can i just interrupt them yeah
there's one woman a friend of mine who
who uh who i gave the book to this
friend of mine and her daughter picked
it up she's not real political but she
just started reading it and she said
after like three nights she was having
these nightmares about cheney chasing
her
and i took that as the ultimate
compliment you know
anyways well no i mean i didn't read it
because i'm scared no i made a decision
that before i go to bed i don't read
comedies or tragedies
and that's what that is um no
so there are many lines of what what's
going on there's the privatization
military which i had been speaking about
with friends of mine for some time as i
had observed um
developing if you will um there's the
privatization of the government
the uh the usurpation of the gover of
the of the democratic process but
very worrisome is something which i'm
wondering what role cheyney has in it
and that is the the wholesale
obliteration of parts of the
constitution
and you know i i guess i fear that the
only amendment the constitution in the
next three or four years that'll be paid
any attention to is the one they're
trying to push through to have no
marriage between men and i'm wondering
now
if
that's because they want to make sure
that that can't be an exclusion for
males if there's a draft but anyway
[Laughter]
whoa things go bad enough we may have
gays in the military uh
um my friend i will direct you
uh to uh there's i actually have a
section on this
and i it it deals with uh mr cheney's
congressional service it's titled
contempt for congress and uh my friend
and
the hero john dean the the watergate uh
not hero well he said it was a hero
watergate but former nixon
administration council is informed my
knowledge of how the white house works
so much and uh one of the things that
and he's written a lot about this as
well and and one of the things that dean
points out and that i really spend a lot
of time exploring is cheney's absolute
contempt for the separation of powers
you know one of the things is we think
of the constitution as only the ten
amendments at the end you know or the
well the initial amendments and then all
the ones we've added over the years but
but the fact is the constitution is
actually a very good structure for how a
government ought to work in many ways
you know you didn't that madison and
jefferson didn't want one individual to
have too much power madison warned if
you read back in madison's writings the
man warned with a passion about how war
was the the tool of executive
aggrandizement he didn't like wars
because he said if you have them
presidents will seize too much power
into their office they will use fear to
become more dominant and so the founders
of this country oh hold it that's
the founders were very conscious of this
stuff and the constitution is a
wonderful document in that regard and
dick cheney just despises
all of those aspects of the constitution
that suggests that you might want to
consult with congress
now he was the one back in 1990 who
advised
his the former president bush not to go
to congress for permission to
go into kuwait and then if they had to
go into iraq he didn't want to do that
he said don't and this is a guy who had
just come out of congress
he was also the guy who led the defense
of the reagan administration during the
iran contra investigations and if you go
back and read the things he wrote during
iran contra they will blow your mind i
mean because here all republicans warren
rudman all these guys are saying you
know look
we have you know we've got to clean this
mess up you can't be like trading drugs
for you know weapons and it's not good
you know
i mean and and yet dick cheney the if
you read the minority report that he put
on in on a rant contract it is full of
stuff like saying you know we just can't
be stomping on the president's power
here you know we gotta we gotta step
back and he was terrified by the idea of
congress actually asserting its
constitutionally defined role so i i
don't want to be too arcane here but i
do want to suggest that if you really
want to explore the most dangerous
aspect of this administration it is not
the patriot act although i think that's
incredibly dangerous and i'm proud to
come from wisconsin where russ feingold
was the only senator to vote against the
patriot act but i want to tell you
something the most dangerous part of
this administration is the fuzzing of
all those lines and and the really
elimination of the structures that give
congress the power to oversee the white
house and you know somebody else asked
about when is the investigation is going
to come
this administration has done more than
any administration in history in fact
john dean says much more than nixon
to
weaken the ability of congress to make
sure that a president does not go out of
control and i would suggest to you that
this war in iraq alone is the evidence
that this administration has gone out of
control
sir
yes um probably more than any time in my
life there's less to trust it seems like
and
from the media as well as from the
politicians but i wonder if you have any
insights on
this issue that came up recently about
the draft uh what do you think that
cheney and his crowd will do about that
we know the change against the draft
this for himself right yeah right well
he's over age now yeah that's true well
you never know
and the second thing uh are there any
secret wars out there that we haven't
heard about yet
oh yeah the secret wars all the time
brother i mean we've got troops spread
around this yeah keep to take the last
part of your question first we've got
troops you know we keep saying we don't
have enough troops for iraq there's a
reason we don't have enough troops for
iraq we've got a heck of a lot of troops
spread all over this planet in you know
every seems like just about every place
that's got stan on the end of its name
has some us troops sitting there and i
wonder you know why would that be could
it possibly be because there's a whole
bunch of oil in all those former soviet
states
but no so secret wars are in the
offering all over the place i don't
think it's north korea or iran i i think
it's
i if if i was a member of the
assad family in syria i'd be a little
scared because there seems to be a lot
of they keep making a lot of noise there
but i also i think the former soviet
states all those stands uh with a lot of
oil and a lot of muslims it looked like
the kind of places that this
administration would be very interested
in so that's where i'd focus a lot of my
attention uh the first part about the
draft the draft is a weird issue it's a
weird issue that has sort of arisen
toward the end of this campaign in
honesty we have to accept that it is
being driven the issue's being driven
into the dialogue by
uh
many progressive folks howard dean and
the move on folks and others who believe
it's a serious issue and they have
they've kind of raised it to a higher
level than it certainly was during the
primaries or or the conventions i i i'm
dubious about a draft i have to be
honest with you i really am dubious
about i'll tell you why
i think if you started drafting people
this war in iraq would end in about five
minutes
because
you know i
believe the soldiers over there
you know i i i'd love to see the the
actual ballot count from the soldiers in
iraq because i think a lot of them would
vote for a ticket home
and and so i think a draft is something
that a bush administration or a kerry
administration would try very very hard
to avoid the only way we get to a draft
in my opinion
is if we
have a another very serious terrorist
incident
and some sort of clear you know
direction for a response whether
legitimate or not but you know that's
where i would see the possibility of a
draft but i don't see it i just find
very hard to imagine they're going to
draft people to maintain the occupation
of iraq which is already so dramatically
impossible i or i'm popular i think that
would tip the balance and and i and i
think to them to bush and cheney
particularly cheney maintaining the iraq
initiative
is more important than doing the iraq
initiative right and so while a draft
might get them a lot of troops and help
to make it a more stable situation i
don't think that's the direction they
would go
please
do you think we've seen so many of the
lines blurred
will that one to push the button
uh the nuclear uh attack do you think
they're capable of that the lines
blurred do you mean between
between uh preemptive strike and oh yeah
i i i think that the the when we
launched a preemptive war
remember this country has done
preemptive wars in the past it's just
that we had the dignity to lie about it
and when we launched this preemptive war
without apology
and without the suggestion that there
was legitimate
some legitimacy to it
i i think we we crossed a very dangerous
line and i think it would be ridiculous
to assume that there's any aspect
of military power military intervention
military action that isn't in play i
don't think that's the way that this
administration thinks of it at all i
think they think that once you have the
right to launch a preemptive war you
have the right to do it in all the forms
that you might choose to do and there's
nothing in dick cheney's record which is
pretty detailed on a lot of this stuff
that would suggest differently
bush said a preemptive strike uh with
incomplete information that was his
statement
in the beginning and so i mean we should
we could do a whole another couple hours
on that i don't know how we're doing
time wise
please my dear yeah i said when myself
i'm interesting to know what happened
with the woman behind this man because
yes very good question thank you uh lynn
cheney uh a fascinating figure and i do
got a little chapter on lynn cheney i
you know
remember a guy who names his book dick
is not gonna you know always be mr
responsible so i i i did kind of detail
her writings her her wonderful lesbian
novel that she did back in the early 80s
sisters
um and there are some amazing tracks
from that book let me tell you uh she i
wouldn't suggest that lynching is the
greatest writer in the world but
man
certainly entertaining in some ways
and but this is i joke about lynn cheney
the fact of the matter is she's super
bright she is one of the smartest people
around politics in this country i've
interviewed her professors in fact i've
interviewed some professors who had her
and who actually and who knew dick as
well and let's just say
the smart one isn't the vice president
lynn cheney is is a super bright super
talented woman uh could easily have been
vice president herself uh could easily
have done this ride up herself i mean
remember hillary clinton never held an
elective office until 2000 when she was
elected to the u.s senate now we all
talk about it being president well lynn
cheney
very easily i could have seen a scenario
where she went back to wyoming got
elected to the senate and wasn't played
she's that skillful and that talented
and we saw her talents and skills as a
politician
uh just the other day
when um
the you know he had in the debate uh
senator kerry brought up their daughter
the the cheney's daughter and mentioned
that she was a lesbian i you know i
gotta be honest i think mention it's
there's no bigger minefield in politics
than mentioning the family of your
opponent and i think that for kerry it
was a foolish move
by the same token i don't think it was
some sort of big you know an issue it
wasn't like he was outing her i mean she
was coors beers
she was the coors beer gang lesbian
outreach director and now she's a member
of the the bush cheney campaign staff i
mean it's not like this woman isn't one
of the most prominent lesbians in
america
but uh but i think that kerry may have
made a mistake but the incredible thing
was
watch what lynn cheney did she was out
there at a rally
within minutes after the debate finished
making this bold statement about how as
a mother i'm you know i'm a i'm an
angered mother and how dare you do this
and he's all these you know tawdry and
using all those words well the fact is
that was a brilliant political move and
it wasn't dick making that move it
wasn't the bush cheney team making this
was minutes after it so who had the the
smarts to go in and spin this thing in a
way that actually was quite effective
politically it was lynn cheney she is a
very bright figure she is an absolutely
essential figure to dick cheney's
success without any doubt
my friend
why do you think no one has uh mentioned
impeachment
the impeachment work well we got to
re-elect him first before we can impeach
him right uh
no i mean
oh i'm sorry this woman says reelected
here i wrote a book called juice for
buchanan about the florida disaster and
all the uh all the elderly garment
workers trade unionists and holocaust
survivors who voted for pat buchanan for
president in that in that very
well-organized florida vote of 2000. so
you're right reelect is a let's say
re-select but bottom line is
uh
impeachment won't come into play as a
serious discussion unless these guys get
a a second term
if it does i think there will be some
dialogue about it in fact one member of
congress
congressman costello from illinois did
look at some of the halliburton and
other business dealings and say publicly
that he felt as a member of congress
who's dealt a lot in business areas that
there was the grounds for impeachment
there and that it ought to be
investigated and looked into
certainly henry waxman and others have
gathered the information and i will tell
you you give me such a good close off
for this event here because
unfortunately oh i do have it um the pin
the our little new press which is a
wonderful publishing uh enterprise led
by andre schifrin and colin robinson
some other great films
they to promote the book they did have a
pin that says impeach cheney first
and uh let's be clear if we're going to
start the impeachments you do want to
get rid of him before you get rid of
bush because of course the making of
president cheney really you know let's
say right now he's president enough
already
thank you so much for joining us tonight
i really enjoy it very much
thank you
john nichols is washington correspondent
for nation magazine he's the author of
jews for buchanan his latest dick the
man who is president is published by
then.com and click on books
halliburton came under renewed scrutiny
tuesday when auditors urged the defense
department to hold back payments of
nearly 160 million dollars for allegedly
over charging for meals in iraq in
thousand three
wednesday the company held its annual
meeting in houston amid protesters
next on book tv dan briote looks at the
history of the company and its
relationship to vice president dick
cheney in discussing his new book the
halliburton agenda
this is an hour
good evening
i'm lisa joyce gorski the executive
director of the federal city club if
you're not familiar with the federal
city club i encourage you to visit our
website www.federalcityclub.com
in the meantime i'll summarize
the federal city club was founded in
1963
to protest the racially oppressive
practices of other washington d.c clubs
now it's in its 41st year the federal
city club remains nonpartisan and
racially inclusive
our members are professionals from
diverse backgrounds
education training careers interests
viewpoints
and points on the political spectrum
our programs reflect
our keen interest in public affairs
from kenneth starr
to john dean
from eugene mccarthy
to dick thornberg
from tucker carlson to eleanor clift
our speakers are public
figures
and thought leaders
our programs are smart
provocative and spirited
tonight promises to be no exception
to introduce our speaker
i would like to now turn the podium over
to the federal city club's vice
president allison adler
dan bryode is the author of the national
bestseller the iron triangle inside the
carlisle group
the secret world of the carlisle group
an award-winning business journalist he
has written for forbes
wired
red herring and the industry standard
he has appeared on numerous radio and
television programs as an expert on the
co-mingling of business and politics
particularly as it pertains to the war
on terrorism and the military industrial
complex he lives in connecticut
and now i present the author of the
halliburton agenda
the politics of oil and
money
dan briote dan
[Applause]
thanks everyone thank you allison
i appreciate everybody coming out
tonight and i expect that we'll have
some lively discussion
i want to talk about
four things from the book i'm going to
read from the book a little bit to give
you a sense of what it is that i'm
talking about but
there are four main things that are
covered in the book
that i think are the most important
takeaways
one is the history of the company which
i think is critical
uh when you're trying to put the events
of the past three years into context
we've all read a lot about
halliburton in the news
over the past three years since the war
began and
there hasn't been a lot of understanding
of this company what do they do
why are they so controversial why are we
reading about them
so much so i'm going to try to put some
of that into context
with their history
also
i think i would be remiss if we didn't
look at the parallels between this
conflict and vietnam
and the role that
halliburton and its subsidiary kellogg
brown enroute played in both of those
wars
we're also going to talk about dick
cheney a little bit
who was the ceo of the company from 1995
to 2000
and finally i'm going to touch a little
bit on the military industrial complex
what is it what does it mean
and why should we should be concerned
with that
so
i'll start off
with a little reading that'll give you a
sense of the history of the company
and we'll go from there
though dick cheney took the game to a
new level it's always been played this
way at least by kbr kellogg brown and
root the subsidiary of halliburton that
is attracting all the political
attention with its role in the two
billion dollar accounting contract to
rebuild iraq's oil infrastructure
kbr was first formed then called brown
and root in 1919 and the company was a
political animal from the very beginning
building roads in rural central texas
hermann and george brown learned early
how to influence public officials in
pursuit of lucrative county contracts
their relentless and brazen brand of
politicking evolved steadily over the
years and culminated in their
relationship with lyndon johnson an
unprecedented business and political
association that propelled both the
browns and johnson to the tops of their
respective professions
yet the story of halliburton and more
accurately kbr
is more than just a tale of the
confluence of business and politics in
america it is also the story of how
government contracting and outsourcing
has evolved over the past 100 years and
how the military came to advocate the
privatization trend
what we are seeing today in iraq
the secret letting of no-bid contracts
the strange and arcane bureaucracy
behind military outsourcing the army's
dangerous dependency on kbr
all can be explained by following the
trajectory of kbr from its early days of
navy shipbuilding in world war ii to its
role in building airstrips and prisoner
cells in vietnam
the cycles of kbr's war business are
repetitive but distinct
during world war ii no one criticized
the company for the role he played in
supporting the war effort
vietnam brought with it heavy criticism
from the anti-war anti-profiteering
element but little talk of the company's
ties to prominent politicians
the iraq war has cast a light on the
potential for politicians to influence
the government contracting process
so that's just a quick overview of uh
what kbr and haliburton have been
through over the past 80 years both
companies were formed in 1920
and both companies started in texas
and
brown and root in particular
had
an astounding relationship with lyndon
johnson that lasted the better part of
40 years
they bankrolled many of his campaigns um
all of his campaigns actually except for
the first congressional campaign uh and
uh contin and in turn lyndon johnson
sent many many very lucrative contracts
into the hands of brown and root
including
dams
including
work in vietnam navy shipbuilding doing
during world war ii
and also
an incredible story that's that's in the
book but i won't get into about a
project called project mohol
which literally was uh designed to drill
a hole all the way through the crust of
the earth and pierce the mantle um and
this was done for scientific reasons
ultimately it did not work out and part
of that was because
it was a political
decision to to give the business to
brown root in the first place
interestingly donald rumsfeld was the
young congressman from illinois who
pointed out the relationship between
lyndon johnson and brown and root at the
time which ultimately scuttled the whole
deal
so we see him
now on the other side of the fence
i'm going to read a little bit about
brown and root in vietnam
and i think that
if you've been following the news about
the contract in iraq and halliburton's
work in iraq
you will hear a lot of terms and see a
lot of similarities between
vietnam and iraq
at least in terms of the role that brown
and route played there
in 1965 a year after johnson stepped up
america's participation in vietnam
brown and root joined three other
construction and pr and project
management behemoths raymond
international morris knudsen and j.a
jones to form one of the largest
civilian-based military construction
conglomerates in history
the group which came to be known
collectively as rmk brj
went on to do more than two billion
dollars worth of work in vietnam of
which brown and root took a 20 cut
the contract was a cost plus 1.7 percent
contract meaning that the consortium
would be reimbursed all costs plus an
additional 1.7 percent profit
a method of contracting that encourages
the contractor to markedly increase
costs thereby increasing their profit
the world would be reintroduced to this
concept nearly 40 years later when
kellogg brown and route won the same
type of contract in iraq
even as early as 1966 reports started
reaching back to the homeland that the
united states was pouring money into a
civ called vietnam
one study by the new york times found
that nearly 40 percent of the billions
being spent in vietnam was being stolen
used in bribes or outright wasted at the
rate of half a million dollars a day
rmkbrj came under fire for not kiting
costs and wasting upwards of five
million dollars in its first year in the
country
its workers were manipulating currency
and selling goods on the black market
dozens of employees were sent home as
punishment
by 1968 when most of the country had
grown weary of the war
senator abraham a ribikoff a democrat
from connecticut filed a report with the
senate's permanent subcommittee on
investigations alleging kickbacks in the
construction consortiums in vietnam
claiming that millions were being quote
squandered because of inefficiency
dishonesty corruption and foolishness
and quote
he ordered an immediate general
accounting office investigation into
rmkbrj
the gao investigation completed in 1967
charged rmk brj with losing 120 million
dollars during its first five years in
vietnam
it said that quote normal management
controls were virtually abandoned end
quote and that millions were lost due to
lack security
after decades of receiving accolades
from government agencies and the
military brown enroute was coming under
fire for wastefulness and inefficiency
the pentagon actually acknowledged some
of the blame in 1966 admitting that it
had misled the contractor lowballing the
estimated costs of the construction
but by 1968 johnson's last year as
president rmkbrj was significantly
scaling back its operations to about
fifteen thousand employees the public
impression was that brown and root was
part of a war profiteering machine that
monopolized work in vietnam mistreated
workers and wasted millions of taxpayers
dollars
so
the gao is again investigating
brown and root or kellogg brown and ruth
the subsidiary of halliburton that's
doing the majority of the work in iraq
there are again charges of of waste and
overages
and a lack of institutional control
it's a very very similar situation to
what we saw 40 years ago
and i think that
many people are coming at this
fresh and have never heard of
halliburton before and rightfully so i
mean the company is an oil field
services company it's not exactly the
the stuff of the front page
but at the same time this is a company
that has been in and out of the news
for the past 80 years
in an almost cyclical and predictable
fashion
so let's
move on to dick cheney
dick cheney was ceo of halliburton
between 1995 and 2000.
when he left to become george w bush's
vice presidential running mate
it was thought that he had done a
wonderful job at halliburton the company
certainly loved him
he received a 30 million dollar
severance package he is still receiving
deferred salary payments from the
company
on an annual basis of about 150 000
a year i think this year was 175 000
and so the relationship between dick
cheney and the company uh still
continues to stay he's still in touch
with the executives over there and
they value his opinion
but what he did while he was ceo um was
in fact very much in misunderstood
uh one of his
biggest tasks as ceo was the acquisition
of dresser industries um
and that turned out to be an absolutely
disastrous uh acquisition it saddled the
company with uh close to four billion
dollars worth of asbestos liability much
of which should have been
uncovered uh during the due diligence
process before the company was acquired
he also changed accounting rules
within the company and failed to inform
shareholders in a timely fashion that
has resulted in an ongoing sec
investigation of the company
but and let me begin reading at this
point uh far more disconcerting though
is the work that the company has done in
iraq
the country against which dick cheney
waged war twice during his career in
public office
between stints as secretary of defense
and vice president while cheney was ceo
of halliburton
he helped to rebuild iraq and enrich
saddam hussein
circumventing strict sanctions and
putting money into the pockets of
america's public enemy number one
in 1996 a un program called oil for food
was created as a way to provide
humanitarian relief to iraqi citizens
while keeping in place the international
economic sanctions against iraq and the
saddam hussein regime
the idea was to allow iraq to export its
precious oil in exchange for
humanitarian aid
everything from first aid and medical
supplies to the most basic food and
water requirements
there were strict there were
restrictions on the type of goods that
could be imported by iraq
anything deemed even remotely for
military use was strictly prohibited it
seemed that the world had devised a
clever way to obtain the much needed oil
of iraq without shouldering the
burdensome crisis of conscience
associated with doing business with a
brutal murdering dictator
not surprisingly the oil for food
program was exploited for personal gain
on both sides of the deal making
the council for international justice in
a september 2002 report estimated that
for every six billion dollars a year
iraq earned from the oil for food
program saddam hussein made two billion
he used this money for everything from
luxury goods to weapons and training for
his military
oil for food was the main source of
income for iraq
but the system was rife with corruption
skimming schemes and kickbacks
worse the united states was consuming 75
percent of the oil exported from iraq
under the program
the oil for food program was so
thoroughly corrupt that it was reduced
to a punchline
general tommy franks the u.s commander
of forces in iraq called it quote oil
for palaces end quote
saddam hussein and his sons were growing
richer by the day exploiting the poorly
audited program by providing substandard
services for its people and pocketing
the rest
it is estimated that of the 57 billion
dollars the country earned through the
oil for food program only 23 billion of
it was spent on humanitarian goods
that comes to about 170 dollars per
person per year
or less than the united nations spends
on dog food for mine clearing operations
it was through this program that
halliburton did business with iraq
between 1998 and 2000 the years that
dick cheney was ceo
in september 1998 halliburton closed on
its 7.7 billion dollar stock merger with
dresser industries the company that gave
george h.w bush his first job the merger
made halliburton the largest oil field
services firm in the world
it also brought with the two foreign
subsidiaries that were doing business
with iraq through the controversial oil
for food program
the two subsidiaries dresser rand an
ingersoll dresser pump company signed 73
million dollars worth of contracts for
oil production equipment while cheney
was ceo
cheney told the press during his 2000
run for vice president that he had a
quote firm policy end quote against
doing business with iraq
he admitted to doing business with iran
and libya
but iraq's different he said
originally cheney denied the business
ties to baghdad outright telling abc tv
in the summer of 2000 that quote we've
not done any business in iraq since u.n
sanctions were opposed on iraq in 1990
and i have a standing policy that i
wouldn't do that end quote
executives at both subsidiaries said
later that no such policy existed
three weeks later cheney was forced to
admit to the business to the business
ties but claimed ignorance
he told reporters that he was not aware
of dresser's business in iraq and that
besides halliburton had divested itself
from both companies by 2000 in the
meantime the companies did another 30
million dollars worth of business in
iraq before they were sold off
but ignorance of the contracts
was also ruled out as an as an excuse as
cheney was forced in the uncomfortable
position of either admitting he didn't
know his company was trading with saddam
hussein or that he just didn't care
now
halliburton and
kellogg brown and roone are extremely
political companies and that comes with
the territory of being an international
firm
and the type of business that they do
so you may be wondering if you know
anything about dick cheney's history um
and his resume you may be wondering how
he became the ceo of a company like this
in the first place
he had literally zero business
experience he was a career politician a
career public servant
and a very dedicated one at that
in 1995 halliburton named dick cheney's
ceo surprised many people uh cheney had
actually toyed around with the idea of
possibly running for president
um he had toyed around with uh with some
other ideas uh but ultimately he became
the ceo
of halliburton
so why why did they want dick cheney as
their ceo
i think this will give you a good idea
brown enroute had nearly doubled its
government contracts from 1.2 billion
dollars
in the five years prior to dick cheney's
arrival to 2.3 million dollars during
his five years as ceo
halliburton soared from 73rd to 18th on
the pentagon's list of top contractors
its government contracting business grew
91 percent
in the five years before cheney took
over halliburton secured 100 million
dollars in government-backed loans from
the u.s export import bank
during the five years of cheney's tenure
that number increased to 1.5 billion
from 100 million to 1.5 billion
by the time he left in 2000 to become
george w bush's running mate
the reason that halliburton had chosen
dick cheney as his ceo had become clear
though cheney continued to deny that he
had any influence on halliburton's
government business
during a vice presidential debate in
2000 al gore's running mate senator
joseph lieberman mentioned casually that
cheney had done well financially in
haliburton
cheney responded by saying quote i can
tell you joe the government had
absolutely nothing to do with that end
quote
um that's a little tough to believe
considering uh the remarkable increases
in government business that the company
experienced during his tenure
and also considering there would be
really no other reason for a fortune 500
oil services firm to hire a career
politician to be their ceo
so why is all this
somewhat disconcerting to me and to
other people in this country
you know
i think the most obvious reason is that
as a taxpayer i'm very concerned with
how my money is being spent
and if i feel that it's being misspent i
want to know why and and who are the
companies that are behind it
so right now that's uh that's on the top
of my mind
but also there's something
that dwight eisenhower referred to as
the military industrial complex and i
talked about this last year at the
federal city club
when i was speaking in my book the iron
triangle
and i think it applies even more to
halliburton and the military-industrial
complex or the iron triangle
is essentially the confluence of
the defense industry
politics and big business
and when those three
when those three powerful forces get
together and start moving in the same
direction
policy can get made business changes can
happen
and and the influence of the defense
industry
can be a little disconcerting
so i'm going to read a little bit
about
the trend of privatization in the
military the trend of outsourcing to
private contractors
like halliburton
and we've all read a lot about this
recently in the press
and hopefully this will resonate a
little bit
it seemed reasonable that a privatized
military would be more nimble efficient
and cost effective if open if open
competition was cultivated
competition would cut down on the
burgeoning bureaucracy of the government
and create a growing new industry in the
united states that would even help fuel
the economy it had worked in other
industries to varying degrees so why not
the military
but the military is not like other
industries the distinction between
public and private market markets is
simple the government or the public
sector is expected to act on behalf of
its citizens spending their tax money to
better their lives
the private sector is motivated solely
by profit
in the case of waging war and action
taken to ostensibly improve the lives of
citizens
it would seem that the government should
remain the sole dispenser of funds and
the military should remain the sole
recipient
peter singer
author of the definitive work on the
subject of military outsourcing puts it
like this
in fact providing for national and hence
their citizen security was one of the
most essential tasks of a government
indeed it defined what a government was
supposed to be
the result is that the military has been
the one area where there has never been
a question of states outsourcing or
privatizing
even the most radical libertarian
thinkers who tend to think that
everything should be should be left to
the market made an exception of the
military
all viewed national defense as something
best carried out by a tax financed
government force
so that has obviously changed a great
deal in the past 10 years really since
the great peacetime dividend at the end
of the cold war the reduction in troop
size
and we've seen
since then a number of smaller
skirmishes and smaller deployments
but a very very active military
nonetheless uh so we have needed as as a
as a country we've needed to outsource a
lot of the functions of the military
one of the obvious uh functions to
outsource was logistical support for the
army in the navy
this
involves everything from
building housing for troops
cleaning latrines
feeding the troops
doing their laundry
any task that you can imagine that is of
a non-military nature or non-combat
nature
could be left to to a private firm
that firm as it turns out right now is
kellogg brown and root the subsidiary of
halliburton
they have done work uh since 1992
under a contract called log cap a
logistical augmentation program for the
army this is a massive massive contract
and obviously we've seen the size of
this contract balloon in iraq
to
close to 9 billion right now if all of
the task orders that are currently in
place were to be fulfilled obviously
just a massive amount of money for for a
single contractor to
to receive
there have been questions about whether
there should be multiple contractors
doing this kind of thing maybe have a
two contractor system where they compete
on on each
task order so as to avoid the time
critical issues that the army
experiences
but to also maintain some competition
but as it stands right now there is one
company kellogg brown and root that does
all of the logistical support for the
army
and that creates a bit of a problem
as we saw in bosnia in the mid 90s i'll
read a little bit about that and then
i'll open it up for questions
the main problem with the work in the
balkans and was a lack of oversight by
the army
from the army's perspective everything
was running smoothly after all brown and
root made their lives considerably
easier
by assigning ever-increasing amounts of
work to the contractor the army was able
to reduce force size and concentrate on
more important things and it wasn't
their money that was being spent
there was also a fundamental and more
systemic problem occurring
the army was unclear about how the log
cap contract was to be used originally
the contract was quote intended to be
the option of last resort end quote
but the army had come to think of log
cap and subsequently brown root as
another branch of the military
at their beck and call the results were
disastrous and fantastically expensive
critics say the brown root benefited
from the confusion the gao found that
the company overstaffed and oversupplied
the army resulting in higher costs and
in turn higher profits for brown and
root in one instance brown and root was
tasked with building a firefighting
force to staff the camps in bosnia
kosovo and macedonia
the company submitted a plan for 116
firefighting personnel army engineers
concluded that no more than 66 were
needed but brown and roo was able to
haggle with the army finalizing an
agreement
to staff 77 firefighters and the
corresponding amount of trucks and
equipment despite the difference of
opinion on the matter the army gave in
to brown and roots requests showing the
rising level of authority the company
had in influencing army policy
indeed the army was confused about its
authority over its primary contractor
in december 1999 the administrative
contracting officer at camp monteith in
kosovo
issued a task order to brown and root to
build a tent for use as the post office
at the camp the government estimated the
cost to be six thousand dollars so the
officer placed a ten thousand dollar
limit on the cost of the construction
giving brown and root amp a wiggle room
upon hearing this the lead
administrative contracting officer at
camp bondsteel sent an email to his
equal account monteith telling him that
brown root quote is the army's customer
and that such funding limitations affect
the army's relationship with the
customer end quote
how the customer vendor relationship in
in the balkans got so turned around is
anybody's guess the army is of course
the customer in the relationship not the
reverse
so that's an example of the amount of
power
that a sole contractor
that that the army and the navy have
come to depend on
uh
wields in the battle time situation uh
they don't have time to upset the
contractor they can't bring in another
contractor in this case in fact in
bosnia uh
in 1997
kellogg brown and route lost the co the
log cap contract to dyncorp um but the
government found that it was impossible
to take brown and root out of bosnia
because they were so entrenched they
were so involved in every aspect of the
army's dealings there that there was no
way they could bring in a new contract
it would cost them too much money it
would be too expensive and and uh and
take too much time
so they carved out that entire piece of
the world and left it in kbr's hands
and
in 2001 kbr won the contract back again
this time for a 10-year installment
um so that's pretty much the four things
that i wanted to cover and i'm eager to
hear uh what you guys think and uh and
what you would like to know so if
anybody has any questions
fire away
[Applause]
i'll take the liberties and start
you've pro you've presented
lots of questionable circumstances
um certainly motives
were crimes committed were laws broken
can you spell it out for us well there
were crimes committed back during the
lyndon johnson era and those things
didn't come out for a good 20 years
after that which is tends to be the way
that these things happen
after some of the public servants and
executives from the company have left
and moved on in their career and they
sort of no longer fear a consequence
these things start to come out
i expect those things to happen
today
have there been laws broken yes there
have even today
there have been
issues of bribery
that the company has admitted to and
they've had to pay fines for that those
have broken international codes
there are ongoing investigations
by no fewer than four government
agencies into halliburton right now
sec gao pentagon
and i believe the army corps of
engineers is also looking into them
so
do i expect
foul play to come out of that yes i do
and i think that you'd be pretty naive
not to not to expect some some foul play
to be found
you know if you're referring to
you know the issue that is on the top of
a lot of people's mind which is did dick
cheney have anything to do with getting
halliburton these contracts in the first
place
that is a much much tougher nut to crack
that is something that i i don't think
you'll ever find a smoking gun to to
prove anything of that nature it's not
like he was writing memos to the
contracting officers at the pentagon hey
could you give my buddies and
halliburton some help
he certainly had motive and means to do
those things anything other than that is
pure speculation though
yeah
um
these days we have a very small
volunteer army relatively small compared
to what we've had in some past years
on the surface uh it it doesn't seem
unreasonable to contract out some of the
things to the private sector that the
army used to take care of entirely
itself when we had
uh draftees for example uh
to me
the key issue is is how good a job of
brown and root is doing in these tasks
that it has taken on
uh and
i i wonder how
how good a job you feel that it has done
you you you've touched on some of the
weaknesses some right some obvious
problems but well
is this an inept outfit no not at all
it's it's been it's been very up and
down um their history in world war ii um
brown and root went into the
shipbuilding business and created
something called the brownship building
company
they had no experience in anything even
close to shipbuilding uh before but they
got the contract
um through some connections and
were phenomenal at it they did an
incredible job uh they won many many
awards from the army and the navy excuse
me
and blew everybody away with how
efficient and quick they were
the strength of this company is
quickness
they can mobilize in a heartbeat they've
got people all over the world
they were incredibly effective in
somalia
they were very effective in bosnia
although they spent a lot of money
in iraq they have had in vietnam they
had considerable difficulty in iraq
they're having considerable difficulty i
think
at least part of that stems from how
insecure both of those regions were and
are
and and how difficult it is for their
for their employees to move around the
country they've lost 34 employees
already in iraq um they've had employees
kidnapped uh you know the toms hamill
obviously escaped he was a halliburton
truck driver
so
it is very difficult for them to do
their job in iraq
that said
the
the difficulty uh that most people have
when it comes to military outsourcing is
the fact that these people do not
fit into the chain of command they
cannot be court-martialed and they can
leave whenever they want to
and if they are not available
for whatever the task is that they have
to do
the military ends up suffering greatly
from that
and it goes well beyond what halliburton
does in some of the logistical support
that they provide although that is
absolutely critical to the army's
operations over there the army could not
operate without these guys
there there is also uh companies that do
security detail
weapons maintenance
things of that nature
can be deadly if a contractor isn't
there to fix a tank
or a contractor isn't there with the
manual for how to fire uh howitzer or
you know whatever the issue is it's not
it sounds absurd but that is the that is
the modern day army these are private
companies that are making these uh uh
these machines and sometimes there is
not a soldier on the battlefield that
knows how to maintain them
so the argument cuts both ways you can
agree you can achieve some some great
efficiencies in that model and it's
certainly politically palatable
because you don't have to send as many
troops over there right now in iraq the
estimate is that there is one civilian
contractor there for every 10 troops
that we have there
and that's a lot of people
so
so it is it is a growing concern and
this administration has
certainly uh shown a real proclivity to
towards outsourcing um and i think uh
that there's got to be a balance um you
can't go too far with it yeah
um
why don't you
for what they take
there was a political decision
down the level above them that the army
is going to become smaller and leaner
and more will be outsourced
and kbr have done a wonderful job of
picking up the slack they're
countering them into the cost issue of
kosovo is that they were so efficient
the army basically said i cannot get rid
of this contractor that's so valuable to
our operations
in iraq and i've not heard about cases
of soldiers going hungry or tanks being
unable to move because no oil
trucks were available
to uh to deliver the oil so it sounded
like despite horrendous
conditions against them not to mention
all the political pressures at home
kpr has been delivering the goods of the
u.s forces in iraq
um i would have to i would have to argue
that um there
they have been criticized by the
military itself um and this is that's a
very rare thing to happen to have an
actual military official come out and
say that
our contractor is not doing its job and
they have done that
there have been problems with the food
delivery
substandard conditions in the kitchens
and and meals not being delivered on
time and drinkable water not being
delivered on time
and gasoline not being delivered on time
now a lot of that you know the company
will tell you uh that a lot of the
reason is because uh the security
environment is so unstable um at the
same time you know
if if it were a military operation
taking care of these tasks for the army
would they do a better job of getting
the goods to the camps
it's hard to say in many cases a lot of
military
personnel are diverted
to providing
to to provide the security detail for
the halliburton employees as they try to
do their jobs
in this case uh there have
the costs some of the costs have been in
inexcusable the cost overcharges um have
been inexcusable um and the explanations
have not
uh pacified the pentagon so the pentagon
is pursuing an investigation into
into
halliburton's work in in country
and they have also come under fire for
not paying their subcontractors on time
some of their subcontractors have not
been paid in over a year
and some of them are in danger of
insolvency right now because halliburton
is not um coming through with uh with
their payments uh so and they
subcontract about fifty percent of the
work um that they do out there uh so
there have been times in the past where
this company has come through with
flying colors somalia comes to mind
world war ii comes to mind
but that is not the case in iraq
and the circumstances surrounding how
they obtained the contracts in the first
place it's very controversial
um and that is also being looked into
so so the whole pretext for the work
that they're doing there and the nine
billion dollars of of contracts uh that
they have potential of gaining uh is
under scrutiny
the vice president's picture on the
cover of your book
well um i think that
when you think of halliburton
i think most people today think of dick
cheney uh right away he's the one who
sort of made this company famous or
infamous if you will um
it's true that that dick cheney is
actually a a relatively small part of
this book this book is a corporate
biography that looks at the company from
1919 all the way through to the modern
day
but at the same time you know for
the current reader
of a book about halliburton
they need to help
have some help identifying this company
who who is halbert oh yeah it's dick
cheney's company um and
and i want to read a little bit about
what dick cheney had to do with uh
what's going on
in iraq today in the halliburton
contracts by your own admission though
there's not a shred of evidence that he
had any kind of arcane
influence on the whole process
uh
that's true there there is no evidence
that dick cheney had a hand in actually
you know steering contracts to his old
company but i think if if that's all
you're focusing on if that's the only
part of the story that you think is
important i think you're missing a much
the much broader story here which
is questions also but i mean i'm looking
at him right now yes i heard what you
had to say and you know i don't
understand why my picture isn't on there
today
you know the point being that you have
as much proof
about my influence on those contracts is
apparently you do on him right but he
spent five years as the ceo of the
company and i think that that uh and is
now the vice president and uh yeah but i
can create any scenario you like on a
situation like that is all i'm saying
i you know
philosophy too in freshman college you
know false syllogism
you know if your basic premises are
wrong
then undoubtedly you're going to have a
conclusion that fits but it's incorrect
well i don't think by putting dick
cheney on the cover book that i'm
promising
that i'm going to tie him to the
contracts in iraq no
but doing that as far as i'm concerned
fits into the current
that
fits into the current level of
administration bash
and you know i mean if that's the way
your people want to market it i think
that dick cheney is responsible for the
state of this company today um the the
decisions that he made during the five
years that he was ceo um have put them
in the position that they're in today
which is um uh they now have two of
their subsidiaries that have had to
declare bankruptcy including kellogg
brown and root um and they are also uh
one of the one of the government's
biggest contractors and that had a lot
to do with uh dick cheney and his time
at the company so
the uh harvard business review of uh a
failed executive as opposed to uh in
and that's all covered in here as well
the other thing is the question is um
what companies would be
capable of being competitive with them
um over the past 10 years the number of
companies
that
would be able to do this type of
logistical outsourcing has diminished
greatly
partially because of the the size and
length of the contract that kbr
originally won in 1992.
if you've got a five-year contract to
provide all of the logistical support uh
for the army uh during that time any
other company that would be suited to
that kind of work would have trouble
finding work obviously because there's
only one army
so
the the length of these contracts has
limited um the amount of competition
that can naturally be in this
marketplace and if you talk to um if you
talk to peter singer uh who i quoted
earlier um he will tell you that the
the basic motives behind privatization
uh which is competition uh and and
penalties uh those are the two sort of
uh governing forces of the free market
uh that there's open competition uh for
the business in the first place and then
if you don't do the business well
there's penalties for that um have been
eroded by this contract uh because kbr
has held it for so long because they're
now inextricable from the army
their the competition has waned there
really is no one that can step in and do
it and the the army is finding it very
difficult to penalize the company
for wrongdoing or overcharges or things
like that because they become so
dependent on them as uh the example that
i that i showed in in bosnia pointed out
wouldn't gsa do that under liquidated
damages clause in any contract did you
do with the government well there are
other uh organizations that look into
these things and and try to keep these
guys honest but you know when you're
working in a war time situation
i think a lot of those constraints go
out the window
however in this case i'm encouraged to
see that there has been a lot of
scrutiny
and there's a lot of ongoing
investigation by those government
agencies to look into just how kosher
this business has been
within he has already touched on the
question i was going to ask earlier
are there not oversight committees in
charge of such kinds of contracts my
experience has always been that you know
you're chosen
you do the job because of your
capabilities and certainly halliburton
has proven over the years it has extreme
capabilities and very difficult
situations however there have always
been oversight kinds of committees to
keep halliburton at all in check
do we not have this we do have this
a lot of the folks who do that kind of
administrative oversight of these
contracts
are under intense pressure they have uh
thousands of contracts to look over in
fact during the clinton administration
that work force was significantly
reduced by about
a third
so there are not as many people doing
contract oversight and if you talk to
some of the experts in the government
contracting field they will tell you
that these people are terribly terribly
overmatched and can't possibly do uh the
job that they need to do in fact the
government has outsourced some of the
jobs that are in place to uh
to to oversee outsourcing contracts um
so
it's a vicious cycle
what's the difference between the mafia
and halliburton
one
they have no competitive bids two
political
and third
uh
no competitiveness
they have the ends of the contracts
where's where's the different trump
uh the difference between halliburton
and the mafia um well i don't think the
mafia is registered with the sec or um
or uh you know has uh shareholders that
i know of um
you know
you can
you know i think halliburton is is a
legitimate company
and in fact their oil field services
business is an outstanding business for
them if you talk to financial analysts
that cover this company they will tell
you
this company should ditch kbr they
should spin it off sell it to someone
it's not their core business uh and it's
not something uh that and they and the
bad press that they get from it um is
killing them
however if you look at how things
unfolded in iraq
kbr was in iraq first they were in uh
they were in kuwait um they built camp
uh arif john
they were there putting together the
housing for the troops under log cap
under an existing contract that was
already in place
that's not in question
halliburton was then brought in their
parent company
to do the
infrastructure repair of the oil of the
oil infrastructure in iraq
why halliburton was given a no-bid
contract to do that
is is anyone's guess you know i've
talked to the folks in the army corps of
engineers who awarded that contract and
they said well it was a secretive
contract because it was not you know it
was national security issue um and uh
and we felt the time was of the essence
i talked to people who were banging on
the government's door who are very
capable of doing oil repair services
they were banging on the government's
door back in november of 2002
when when the war drums first started
beating about iraq
halliburton was given that contract out
of convenience because they were the
parent company of kbr and they were
already there and there's no reason that
that contract should have been no bid
there's no reason that it should have
been secretive
it was it was a contract of convenience
so uh you know do their do their
connections have something to do with
that yeah i think they do i mean i think
you'd be really naive to think that they
don't um
you know at the same time do i think
that there's anything you know along the
lines of the mafia i doubt i doubt it
goes
quite that nefarious allison
despite the
broad entrenchment of halliburton across
the board in the rebuilding of iraq and
the allegations of billing
irregularities
i have read that the actual profit
margins are quite thin
can you comment on this that's a very
good point and that's something that uh
that that i touched on earlier when
these financial analysts are looking at
the company and they're interested in
you know the shareholder interest and
they're saying why are they keeping this
company around uh one of the reasons is
for for what i just told you which is
that kbr
got halliburton this incredibly
lucrative contract um to do to do the
oil infrastructure repair work
it was sort of used as a stocking horse
for that contract
you're right the
the profit margins for this type of
business are very very slim
it is not an attractive business to many
other companies which goes to rich's
point you know how many companies are
there out there that's doing this not
that many
but remember that these contracts are
cost plus contracts so
while the profit margins may vary
between one to three percent they are
guaranteed profit margins you will not
lose money on these contracts um so and
the more money you spend the more money
you make um so
so there's no risk involved
in terms and no financial risk involved
for a company like kbr to do this kind
of work the profit margins are slim
but you know at the same time it is a
guaranteed profit and i don't know too
many companies that would turn would
turn that down
but dangerous for many of these
individuals who are there absolutely and
we've we've seen a lot of that recently
yes
can you
explain some of the similarities and
differences between the power sources
within carlile and halliburton and if
if there's a crossover there there's not
really a crossover between these two
companies um they're in very distinct uh
marketplaces carlow group is of course
private equity firm
that's much more in the financial
markets halliburton has you know actual
products and services that they deliver
so the the the nature of the two
companies are very very different uh
where they sort of intersect is in the
area of what i've been calling the
military-industrial complex um they are
both companies that uh wield political
influence um both by people they hire
and dick cheney is not the only
political uh ex-politico that uh
the halliburton has hired over the years
uh so uh they will political influence
um they are involved in the defense
industry um and they are major major
businesses in this country major major
economic forces um so when you combine
all three of those things uh you you've
got a very very powerful force um in
this country and in this economy uh and
so so i think that uh you know the
similarities between the carlyle group
and halliburton uh pretty much end there
yeah
what is the paper trail if one can find
it
for
kellogg brown and root
halliburton in the
joyous process of election contributions
well you can uh all of those are readily
available you can go to opensecrets.org
and see just how much uh halliburton has
contributed to the republican party and
to uh the democratic party over the
years you can see their individual
contributions
to
to individual politicians
and you know you'll see a a heavy
heavy
balance on the republican side not
surprisingly it is it is in the oil
business and and that's very typical for
them
um i don't think you know i looked i
poured over those numbers again and
again and
tried to see you know
what they were doing why they were
spending money here or there
and i honestly think that
they're no different than any other
fortune 500 company
in this country in the way that they
sort of dispense those funds
i think that the type of influence that
they wield is uh is much different than
than the kind of thing that you can
register and look up if you read bob
carroll's biographies of lyndon johnson
and it was
halliburton or brown root at that time
covered their backside by contributing
to both sides right you know it's an
insurance policy i'm sure
isn't that going on today well
in the carroll books
if you look at
what was going on during lyndon
johnson's senate campaigns in 41 and 48
i think they were
that was
there was an unbelievable amount of
money changing hands there and most of
it was going right to lyndon johnson
so while they would make contributions
herman brown was an incredibly astute
politician even though he never held
political office
he spread his money around very very
strategically
and he uh was known in in houston and in
texas and really on the national stage
uh as a guy who had politicians in his
pocket um now
back then it was illegal for a
corporation to make a donation to a
campaign so they found other ways to do
it
they would
make individual i think an individual
could make a camp a campaign donation of
up to five thousand dollars
so herman brown would
distribute all of these
bonuses and other types of payments out
to his friends and
subcontractors and whatnot and they
would then turn around and
make those donations to the campaign
there was also a lot of cash floating
around
big bags full of hundred dollar bills um
that found their way to the johnson
headquarters uh so uh back then it was
much it was it was sort of the wild west
of politics certainly in texas at that
time and uh things were done a lot
differently there was much less
oversight um it's it's much different
now like i said i mean you can go to a
website and look up exactly how much
halliburton is donated to uh various
parties but it's uh i i would say more
subtle it's more subtle exactly
difference
it's still the fact that a state house
is a dome with a cash register yeah
different doesn't mean better
you're right it's still happening
yes um first comment about the one to
three percent returns and guarantee that
investment returns i mean you'll get
probably better returns that if you
invest in five year notes of the u.s
government
uh so you can get guaranteed you know
lawyer-free
returns just fine but you won't get the
cash flow that these guys are getting
from from this kind of business
goes with it
but taking on a higher point the
military industrial complex
how is that conflict how is that
industry different from any other
industry that has national interest in
this pharmaceutical industry have just
written
into a legislation that the government
cannot negotiate prices right the farm
community fund the farm subsidies are
all over the place and how is this
industry different than the other
industry who tries to influence the
government to maintain its interests
well i may be
unique in this regard but i i happen to
think that the military is a totally
different industry than other industries
in this country and part of what i read
out of the book earlier
was was why that is why is the military
different uh than other industries in
this country
part of it's because the military is is
the part of this country that goes to
war
and that is
i think a very significant difference
between you know the pharmaceutical
industry or any other industry that
wields political influence
what dwight eisenhower was saying in his
farewell speech uh when he referred to
the military industry and warned against
the formation of a military-industrial
complex is that he felt that there was
the potential for this industry for the
defense industry with political top with
enough political clout and ties to
influence this country's decision
military decisions and that is a very
very dangerous uh precedent to be set if
you're talking about profit-driven
companies
influencing our nation's leaders when
they decide when and where to go to war
that i think is uh is
much more disconcerting
than
than other industries like
pharmaceuticals although though those
have their own problems is there any
other reason
to anything similar to that
having having directly influenced the
decision to go to war essentially they
do what eisenhower fear that the
military industrial conference company
would do so any proof that anyone that
decision to go to war had anything to do
with elements
no no of course not um there's there is
certainly a lot of speculation around
that point
there are conflict of interest
rules that are built into government
um that are meant to avoid
the even the potential for something
like that to come about
with dick cheney still receiving
deferred salary payments from
halliburton with him still in touch with
the executives at the company
i think that conflict of interest those
conflict of interest rules have been
violated um i think that that that does
constitute the potential
for his decisions to be influenced
i'm not saying they were i'm just saying
that that the potential is there and
that's something that i'd rather not see
in uh in the public servants in this
country how much they contribute to the
tax base
how much does halliburton contribute to
the tax base i don't know that number
offhand but the reason i think about
that is that
if in fact they are an american company
and say the 87 billion dollars it was
put through congress in order to help
the rebuilding there right
the taxpayers money is going back
to an american company
providing
employment for american
people plus others obviously locals and
i think that's a dangerous argument to
be making i think that's uh i'm not just
making the comment that it would follow
that that's the case right and that's
why i ask when it's all said and done
yeah i mean if you backed out the
numbers company the business to a french
government you know schlumberger is
actually uh halliburton's biggest uh
competitor um but they're sure as hell
not going to get the contracts
you're missing my case
in john dean's recent book and i guess
he spoke here recently
um which i haven't yet finished but he
points out that
he makes the argument i should say that
uh
chaney was aware of these enormous
asbestos litigation liabilities with
dresser at the time
that the merger occurred in the takeover
to purchase the company
and
he suggests that
that cheney was aware of this and knew
that this was in effect a
kind of ticking time bomb that was going
to
devastate the stock price of the company
now of course uh halliburton's stock
price dropped dramatically along with
the rest of the market
first of all do you even get into that
in your book
yeah
i touch on the fact that
within the decision making process to
acquire dresser
there is some evidence that the
executives of the company were aware of
asbestos liability
though
publicly on the record those officials
have said that they thought that
asbestos liability it was far far less
than it turned out to be they thought it
was ima that's exactly what they called
it in the uh prospectus that they put
out to the shareholders they called it
immaterial um
it turned out and and uh to their
defense the uh
the
nature of asbestos litigation changed
somewhat
over that over that time
however
it is inexcusable for a company of that
size to acquire another company of
that's a dresser size
and not
understand the full extent of what of
the liability that they are acquiring
that was clearly a mistake
and it's another one of the things that
um you know rich you're mentioning that
you know maybe this book should be about
the the fact that cheney was a really
bad ceo and there uh is a lot of
evidence in this book about um what
cheney did wrong as ceo and i think that
that really tops the list
and over and over again cheney has said
publicly i wasn't aware of the asbestos
litigation i wasn't aware that we were
doing business in iraq i wasn't aware
that we changed our accounting rules and
fair and failed to uh uh tell our
shareholders well what was he doing and
he was the ceo of this company and uh
and and these are major major decisions
that this company is going through um so
it obviously begs the question you know
what what was this guy working on the
whole time he was like well he was the
marketing i wanted to make one comment
and ask another question apropos not
knowing i mean
i do corporate investigative work and
you know that's an absolute basic thing
you do is a litigation search
and so you you know
right this is a symbol straight these
are public records right you go and you
pull those files you look at them and
you
you know make an assessment about what
that's about and that's just all part of
the standard package yeah that
undoubtedly was done before the
acquisition
so i mean it just sort of bolstered your
points but it's not clear whether they
knew about it and chose to downplay it
for the sake of getting shareholder
approval of the deal
or whether they really were unaware of
it and were
not not very diligent on the deal here's
my question in terms of the stock price
job
the market was going to hell during that
two years anyway
was there any sort of a differential
analysis within that
coming to that type in those businesses
in terms of how their stocks performed
relative to halliburtons
in other words something where you could
point to it and say
this company's stock price declined far
more than other companies of its type
and
the asbestos litigation did have a
material absolutely i mean if you look
at those numbers you will see that
halliburton
suffered with the rest of the industry
and then suffered more because of uh the
massive asbestos litigation i mean we're
talking about you know uh i think the
final settlement offer was 4.4 billion
dollars that's a massive chunk of money
to be paying out
for for getting you know zero benefit
from it so
they essentially
shut down dresser
and bankrupted kbr
all throughout this process so they've
taken a tremendous hit from this much
more than than companies of their ilk
was there a particular day when you know
the stock went off the cliff on the
basis of some news about that
i don't know what the exact day was but
i think there was a moment when it
became suddenly clear how serious it was
i think the number of suits filed
against them had reached uh such a
massive level something like 400 000
suits um that once the press got ahold
of that uh the
share price really uh dipped
dramatically but i don't know when the
exact date of that was yeah you also
talked about the bonuses that they may
have received during those
people's years
oh the bonuses that the executives yeah
i don't actually know what their bonuses
were but but i know that uh you know
dick cheney walked away from the company
with 30 million dollars so um it wasn't
uh at the time that he left the company
it was not seen to be the disaster that
it is today
um and
uh sort of inexplicably the the company
still loves dick cheney um they they
look to him as sort of a godfather um
you know i've talked to people in the
industry who say you know these these
guys love to talk to dick they love to
get his opinion on things and um and i
look at his track record as ceo and
wonder why they would ever solicit his
opinion again but uh
i'm not really sure
maybe it's because he knows some things
because he's vice president
i think i'll take the liberties for the
last question
americans have a very short attention
span we're in an election cycle um
polling around white water for instance
tons you know tons of confusion
disinterest checking out
why should americans care about this
should
should they why and can you give us the
sound by the answer
number one reason they should care about
it is because it's your money being
spent and you should want to know how
it's being spent
the second uh most important reason i
think is if a company
like halliburton reaches this level of
political influence and um and and
economic influence um it is it is a
danger um it is uh it is approaching the
military complex
and that's something that we should all
be vigilant about
because we want to feel that whenever we
go to war we're going to war for the
right reasons for the moral reasons
whether or not you believe that this war
is for those reasons or not you don't
want to have that doubt in the back your
mind
that there were other economic interests
involved something that hasn't been said
something that hasn't come out
and and i think the american people
deserve that and they deserve to feel
good about deploying their troops
someplace
and in this case this is just one of
many things that has made a lot of
people sort of doubt our motives and our
interests in going to war
thanks everybody
[Applause]
dan briote is the author of the iron
triangle inside the secret world of the
carlisle group
his latest the halliburton agenda is
published by wiley for more information
visit wiley.com
rowan scarborough has covered the
pentagon for the washington times for 15
years
next he discusses his new book uh plus
shipping and handling and then you're
required to buy just uh four more books
over the next two years
and certainly if you are somebody who
cares about the conservative movement
and conservative ideas and just
generally wants great books
for instance one of our main selections
back in august was the afghan by
frederick forsyth the novel
and an extraordinary brilliant and
terrifying novel about uh jihad and we
offer again the the widest possible
range of books so americancompass.com is
the place to go
brad miner editor-in-chief of the
american compass thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
president bush pledged bipartisan
cooperation this week after democrats
won a majority in both houses of
congress
next lou dubose and jake bernstein argue
that vice president dick cheney has made
the bush administration unpopular
this talk from politics and prose
bookstore in washington dc is just under
an hour
good evening i'm barbara mead i'm one of
the owners here at politics and pros and
i'm delighted to see we got as many
people as we did tonight first of all it
being a rainy day
but second of all of the astounding news
that came over the news wires today
which i think a lot of people have gone
home to
watch all those pundits figure out what
it all means but we we've got our own
we've got our own two pundits right here
so they they can help us and they may
help us better
okay i'm here to welcome lou dubose and
jake bernstein on the occasion of the
publication of vice
which is a
investigation of the political years of
vice president cheney it's just an
extraordinary book and these are two
guys who really knew what they were
doing and writing it louder bose
has
two previous biographies of bush that he
has written with molly ivan's
shrub and bushwhacked
he has also
written a biography of karl rove and
he's also been written a biography of
tom delay
he has a lot of political research under
his belt so
and with of uh lou this evening is jake
bernstein
he is the executive editor
of the texas
observer he spent a long time as an
investigative reporter
in texas and one of the things that came
out of that was a series of a series of
articles
about tom delay that won him
many awards for his investigative
journalism
so between the two of them they've come
out with just a wonderful
overview
of
what the cheney years
in the bush administration have meant i
i can't help but tell you in closing
that i think i was counting up that it
is uh this uh
cheney rumsfeld affiliation
started back in 1974
so
as of today we're
22
30 32 years later
at least one person has left the
equation and we'll find out more about
that tonight but i'm delighted to have
jake bernstein and lou dubose here
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you barbara and thank you all for
coming i'm
delighted to be here again
the last time i was here i was
prophetically explaining that tom delay
had told me and that there would be a
permanent republican majority in the in
the house of representatives
i was late getting here on the way over
i realized that the traffic was held up
because of the shifting of the tectonic
plates
in the uh in the american electoral
political system
an amazing night it's a different
morning we all wake up to this morning
before i i start i guess not before i
start because i've already started uh i
would like to uh recognize our colleague
and researcher peter lindstrom uh who is
sitting in the back uh peter has worked
with us on this book but there's another
uh aside of it peter peter is both a a
literary and political researcher not
that the work we do is literary but i'd
like to sort of give it that little
cachet uh he uh peter worked on uh has
worked on on three political campaigns
that i've known of one involved tom
delay
and most recently uh it was he he was
the opposite he did opposition research
for on the rick santorum santorum
campaign for casey and also on the palm
book uh richard pombo campaign so if
you're uh predisposed to applaud go
ahead he's
he is a man
he's a man on a roll uh
and uh and we were pretty
you can afford them peter
uh
you know uh it is a different morning
that we wake up to uh we were speaking
last week in austin and uh i i said it
was the 30th anniversary the precise
date and jay corrected me it was the
20th anniversary of iran contra uh by
which dick cheney rose to another
another level of pro of prominence in in
an american in in the american political
pantheon uh where he finds himself as
mourning um
you know i started out uh uh as as a
texas a reporter of texas following
george bush and uh watching him uh
run a gubernatorial campaign that was
essentially a campaign for the uh a
gubernatorial uh six years as governor
that was what was essentially a campaign
for the presidency
and uh
and
there was
so you know those of us from texas who
believe in the state and it's a state in
which people believe uh you know looked
at this iron triangle of of karl rove
uh
and uh karen hughes
and joe alba and and we're we're very
much in awe of the fact that these that
these that these these these three were
coming to washington
and we're going to actually take over
and run the country and i think they
believe that too for a long time uh you
know karl rove is is without doubt one
of the one of the great uh political
minds of modern political history in
this country but you know karen hughes
was okay i mean she was an adequate
press secretary for george bush in
washington
in austin and and joe alba was kind of a
business guy and a hustler and and what
they encountered in washington
i think establish when they arrived here
was was a team of of uh seasoned
political insiders
uh
you know
don rumsfeld and dick cheney started out
together in the nixon administration uh
don don rumsfeld
uh gay uh other than being a a lineman
in in in his home state
not a football type lineman but but you
know like a lineman for a glenn campbell
type of lineman uh dick chen
his first paying job his first
government job his first what was dick
cheney got was from from don rumsfeld is
when don rumsfeld was working in the in
the uh
in the nixon administration so you know
you go all the way back to nixon with
cheney and rumsfeld uh
david addington uh you know the the
legal mind behind uh
the uh the unitary presidency and and
dick cheney's longtime advisor was at
the cia
and in working uh in in the a in in and
in the early 80s moved over to the
intelligence house intelligence
committee where he he joined up with
dick cheney uh
paul wolfowitz was was moving back and
forth between yale and between uh the uh
the the policy shop of of uh senator
scoop jackson
and uh who else who am i missing
in that group uh
scooter libby was was was uh in 81 went
to work at the state department well in
81 george bush was was still hanging out
at chateau de jean playing basketball at
the downtown houston y and and really
trying to find himself
so you i think what happened with with
uh the uh
the the the iron triangle and the end
were they really were and and i don't
want to diminish karl rove's uh uh
brilliance as a political tactician
because i think that up until up until
last this morning at about two o'clock
that was proven
but i i think that that that he kind of
ran out of tricks but but the the iron
triangle really was not an iron triangle
they they really in the end i think were
they were they were three three people
from texas and they were very much uh
the mayberry machiavellians
that that uh joseph diolio called this
as he described them and what they
encountered was was
a well-oiled seasoned political machine
that had been working together in
washington since since since the 70s and
i think that that's where
what happens with the presidency and why
the war becomes why it was why dick
cheney was able and wolfowitz and and
and rumsfeld were able to sell the war
to to to george bush was because they
were so vastly some so far vastly more
experienced than he was
and
it all goes back to and this is this is
a a bit of a dog and pony show and we
take times turns being the dog in the
pony uh it all goes back to the to the
to the ford administration and and and
it was jake who uh had the privilege of
flying to dearborn in winter uh to look
at that to look at what dick cheney had
done in the ford administration and i
think i'll step aside and we'll sort of
talk back and forth for a while but this
is the this is a crowd that probably
knows as much as we do so maybe we can
have a conversation about this in 15
minutes or so or we can go on for an
hour and a half
am i the dog or the pony
actually it's ann arbor michigan where
the ford library is but there there's an
incredible irony uh to to yesterday's
revolt uh results uh involving dick
cheney well and revolt yes indeed um
and that and and that is is directly
related to the ford administration and
so much of what's happened uh in the
past six years is actually directly
related to the ford administration
when when when cheney joined ford
rumsfeld was chief of staff and cheney
was deputy chief of staff in the
beginning
in 74 after the nixon pardon there was a
huge democratic wave the democrats
picked up
more than 40 seats
and this incredible reform congress
started and their main goal was to
dismantle the imperial presidency that
richard nixon had constructed and they
went about doing that quite aggressively
particularly in the area of intelligence
uh the church committee and uh and the
pike committee
were starting to to do their business
and all kinds of awful skeletons were
coming tumbling out of the closet and so
uh there was a big battle
as jack marsh uh said to us um
dealing with congress on intelligence
during that period was like opening the
door and having a tsunami come through
every day and so this really traumatized
cheney i think traumatized rumsfeld as
well but particularly cheney and he has
really spent the past 30 years trying to
reconstruct the imperial presidency
that was dismantled under ford and a few
years before and a few years after um
the irony of course is that uh in the
process of doing this uh in sort of
being more
authoritarian and uh and and less
concealed conciliatory and and certainly
um less willing to discuss
and uh and work with congress
he engendered to some degree the
backlash that created the very same
dynamic that happened in in 74 except
this time in 2006. so i
i tend to doubt that that he's in south
dakota right now hunting uh that he's
really savoring this irony but uh but
it's certainly out there um some of the
other areas that that that have echoes
to to ford that are happening now
in addition to intelligence is
environmental stuff nixon actually has a
fairly decent environmental record uh
ford was not so so good and and there's
certainly a lot of uh
there's some indications that the part
of that was cheney energy was an issue
in ford uh that as it is now and cheney
again was was right at the center of
that and cheney really picked up his his
uh his political style in the ford
administration cheney was the guy who
went into the oval office and had the
last word with the president he was the
person who never wrote anything down
that was one of the things he learned
from rumsfeld but instead
had
you know was whispering in the
president's ear and had influence in
that way and that's really carried over
to the bush administration
one other aspect that's particularly
kind of
ironic and revealing about cheney's time
at ford is nelson rockefeller
nelson rockefeller was ford's vice
president and he was a major player in
the republican party from the moderate
wing successful new york governor and uh
and ford wanted rockefeller to have a
real role in in the ford administration
and so he he put him in charge of the
domestic policy council and the idea was
that rockefeller would be the one who
would
drive domestic policy to to a large
degree in the ford administration now
rumsfeld and cheney really didn't like
rockefeller they didn't like his
politics they didn't like him personally
i don't think uh and uh and there was a
immediate conflict there and since they
kind of controlled the bureaucratic
levers to some degree they managed to
kind of isolate and marginalize uh
rockefeller and in the end uh
ford asked him not to to put his name in
again um when they ran for
when ford ran for re-election
or election since he hadn't really been
elected but uh but what's the ironic
part of it is that uh shortly after the
ford administration cheney gave an
interview and talked about how
what ford had tried with rockefeller was
exactly wrong that a vice president
shouldn't have that kind of power
shouldn't be involved in policy because
in fact you know it wasn't going to be
equal there was no way that staffers
could relate to the vice president as a
staffer uh he he had a more powerful
position and that it was just an
imbalance that couldn't be corrected and
it would sort of throw off the whole the
whole shebang and so
you know ironically that's exactly what
uh what what cheney sort of constructed
for himself
um after uh
we could talk a little bit about
congress but uh
the uh
after after ford uh
cheney took a a a little time off but
not much
and ran for congress in wyoming and and
and became a congressman and was was
instantly sort of a player in congress
because he had been chief of staff the
youngest chief of staff in the history
of our country and uh and and
lou will talk a little bit more about
what
some of the things that he did in in
congress but one of the things that's
particularly revealing for for where we
are now is is cheney's role in iran
contra which which a lot of people don't
really uh understand he was the ranking
minority uh uh person on in on the
intelligence committee and also on the
iran contra committee and uh and he
really worked to um
to limit the the extent of iran contra
and uh and coordinated it see it seems
clear now that uh that he coordinated if
not personally his staff coordinated
oliver north on their testimony and on
the uh the stuff that went on as as far
as the investigation into iran contra uh
this was really an example for cheney of
how to um
of what the president should be allowed
to do i mean it was illegal they were
circumventing congress but but cheyney
kind of thought that that they didn't
you know congress didn't have a role in
foreign policy and and so in fact the
the president hadn't really broken any
laws
errors of judgment he said but but
certainly
no law breaking
so um but there's a rise uh
of of the republican right in congress
that cheney was very much part of and
lou can certainly talk on that i think
we should interview each other there we
go we should we should actually be
interviewing each other back and forth
because this is an odd dynamic but we
will proceed with it nonetheless uh you
know there are missed opportunities in
life and just as i think uh george w
bush would have made a great
commissioner of baseball
uh dick cheney given the opportunity
would have made a great majority leader
in the house
and and perhaps uh for a while uh
speaker of the house because uh dick
cheney arrived at the hou in the house
same year george bush uh lost his
election in midland uh
and and and sort of set out again to
find himself uh as he has done on
occasion uh
dick cheney uh was elected to the house
78
78 he's elected to the house
um and he he of course arrives not as uh
uh uh just a guy who's run for the house
of representatives but as a former uh
staffer in the white house with it with
this enormous celebrity status
and uh and and was was for a while
a real institutionalist in the house of
representatives sort of following the
same track that that the leadership path
that lyndon johnson had followed before
him and that uh then another uh
interesting footnote in american
political history tom delay had followed
after
um
you know sort of committee by committee
position by position the you know the
republicans had been out of power
for uh 25 years at the time
about 25 years i think and and uh and
dick cheney found insinuated himself
into into various uh committees and
paths to power and was really uh
entirely on his way to becoming uh
to becoming the majority leader and
replacing bob michael who was then uh
was then on his way out
uh or at least was contemplating
retirement because the republican
republicans in the house have been out
for so long um
probably would have been a majority
leader had had not he been appointed by
the senior george bush as secretary of
defense but um
you know along the way he compiled one
of the most
extremist records uh voting records and
and and and in the history of the house
modern house he was to the right of newt
gingrich he was he was sort of out there
between newt and bob dornan uh you know
he went off the cliff on a number of
issues uh with eight 10 12 38 26 members
uh yet no one ever uh you know i sat
down and and talked with with a mickey
edwards a congressional scholar and a
former congressman from oklahoma and
we're talking about cheney and and he
said uh well you know had the same sort
of
moderately conservative record that i
haven't when i started reading the votes
off he said you know i forgot that and
his demeanor always covered much of that
uh he was also never you know he was i
think he was
i think he's a terrifically uh uh
smart guy and it's all in the book i
mean you could you know get it all out
of the book uh he's uh you know he's
he's one of the most one of the most
brilliant process politicians of our
time
he he never he never joined uh newt
gingrich and vinn weber and and and the
the conservative opportunity society and
and the the bomb throwers who who sort
of seized the night and did the and and
and and took
control of the special orders what
speeches are they special order speeches
at night uh he was he was a he
he he behaved very much like a moderate
until the moment that he saw that they
had that they had taken over and then he
invited he invited them into the
and the name of the group that he led
the house
the
leadership uh
one of the big leadership conferences
though
and i'm i'm stumped but i was i was
watching alexa i was watching election
returns at 1 45 in the morning and
haven't slept a lot since
uh but but he he never he he was very
smart in never and never taking a great
risk and identifying with newt and and
the bomb throwers until until uh and who
took over in 94 until it was evident
they were going to take over 94 by which
time he was on to the
to uh to serve as secretary of defense
should i just keep talking
about the negotiating his negotiating uh
postures particularly with the soviet uh
there was there yeah there was um
and now i've got my foley's confused
there's mark there's mark
there's tom
and there's a democrat
tom paulie no no
no from new york
audience participation moment
downey that's why tom downey
it was a long night of watching
elections uh in in uh in 84
dick cheney was was a real a genuine
cold warrior and and really believed in
in almost uh
every every missile system that was that
was proposed and and you know ultimately
had a part in in the dissolution of the
collapse of the soviet union i think but
but there was an interesting moment when
he was not with when he was with neither
mark foley nor tom foley but he was with
tom downey in 1984 and they it was the
first code the first congressional
delegation trip to moscow
and um
and
because of because since 79 because of
tensions involving afghanistan so they
were invited to speak to the to the to
the number three uh
leader in the soviet union at the time
whose name i won't dare because it's
it's russian uh uh martial acromerev and
uh and he made a remarkable offer to
them he said that he would like to see
uh
uh he would like to see arms
negotiations begin he would like the us
to to consider
to consider
discussions of stopping testing of the
amex for which the soviets in return
would would stop testing a weapon system
and they would they would they wanted to
consider deploy weapons deployment in in
in in
in eastern europe and western europe
uh they stepped out together into the
into the sunlight in moscow and and uh
tom downey told his story and dick
cheney said it never happened
he said that there was no such offer
made
that that tom downey had had uh who's a
a clear-headed seasoned uh
congressman at this time tom downey had
misinterpreted what had been offered and
there was no offer on behalf of the
soviets to to reopen arms negotiations
and and in fact it was all a mistake
tom told me they had a discussion later
and in which he said well it was all
said he said he tom sort of went through
it there was a junior state department
person with him as there would be with
any codel to a a a
to a russian a a soviet leader uh
and uh and he said well there's there
are known there's dick cheney said there
is no negotiation with these people and
and tom downey said arnold doesn't are
negotiations by negotiations do you mean
imposing your will on them do you expect
them to surrender and he said that's
what i expect they'll surrender and
there was so there was going to be no
negotiation he was not going to be a
party to it
later that night
the two of them walked out onto red
square together just the two of them and
and despite their ideological
differences they became they had become
good friends they walked out under red
square together and and and he describes
it
a former congressman down he describes
it as a spectacular clear cool night in
moscow and he said that he said dick
what are you thinking what are you
thinking and dick cheney said i think
we're standing on ground zero
and uh even as a casual comment you know
here here was uh the future vice
president united states who didn't
believe in in negotiations who believe
that negotiation was imposing your will
on on your on your adversary
and uh and who who you know who had
bombs going off in his head in 1984
uh so now let's i suppose time for jake
to interview me or me to interview jake
and we'll continue uh and then we'll
we'll we'll quit soon and we'll take
questions and argument
[Music]
yeah i just want to follow up on what he
was saying about the new negotiation
posture because he fast forward to today
and uh and we have iran and actually
right after uh
the invasion of iraq when we've torn
through the country and and routed
saddam and and actually it looked like
we had done pretty well there for about
five seconds um but the iranians were
were sufficiently disturbed by how fast
we had moved
that they went to the swiss ambassador
as an intermediary to approach the
united states and say we want to
negotiate and not only do we want to
negotiate but everything is on the table
we'll we'll talk about our nuclear
program we'll talk about uh al qaeda uh
and and prisoner exchanges we'll talk
about everything and um
cheney uh from from our sources told us
uh not only put the kibosh on
negotiating with iran at that time even
though they were they were
approaching us in a posture that was was
less than belligerent uh it was it was
almost uh
as a supplicant to some degree um
cheney said not only
will we not do that but then they they
reprimanded the swiss ambassador for
getting involved
so it it's uh
the same thing uh pretty much happened
with korea we heard that uh when there
was a negotiating in with with korea
north korea that we would um
yet the the principals would agree
powell and and and dr rice and and
cheney and and bush would all agree on a
negotiating posture and then cheney
would come in at the end
and talk directly to the negotiator and
say no in fact you can't uh say any of
these things uh really there's not much
that that we're willing to negotiate at
all so it's he's been very consistent in
that respect and and unfortunately i
think we see the results of that but
here you have a guy who has been
he was in congress he was in the white
house as a young man
he's a masterful bureaucratic warrior
and he really uh before he accepted the
the vice presidency or officially
accepted the vice presidency uh i think
he gave it a lot of thought and and how
it would work and and one sort of tiny
example of that and and i think david
addington was part of that dating david
addington had run his uh his uh
presidential exploratory committee uh
when he was thinking about running for
president in 96 so they had been
thinking about uh the way that you would
run a white house uh for some time
dreaming about it in fact and uh and he
had uh
he had thought about the office of the
vice president
which is a very interesting office
because it's not um it's not technically
a part of the executive
in the constitution it's it's actually
the ceremonial uh uh president of the of
the senate and uh and more a part of the
congress in a lot of ways than it is a
part of the white house and cheney and
addington have exploited that uh
unbelievably and some of you probably
remember
al gore's famous statement no
controlling legal authority and and
cheney and eddington have uh have really
taken that to heart um
as as since they're not technically
members of the executive they're they're
not subject to foia because they're
members of congress and and congress is
not subject to foia
but because he's ceremonial head of the
president of the senate uh the senate
doesn't really have any rules that
govern the vice president's office so
he's not really under the control of the
senate either
and so you have this kind of
liminal
no man's land of an office and so they
have been unwilling to release the most
basic information about how the office
of the vice president actually works
you know what how many staffers they
have what their budget is how many
documents they've classified sort of
information that you would think the
american people would have a right to
know but but cheney has has figured out
this sort of loophole uh involving his
office and and refuses to to release
this information
and part of it is just as a man who has
tremendous knowledge really knows how
the system works believes that there
should be a strong executive has uh i
think
an authoritarian bent
and uh and so all of that sort of came
uh to a climax uh in his vice presidency
and and created what we believe to be uh
the most powerful vice president in the
history of our country
so maybe we could uh what do you think
about opening up to some questions uh we
could take questions we could go on for
another couple of hours
we could do another we
stump the audience by giving long last
names of memories of the house and
having you answered why don't we do the
questions
come on
you got any questions
i i have a question how
much do you think that cheney was
involved in the
uh resignation or uh removal from office
of rummage to help today
boy that's a good one
uh you know
how how much was dick cheney involved in
the in the resignation of of uh of
donald rumsfeld today
you know he was he was i think i think
rumsfeld i think to answer that question
is to not answer the question don
remsfield was was in office in part for
as long as he was because the bush's
astounding sense of loyalty but also
because uh
he was he was he was dick cheney's rabbi
he was his godfather he was to be to be
ecumenical uh he was uh you know he was
his patron from the very beginning uh
their the fam their close friends they
dined together they bought uh compounds
together out on the eastern shore uh you
know i i think that that that uh that
it must have been uh
in many ways today must have been a
difficult day for dick cheney because i
don't think that he wanted uh uh that
you know they they share the same mind
and the same philosophy
i don't think i certainly don't think he
would he would have gone in and said to
the president it's time for don rumsfeld
to go so if you're hunting with him
today beware
a cheap shot
he did he did come to texas and shoot
the finest republican in our state harry
whittington who is a a a man without
peer in in in public in public service
service in texas
could you just talk a little bit about
the current administration and what he's
uh done uh uh recently
sure
i mean there's
the question was can we talk about the
the current administration what he's
done uh recently uh there's there's so
much to talk about i mean we could just
take torture for example which has been
a a a an issue close to cheney's heart
he's been uh
he's
he's been um
ways yes i'm sorry about that he's he's
he's been a big proponent of of
of of of allowing the the president to
to order uh coercive
uh interrogation uh techniques
um
there was a a a legislative battle over
that uh one that uh john mccain and and
lindsey graham uh uh had thought they
had won um and then uh cheney uh well
through addington
the president issued a
a signing statement that seemed to
minimize that and then of course we have
the military commissions act chaney has
been
incredibly influential uh in in the
torture debate and what's interesting
about that is that if you talk to
professional interrogators
they will tell you that torture is
really not the best way to get
information um that they're
it's much better to to try
to use a sort of good cop bad cop
befriend the person you're interrogating
and bring them over to your side
so why the emphasis on the ability to
torture is especially when people will
say
that it it endangers our troops in the
field because if if we're doing uh if
we're if we're using interrogation
techniques uh like waterboarding and
things like that uh then certainly uh
those could be used on our soldiers if
they're captured um and it comes down
again to uh to the executive authority
you know and and and what happened in
the ford administration to some degree
cheney believes uh it doesn't matter i
think so much whether torture is an
effective means of interrogation or not
cheney believes that the the the
executives should have that authority
and that's something that the president
should be able to order if he believes
it's necessary and that there shouldn't
be any oversight over that so i think
that's really what that's about and so
much of what has happened in the past
six years uh is along those lines
whether it's the energy task force and
lou can can speak uh uh quite a bit
about that um or or any number of of
issues that are going on
right now freedom of information act and
whether documents should be released
comes down to cheney's conception of
what
a wartime president should be allowed to
do
what explains the influence of changing
on our president
is it that we have a common mindset
uh is it that one is obesity to the
other
what is the basis
um what explains that the the uh
cheney's uh
influence with the president uh i think
a lot of it has to really has to do with
experience i i mean
george bush for all of his personal
political talents and his enormous
seductive ability in sort of a
one-on-one relationship with with
members of the texas legislature
although there hasn't been much
seduction going on with with with a
congress for which he hold that he holds
in very low regard the institution uh i
just think that i think that there was
just an enormous experience
that that not just cheney but the entire
staff in the office the vice presidency
had that that it was it was almost
inevitable that they were going to suck
all the oxygen out of the out of the
west wing
i mean these are guys you know this dick
cheney was was was uh
kneecapping henry kissinger and ending
the career of of
of nelson rockefeller when george bush
was was playing pickup basketball to
downtown hawaiian houston because i was
there and he couldn't go to the right uh
uh believe it or not uh i mean so so you
have uh
i mean you have you have this you have
this team this incredibly experienced
team
and you have these you have a team that
comes in from from
from texas and a president who's
determined it seems to to of skew all
advice from his and and assistance from
his from adult adult supervision from
his father's administration i just think
it was natural that they were going to
take over
and and also i think
bush puts a premium on on on loyalty
and and one thing that that cheney is is
he's loyal he he's you you have a
conversation with cheney in the oval
office you will not be reading about it
in the newspapers which bush has said
repeatedly is something that he really
values and and i think that that was
very important
for bush
he felt that he could count on cheney
that cheney wasn't going to go
off the reservation and and and sort of
have these back alley fights that were
going to spill out into the press and
make
bush look bad cheney would never say
anything uh directly that would make
bush look bad and i think
for bush that was really important
yeah of course there's some
who's who's leading who here who's who's
being loyal to who i mean is cheney
actually
the one with the reigns but um the other
question is is uh the profiteering from
the war and anyone who's seen this um
movie lately uh iraq for sale i mean it
is just gut-wrenching to see what is
going on and halliburton is very much
one of the
you know the ones that is accused of
profiteering and of course you think
halliburton you think cheney so
what about the connection there i think
there's a clear connection uh
you know uh the i mean beyond beyond the
profits at halliburton it was in his
final act as uh one of his final acts as
secretary of defense and and to give him
credit if you if you talk to
active or retired brass at the pentagon
everyone considers him perhaps the
finest modern secretary of defense
not so anymore because the same people
will tell you that he's also left the
army badly broken it will take a number
of reconstitution bills and generations
to fix it that's not the answer to the
question uh the answer to the question
is that he he created the mechanism with
halliburton as secretary of defense by
which these contracts are left uh as he
was at the end of the bush and minister
the first bush administration the one we
in texas consider the good bush
administration um uh uh he um
dick cheney uh secretary defense cheney
uh uh commissioned halliburton uh to
write a report it's i think it started
at 3.9 million and then there was an
additional five million to write a
report and a contingency plan that would
basically establish how uh
what we consider the quartermaster
function of the army could be outsourced
so uh halliburton uh got the co wrote
the contingency report and then in in in
a violation at least to this the spirit
of
protocols of contracting protocols then
they bid on the contract and it is the
contract that's known as the log cap
contract uh an acronym but it's
logistics contract that they that they
still have in iraq today so there is a
direct link and and you know did he do
it because he was going to halliburton
well i don't know but halliburton hired
him shortly thereafter uh in part for
his rolodex and i don't think they hired
him to thank him i just think that it
was a it was a good a nice coincidence
and then michael mobs
yeah
[Music]
well
i mean
what what kind of role chaney had in in
the awarding of of subsequent uh
halliburton contracts uh
really big ones you know billions of
dollars uh is an open question and and
one that that uh maybe henry waxman will
have uh better luck in in ferreting out
the answer to but uh he did say on meet
the press uh cheney did that uh that he
had absolutely no role whatsoever in in
the awarding of those iraqi contracts to
halliburton his former company um
well we we discovered that in fact uh
scooter libby had been consulted before
those contracts were awarded and had
been apprised of negotiations and what
was going on
so it it sort of defies
uh belief that uh that that libby who
wrote to work with cheney every day uh
they and their wives dined together they
were very very close they had known each
other for decades uh would not have
mentioned to the vice president that uh
they were seriously considering giving
a huge sort of unprecedented contract to
his former company
i have a question about the energy task
force that you mentioned in full
disclosure i work for a nuclear
information and resource service which
is a anti-nuclear group here in dc
but the secrecy that you mentioned
before that none of the meetings of the
task force are knowable
and like you said the executive branch
is
foia ebola and natural resources defense
council foia the energy secretary
on who he met with in the lead-up to the
chaney energy task force the nuclear
power industry was the biggest number of
meetings it was 19 meetings with the
energy secretary in a matter of january
february march april may of 01
and then after that was big oil at about
10. so i'm just curious about you know
the role of nuclear energy institute on
the energy task force ken lay on the
energy task force and
what do you think about all that
well i think it was unprecedented
secrecy uh for uh for a uh um
for what should have been to make what
what was the making of of of lasting
public policy it started uh you know 20
days into the bush administration
the uh the
the meetings were arranged
so uh there's a fact of the federal
advisory committee's
commissions act thank you carolyn the
federal advisory commissions act
would
generally require a group when a group
of lobbyists it does require by law when
a group of lobbyists sits down with a
with a member of the administration
that should there's it requires
transparency
they by by
by including one or two members of uh of
the administration in every meeting they
created they they circumvented that law
uh that what we do know from it we know
because of of judicial watch and the
nrdc who who first did foias and and
then when they couldn't get
of the from the executive agencies went
to court starting in gladys kessler's
court judge kessler's court and
litigated it until that some of those
names were finally released uh what do
we know i guess in dick cheney's memoirs
we'll get the whole story uh and and and
and you know ultimately or and and
congressman henry waxman's uh subpoena
uh request we'll get more of that
information because it was congressman
waxman who first who first uh asked for
those names and for the meeting notes
and and he never got them uh i think
an aside there and and in canada
candlelight showed up on one day in
april cheney cleared his calendar he
knew ken lay from uh from texas we all
know we all know now can lay from texas
the lake can lay from texas
he cleared his calendar they met they
talked about price caps in california
the next day the very next day
the vice president a vice president who
is known to be averse to talking to the
press
calls the
the la times sacramento bureau out of
the blue uh this this beef reporter gets
uh and columnist gets a call and says
would you like to speak to the vice
president of the united states
he says yes and he and he and he and
dick cheney gets on the phone and he
beats this guy on the head with ken
lay's talking points which were
no price caps in california
uh no no regulation of the california
market the california legislature made
their own mess but but enron was was
making four to four to six hundred
percent increase in profits while while
california while people were going
without lights whether brownouts uh
electricity rates were up three to five
to fifteen hundred percent and and the
vice president of the united states on
the day after he met with ken lay did
his bidding and only was saved by by by
by the fed by ferc who who ruled in
favor of
which ruled ultimately favor prize caps
yes well speaking of beating people over
the head um
um
dick cheney i although i haven't read it
yet john dean in his book uh
conservatives without conscience talks
about the authoritarian personality
and you know from everything that you're
describing you know beating people on
the head torture
ground zero rejecting iran's offers
letting
death and suffering you know i guess we
would say
that he's uh sadistic sociopathic uh
ruthless um
i mean mean cruel
and so
i mean it's not really yeah i guess
there's a question of how we get people
like this to lead us and maybe now
hopefully we're
less vulnerable to that but my question
is how did he
get to be that like what about his life
his childhood um what do you know about
how he got to be like that
you know sometimes you wonder if it
didn't have something to do with a
little league
uh you know he was a star football
player he was a star football player it
it is a puzzlement uh i i mean um
he uh
you know i've written about bush before
but dick cheney is a much more
interesting character because he has a
much more interesting character arc
uh he was he he was you know a hardened
conservative by by sort of a congenital
conservative i think because he was born
in wyoming
of conservative parents but you know i
think he he showed up in madison uh when
when in this in the 60s when uh when
campus unrest was was was really scary
for a guy who believed in conservative
american values and was from wyoming uh
he was disturbed by that i just i i
don't i don't know i i mean we didn't
try to get uh too much inside his head
um
but his family of origin as parents
you know he had
a normal
his parents were democrats his his dad
was his dad was a bureaucrat and and and
and and a democrat who who ultimately
like much of the west gradually flipped
and not flipped but converted to to
republicanism and and which was a better
fit for the conservative west i think
that might be changing too uh but uh
it's it's it's a bewilderment uh maybe
jake is uh has a few more ideas but
maybe not
can you tell us anything about the
relationship between cheney and gates
and what cheney may be
looking for in his secretary of defense
and who his choice might have been i
don't i'm stopped
i think it's it's
unfortunately it's it's a little bit too
early to tell what went into the gates
decision uh gates is certainly someone
who who they would be comfortable with i
would think he's got a lot of texas
connections um you know he has a the
intelligent stuff he he worked with uh
with with bush's father he's someone who
might be able to bridge the two
uh you know those two worlds the world
of cheney
and the world of uh of uh of of of
george bush senior um
i don't know i mean i i think that that
that that cheney was probably sorry to
see rumsfeld go
um and and how much he was a factor in
the gates decision uh is something that
the reporters are really going to have
to ferret out
uh i i i don't know even more than jake
doesn't know but but i have a friend in
the audience who's pointing me in the
right direction i mean we're looking at
the return of of the adults from the
first bush administration we're looking
at james you know james baker is is back
and he's going to have to he's going to
have to paper over the the disaster and
it really is nothing less than a public
policy in a foreign policy disaster in
iraq and and brent scowcroft is always
is always pushing the right the right
candidates and and people who are are
capable of really serious adult
supervision into the white house and and
and it seems like perhaps they they
finally uh with with today's decision
uh succeeded what's interesting is how
how it was just a vertical collapse i
mean they could have waited a couple of
days to save face but the day after the
election
uh
you know it was remarkable it was just
it was it was a it's it's one of those i
mean we really this is this this is one
of these remarkable moments in american
political history that really see has
the feel of of a tectonic
shift of the place now what happens over
the next year with those place grinding
uh remains to be seen but it's it's a
different morning we woke up to today in
washington well i was awake with it at
three in the morning anyway but it is a
different more morning which probably
shows but uh there we go
stepping backward could you give us any
insight into what cheney's role might
have been
in preparing
america
uh before 9 11 and preparing america for
911.
well he was briefed bush wasn't uh you
know in in in
richard clark's book you you have uh you
know you have cheney in in the in the in
the presidential emergency uh center at
the bunker under the under the east wing
and you feel like the right guy is there
uh george bush is is is
reading to a class in in florida
elementary school class in florida you
know he did that a lot when he was
governor
he did i'm serious he did those reading
circles again and again and again i mean
i went to so many of them and he and
laura
were reading to kids and i thought well
that was good but we got a state to run
here you know we got an environmental
crisis but but you had the sense that
the right guy was there he had he had
been briefed on both the clinton plan
and he had been briefed on the the the
clinton back plan on on on al qaeda and
he had been briefed on on uh the richard
clarks clark's current plan
and and you had um uh condi rice had
been briefed uh uh colin powell had been
briefed yet the yet the president of the
united states who was reading to a group
of children in california had not so i
think he was he was the man he was
florida i'm sorry uh one of those long
states uh he was uh
he was um
he was the right guy in the right place
i think and he was he was there at that
moment and i i feel a little better
knowing that he was there rather than
rather than my former governor
okay let's take the two questions two
men in line for the last few questions
okay brief i'm just wondering if you
could talk more about the relationship
between cheney and uh kissinger because
there seems to be something in terms of
cheney's reaction to the real politic
that kissinger was putting out and then
cheney's conversion to a more neocon
perspective and i wonder if that'll give
us some insight as to how cheyney may
react or what his relationship was with
baker in uh bush 1.
i'll i'll start and we'll
kick it over to luke uh that's a a meaty
question from frank smythe again why
could i just add sure sure
gristle to it as well um uh what about
the relationship between cheney and bush
senior i'd be interested to if you could
fold that into your answer as well i'd
be interested in that
you've got one too
hey you me smith were on the same you
know now that was
adding to that as well i mean one of the
defining interim scene political battles
in the 70s was the antipathy between
cheney and rumsfeld on the one hand and
hw
bush on the other and even in the first
bush administration
when cheney was selected as sec-def
there was some murmurings about that and
that came up so i guess i guess all i
think all of us are sort of asking the
same thing which is
when you look at the relationship
between hww cheney and rumsfeld
uh when you guys were
researching the book i mean what were
you able to glean any new insights as to
how these people how all of them have
related to and with one another at
various points in time
the kissinger one is is a very
interesting one because uh
there was not a lot of love between uh
rumsfeld and cheney and kissinger in the
ford administration i mean uh they
cheney and rumsfeld felt that kissinger
uh was too soft on the soviets uh and
they they were not big fans of ditant
and and they didn't uh they were they
were constantly
there was a
an orgy of leaking going on in the ford
administration which is
another irony that relates to today but
a lot of them were leaks against
kissinger and there was a lot of
suspicion within the white house that
they were coming from rumsfeld and
cheyney
um
as a way to sort of undercut him and in
fact with the halloween massacre when
when when they named uh bush uh to head
the cia and rumsfeld was moved up to
secretary of defense for the first time
kissinger
had his dual role he was secretary of
state and national security adviser and
they stripped the national security
adviser away from him and named
scowcroft instead um
in in his stead so it it there there was
a lot of there wasn't a lot of good
feelings about that but then you have uh
woodward's book which just came out that
says that they have been consulting with
kissinger
which in and of itself is is kind of
interesting and some of that i think
does go back to
to to to vietnam
kissinger kind of escaped vietnam uh
relatively clean uh it ended up being
other people's faults at fault and not
really kissingers um and so i think that
as as we're mired in in a war that's not
going particularly well
um that is starting to create an
iraqi syndrome
to displace the vietnam syndrome um that
they might be looking to kissinger for
for his insight and and and my guess is
that that's probably been uh difficult
for cheney uh to stomach to some degree
because uh he at least when he was a
young man in his thirties he felt that
he knew better than kissinger um at
least when it came to uh to foreign
policy vis-a-vis the soviets um the
relationship with with with george bush
senior is is a complex one as well i
mean there's certainly been a
you know the people around uh poppy bush
have have been very critical of of
foreign policy and have said that
they're very disappointed with cheney
when he was secretary of defense he was
a great as as lou said a a fine
secretary of defense but he was on a
short leash and i think that was part of
the
why people were so surprised when he had
a long leash sort of absolute power to
some degree operating out of the vice
president's office
that
that he went in the directions that that
he ended up going and i think it was a
surprise to a lot of people um including
george bush uh george h bush
and his conclusion in conclusion can i
conclude uh not not to not to agree too
much with my esteemed colleague the
nobel prize peace prize is not an
exoneration
i think
i mean jake he does bear some
considerable responsibility for for
vietnam i do think that jake touched
upon what is the the the the real irony
that a a man who started out
who who stood outside his west wing
office as nixon ordered troops out
as forward-ordered troops out of out of
uh
out of vietnam and and and watched the
presidency collapse with a promise to
someday rebuild it was really the when
you get into personal psychological
stuff that's what scarred dick cheney
not not little league uh you know watch
watch the uh watch the presidency
collapse under the weight of of
watergate and resolving then to to build
rebuild this imperial presidency has if
the one one particular general i talked
to said the army is broken the troops
are broke the equipment is broke i
talked to someone at the cia's who said
he went out there 13 times and he beat
up on our 8 to 15 times and beat up on
our analysts the agency is a fragile
bureaucracy it's also broke so the
imperial presidencies that he set out to
to to to a restore seem to have uh it
seemed to have come to a completely
opposite end and with that i should
thank you and turn the microphone over
to barbara who is
gracious enough to have it
stephen hayes in a recent interview with
radio host jim bohannon talks about his
new biography of vice president dick
cheney
this is an hour
hi there and good evening welcome to the
jimbo hammond show from westwood 1 radio
we're at
1-866-5-0 jimbo 1-866-505
and on the web you'll find us at
jimbotalk.net
and by the way you will in the very near
future also be seeing this particular
program
on c-span's book tv on c-span 2 camera
is in studio tonight taping us so you
can't tune in now stay with this radio
station but we'll have posted on the
website
jimbotalk.net just when c-span 2 will be
carrying this particular interview which
is with a senior writer for the weekly
standard and the author of a number of
books including his latest cheney the
untold story of america's most powerful
and controversial vice president
published by harper collins stephen f
hayes good evening great to be with you
how much cooperation did you get from
the subject in putting this book
together
uh i had a total of 30 hours of
one-on-one interviews well i guess we
could call that cooperation that was
cooperation it was uh i went in frankly
i didn't know how much to expect
one of the things i had said at the very
outset was that in order to do this book
and to do it right it would require
access and require you know not only
time and interviews but i wanted to take
trips and see how he operated overseas
and on political campaigns and i really
had an opportunity to do all that
about three years ago he was quoted as
saying am i the evil genius in the
corner that nobody ever sees come out of
his hole
and he added it's a nice way to operate
actually
it has always struck me and i haven't
been around the vice president that much
i've seen him speak in public a few
times but it always seems to me that he
has a very bemused attitude about this
machiavellian image that is placed in
him now it may be true
and we'll ask you how true it is but it
always seems to me that he finds it
rather amusing well i will say i'm going
to steal your use of the word bemused
because that's exactly the right word
and i didn't have it in the book
it is he he is he it's almost as if he's
sort of playing with it when he's asked
a question that was in an interview with
usa today and he's asked this question
and he gives that kind of an answer
which sort of exacerbates uh exacerbates
uh that that stereotype and uh there was
a one point at which i was talking to
him we were talking about the ford
administration and
his run-ins with nelson rockefeller who
was ford's vice president this is when
cheney was chief of staff in the ward
the ford white house and he said uh
just at the end of a description of one
of their uh their shouting matches he
said
vice presidents are a sinister crowd you
really have to keep an eye on them you
know he's always got sort of one of
those kind of lines
grew up i guess much of his early
childhood was in nebraska right right
how did his father dick senior get there
uh he was working for the the
soil conservation service uh
at the time was a new deal era
department uh in which he was monitoring
soil to see if it was suitable for
farming things of that nature at one
point he had a choice i think between
going to idaho or casper wyoming right
and as it turned out uh he chose wyoming
and thereby history was set in motion
that's right that's exactly right he
chose he chose casper and and
young dick cheney then just a teenager
moved in and started playing baseball
and football and joined all of uh
made some friends and went to the
library and
settled in casper a jock uh popular uh
was known to touch a bit of the brew in
fact that would come back later to to
haunt him in a number of ways in many
regards as i read about the early dick
cheney it occurred to me uh boy this guy
could almost be george w bush in a lot
of ways uh early party life reaches an
epiphany and a turn toward the sirius
but many parallels even right down to
the yale attendants
yeah it's interesting i mean the the
i would say the difference is when
george w bush uh you know
realized that he was drinking too much
he cut it off and cut it off cold turkey
now i don't think cheney ever had sort
of a moment where he thought i was you
know i'm drinking too much but he was
arrested twice
uh in the period of nine months for dui
and had had a moment where he said you
know okay it's time to clean up my act
but interestingly he didn't
quit drinking entirely he sort of i
think moderated his behavior how did he
meet this girl named lynn vincent
he approached her actually in class one
day um he was looking for a date this
was high school to a dance this is in
high school yeah he approached her
now they disagree uh lynn and dick
cheney disagree about which class it was
actually
but he approached her and and
asked her basically asked her out and uh
and her response was are you kidding me
he thought that this meant that he had
been turned down or she had no interest
to take it or yeah and uh and in fact
she was excited it was it was a sign
that she was excited to go with him um
but but my favorite part of that passage
in the in the book is is the way that he
explained it because it's sort of a
romantic first date story how did this
all come together and uh
and he was explaining the confusion and
he ended the story by by saying simply
we got it sorted out in short order you
know
sort of typical dictionary typical very
very uh cut to the chase kind of dick
cheney how did yale enter the life of
this young man he was actually recruited
by a local casper oil man who was lynn
cheney's boss at the time she was doing
some work for a guy named tom strzok and
he was a local recruiter for yale and
and dick cheney had done well in high
school he was a standout athlete and
strook recruited cheney and his best
friend tom fake and said
why don't you guys go to yale that's
about all it took it was the only school
that cheney applied to because he was
virtually assured of admission
and
that didn't work out too well it didn't
work out too well he had i think he had
he had made his way through high school
uh and done it with ease he didn't have
to apply himself in order to do very
well
and i think he took those same study
skills or lack of study skills to yale
and they didn't serve him as well when
he was thrown in with people you know
who in many cases had this had been a
life goal and and perhaps they'd gone to
a year of finishing school
so he did not take to yale very well
but uh
he had continued nagging i guess from uh
from lynn right she was really really on
his case you know do better try harder
because she was going to a school of
considerably lesser prestige and i got
the impression that maybe
she was kind of jealous that here's a
guy who gets this chance that i would
die for and he's squandering it well
yeah yale was at the time an all-male
institution so she wouldn't have had the
opportunity that that he had and she
certainly pushed him i mean she was
really at natural county high school
which is where they went to
high school together she was really the
star i mean she was
a champion baton twirler she was
sort of the a plus student she was
really the standout and cheney was a
good student but but probably not quite
at her level um so i think yeah i think
you're right i think she certainly
pushed him again and again to do well in
school may 21st 2001
george w bush is invited back to new
haven to address the yale graduates and
he said to those of you who received
honors awards and distinctions i say
well done and to the c students i say
you too can be president of the united
states a yale degree is worth a lot as i
often remind dick cheney who studied
here but left a little early so now we
know if you graduate from yale you
become president if you drop out you get
to be vice president
it was a funny story and when uh when
cheney was telling me about well i
looked up that story and we were talking
about the uh the
the joke
he said that when bush told him in
advance of the speech that he would be
that he would be doing this
uh he said that bush couldn't get enough
of it just laughed and laughed as he
told him that he was gonna gonna tell
that joke
we're talking tonight with the author of
cheney his name is stephen f hayes and
he is the author of a book published by
the good people at harper collins cheney
the untold story of america's most
powerful and controversial vice
president and we are by the way uh on
the c-span or will be in the the next
few days or so you can check c-span
2 and their book tv website and also you
can take check our jimbo talk
website and i will tell you when this
particular interview will be played back
cameras rolling tonight but uh radio of
course remains you're a key to hearing
this whole story tonight on the
jimbohannon show from westwood one and
we will continue in a moment brought to
you by simplegreen.com
let non-toxic simple green keep your
gear clean from boats to bikes and cars
to campers simple green cleans at the
speed of life learn more at
simplegreen.com
we'll be back here at westwood one
and these are our
humble surroundings here since of course
when you're on c-span you never go to a
break right right
always remind guests of that
we may not be on the radio but we are
still on tv it's nice of you to remind
guests i bet you'd maybe make some news
if you didn't well i i could i've had uh
i've had a number of notable people here
when the c-span cameras have been here
and i won't name any names but i'm
pretty sure that i saved at least one
reputation once
yes i am i think it'd be unfair of me to
mention any names but it's a name
everybody knows
now they had
and he should have known better of all
people this particular person should
have known that the c-span cameras are
are everywhere yeah it was kind of funny
but uh yeah here we are in our uh posh
but not overly ostentatious studios
we usually remind people by the way if
that camera tilts up of the the fact
that we are in america's only radio
studio with a mirrored ceiling you
get a chance to catch that
we don't know why
it was here when we got here
i can only tell you that we occasionally
stare at it
much as the primates in the movie 2001
wondering if there is some cosmic
significance to that ceiling
but anyway
for those who've been curious about what
this show looks like we got all your
computer screens here
and uh
i don't actually use these two over here
i'm not sure what they're for but uh
they look good they look very very
impressive
others others here actually do use that
i i i've never had the need to so i just
don't know
but
if i ever figure it out i'll let you
know
so where do you go from here on your
tour
well we're doing uh i'm actually taking
a a day off tomorrow i've got my
brother-in-law's bachelor party down in
austin texas oh no we're giving some
phone interviews
from down there uh and then we return um
sunday night and monday we
take off again mostly media in in and
around washington for now you ought to
call matthew mcconaughey i don't know
all the places to party in august that's
right that's right
well there's there's we went there we're
going to go there because there's a
great live music scene lots of blue
wonderful music scene yeah yeah there
sure is
or uh
oh who was it whose birthday it was
today uh sandra bullock from austin no
was it really she just turned 43 today
she doesn't look 43 no she doesn't
but when she's 83 she won't look 40.
[Music]
welcome back to the jim bohannon show at
1-866-50 jimbo
six we're 1-866-505-4626 with stephen
hayes senior writer for the weekly
standard and the author of cheney
published by harper collins and
subtitled the untold story of america's
most powerful and controversial vice
president so here you have dick cheney
who's uh stubbed his toe along the way
to his academic career but
finally gets his act together back in
wyoming
yeah after uh after his his two arrests
for uh dui
he uh had a stern talking to by his wife
i think and and
decided to uh to go back to school at
the university of wyoming he got his
bachelor's got his master's
from there and then actually set out on
a course uh to become an academic in
political science
and at one point he had some
opportunities uh he had an opportunity
to run a campaign and at the same time
that he was coming really close to i
guess getting his doctorate and rather
rather abruptly told well you can be a
politician or you can be a political
scientist which dick cheney thought was
kind of an unfair choice that's exactly
right there were several of those
instances uh where he had to essentially
choose between
a life as an academic and life in
potentially in government and politics
and uh the first couple times he stayed
on the path towards academia and uh and
the last time obviously
he decided i'm gonna i'm gonna make the
move to politics there was a story in
here that of all things involves uh a
democratic senator from maryland joseph
tidings
and uh
well just to quote dick cheney years
later if it hadn't been for joe tithings
i wouldn't have come to washington it's
interesting that a democratic u.s
senator would be responsible for
launching such a prominent republican
career how did that come to be well
tidings was involved with a fellowship
that uh that cheney had applied for that
would would have brought him or that did
bring him to washington dc
and they had they had a beer in madison
wisconsin where cheney was living at the
time as he
as he was applying for this fellowship
and tidings when he had this beer with
cheney knew that cheney had already been
selected cheney thought it was a job
interview so they had sort of a an
interesting discussion and cheney
eventually came to washington and and
the rest is history
and had cheney by this point made his
political affiliation and viewpoints
known
he hadn't and and tidings said when i
talked to him that it wouldn't have
mattered he thought cheney was an
impressive guy regardless of his
politics but
you know one of the most interesting
things that i found in putting this book
together was that
you know the man who's considered a
pillar of the modern conservative
movement
uh really had no ideology until uh you
know well into his late 20s after he had
been in washington for quite some time
so it was i guess what september of 68
dick cheney comes to washington and uh
to do what he was part of a
congressional fellowship program uh that
brought him to work he was supposed to
have spent part of his time with a
member of the house part of his time
with a member of the senate and he came
and worked for
a young
republican from wisconsin named bill
steiger who was a regarded as a real
up-and-comer in the house of
representatives
he served in a number of positions with
the nixon administration how did that
come to be
well he worked for steiger and then
eventually that job led to a job with
donald rumsfeld who was going to the
next administration to run the office of
economic opportunity
which was a fairly liberal program for
the knicks administration it was a
poverty program um chaney worked for
rumsfeld
at the office of economic opportunity
and then they together went to the cost
of living council which ran
richard nixon's wage in price controls
which is really one of the more
sort of anti-free market uh undertakings
very actively
in recent american history at the time a
considerable
outcries of certainly from the
conservative wing of the republican
party barry goldwater was very incensed
at nixon
and and others and any number of
democrats were saying well maybe this
next guy is not so bad he's trying to
step in there and clamp down on those
prices this i guess was the the first of
many occasions in which dick cheney and
donald rumsfeld would come in close
proximity does either man have
recollections of their first impression
of the other
yeah they do
the first interview actually cheney went
to interview before he took the
internship with
bill steiger he had seen donald rumsfeld
speak as part of the very first part of
this this congressional fellowship and
was impressed with rumsfeld and set
himself up with an interview
looking potentially to go work for
rumsfeld who was then in congress and
they had this interview and by both
accounts the interview went horribly
chaney said that he was busy trying to
impress rumsfeld with all of his
academic knowledge and and he thought
rumsfeld was was short and curt and uh
and the interview lasted 15 minutes and
cheney says to this day it's the worst
interview he's ever had
well something must have worked i guess
so uh
things progress uh both uh gentlemen
obviously showed a certain amount of
acumen at working within the bureaucracy
and uh uh of playing the game as it were
and it is a a game the consequences can
be serious and important but nonetheless
you have to know how to play and
obviously both men had serious aptitude
for this
then uh when gerald ford assumed the
presidency after watergate then dick
cheney moved to the white house how did
that come to be he did well ford had
been close to rumsfeld from their time
in congress and and when ford
came to the white house he first asked
don rumsfeld to come and help him with
the transition uh rumfeld came helped
him with the transition and later was
taken on as ford's first chief of staff
and rumsfeld brought cheney in as his uh
his top deputy so he was you know in a
matter of of eight years he turned
around this this uh young man who had
brushes with the law uh had turned his
life around was in such a rapid fashion
that he was now the number two staffer
in the white house
at uh
at one point
he uh we became white house chief of
staff that's the position that he held
of course throughout the the rest of the
the ford administration and at this
point he is on on a fast track obviously
he's he's a comer how old is he by by
this time he's going to be 34 i was
going to say he was born in 1940 so he's
34 years of age he's got the world by
the tail
and then after ford leaves office
it's 1977
and cheney decides his next career move
will be to run for congress right he
wants to run for office and he's not at
first sure what office he wants to run
for there was an opening in wyoming for
the senate um but there was another
young uh
rising young wyoming political star
named al simpson who was uh wanting to
run for the senate seat and cheney went
and met with the head of the republican
party in wyoming and said look i'm
interested in this senate seat too and
the head of the wyoming republican party
said to cheney you have no chance al
simpson is going to run for the seat um
he used some more colorful language that
i'll i'll spare for now i appreciate
that
but
in any case there wasn't an opening so
simpson ran for the senate seat and
there wasn't an opening immediately
until unexpectedly the incumbent
member of the house of representatives
from wyoming the man named tino roncalli
of wyoming's only member of the house
announced that he was retiring and
cheney quickly after that decided to run
for the house and and
announced his campaign and a statewide
seat too in the fact that wyoming only
has one member of congress so he has to
run all across the state how was he on
the stump had he ever been anything like
student body president had he ever
actually campaigned for anything before
yeah he'd had some experience in in
student government in high school but he
said it was really mostly just a social
um outlet it was not something that that
people took seriously and he wasn't into
speech making or anything
um
he he did reasonably well by all
accounts on on the stump i mean he's not
you know he is not a glad hander he's in
some senses he's not a typical
politician he doesn't enjoy
sort of shooting the breeze
for hours on end with people he doesn't
know but i think in wyoming what was a
real strength is the ability to actually
communicate your ideas and to be blunt
to be straightforward with voters and
certainly cheney has has those qualities
and so the dick cheney career continues
and we will continue our discussion on
just uh how it became because uh again
this is a man who is not that well known
everybody thinks they know about dick
cheney but in fact most people don't
know that much about him and he is a man
who let's face it has
achieved much in his life and much
controversy along the way we'll continue
our discussion and uh invite you to join
in as well at 1-86650
jimbo
1-866-505-4626 with our guest stephen
hayes the author of cheney
it is published by
eight
harper
collins
five oh jimbo will take a call or two
after these messages
i remember the last time i had len
cheney on but that's been a long time
ago is it yeah boy that was she's good
that's been at least 20 years since i've
had oh you're kidding me oh yeah yeah
she was was she the national endowment
for the arts for the humanities
humanities
yeah exactly that's why i had her on is
that right long long long time oh that's
interesting
well she's working on a book now um on
uh on life in wyoming growing up in
wyoming
i believe it's out this fall if i'm not
mistaken i know we'll just have to uh
check that out yeah it could be
interesting you know i when i started
researching i i didn't imagine that i
would become so interested
in what life in wyoming was like in the
in the 40s and 50s and it's fascinating
to remember that history it was it was a
pretty still a pretty uh
in many ways almost a 19th century place
it was in a lot of ways i mean you had
little pockets cheyenne and casper but
right uh of course another guy who who
had an interesting connection with uh
wyoming was uh ted kennedy who was put
in charge of uh western states for his
brother in 1960 and you can actually
rode uh a rodeo bull i guess at one
point is that right i didn't know that
go back to the uh
the democratic
convention in los angeles in 1960 it was
wyoming that put
jack over the the top on the first
ballot and it was teddy who was in
charge of seeing to us that that
happened that's interesting i did not
know that yeah
something i've got a picture
uh kennedy and and
john mccain
used to do a series of debates on my
morning yeah right america in the
morning and we went up to capitol hill
to uh to do a photo op but to the two of
them and it was it was a kind of a
a fun thing to see some of the
memorabilia that ted had when we were
taking the pictures by the way this was
really funny we're standing out there
just doing publicity shots just standing
there like statues on easter island you
know and then mccain suddenly decides
hey it's a debate and so while they're
snapping away he whips out his fists
and so ted kennedy whips out his fists
and i get between them like a referee
and we got some wonderful pictures it's
funny
it was really yeah those i guess two of
those shots are among my most cherished
do you have them do you have them here
with you i don't have them here no if i
did i should have brought them in
tonight i should have thought about that
i should have brought those pictures
there yeah it really was but you know i
never got either one of them to sign it
i've gotta you need to do that
absolutely
i did get one picture signed one night
we had two guests back to back the most
unusual guest you could ever imagine
james baker secretary of state or i
guess former secretary of state at that
time and boy george oh you're kidding
saddest little man i ever met in my life
and as the two were passing by each
other i said hey pose for a picture and
you can see the picture baker's look
like you know i'd strangle you if i cuz
i have this wonderful shot so i was
telling bob schieffer whose office is
just down the hall here at cbs about
this he knows baker so he borrowed the
picture from me had a copy made and sent
it to baker who autographed it you're
kidding me
that's fantastic here we go
welcome back to the jimbo handed show
we're at one eight six six five oh jimbo
1-866-505-4626
talking with stephen f hayes senior
writer for the weekly standard and the
author of cheney and he had 30 hours
with the vice president to put this
together along with many many many other
people and some great stories we've
already heard that i had never heard
before let's go to uh dubuque iowa where
lee calls in tonight good evening hi
there jim uh thanks for your good uh
work and uh to your guests there i just
got
the radio squared away
in
89
summer of 89
my
squad of
light fighters out at
forder on california the high desert
we met
then secretary of defense dick cheney
out there in the high desert it's
standard procedure for motorized
vehicles when they say infant when they
see infantry on the ground
that don't have a vehicle around to go
over and ask if they're okay if they
need water or something like that
and uh the other guy i wasn't there
actually when the secretary defenses uh
humvee pulled up but the other guys who
met him they said he was just sitting in
the humvee like an ordinary guy
and they came by and stopped and asked
ask him if they had water if there's
someone who's coming to pick him up and
everything else and we all thought
you know that was that was pretty good
that here he was secretary defense head
man of the whole
army navy air force and marines and
his humvee stopped by to
check on some uh some infantrymen on the
ground so
from from that personal observation i
guess uh
i'll look forward to reading uh your
book fantastic any thoughts about this
actually it may typify how dick cheney
approaches the job yeah there are there
are two two things that that sort of
jump to mind one of the one of the the
interesting articles i found from a
local wyoming paper
back when cheney was a member of
congress
this local columnist happened to run
into cheney at the denver airport
which was where where he changed planes
and the columnist wrote a column
actually about dick cheney traveling
alone without an entourage carrying his
own bags and
you talk to people who have known him
over the years and he absolutely abhors
the idea of having an entourage of
having people follow him he doesn't like
to be driven around he loves to drive
his own car
very interesting what was this solo trip
across country after he left the office
of a defense secretary he just hops in
the car like jack kerouac on the road
yeah sets out across the country yeah
what was that all about well it's it was
it was you know
you come across a lot of surprising
things as you put together a a book
that's that's this long
um
and and
that was one of the things that i found
most surprising is you know he finishes
his time at the pentagon and he hasn't
really driven a car for for his entire
time as secretary of defense i mean
that's a bit of an exaggeration but he
decides he wants to take a long driving
trip so he takes a solo cross-country
driving trip that totals about eight
thousand miles wow by himself that's a
lot of sidetracks there's only you know
about 3 000 lacrosse he went up to
canada he did some fishing he went down
down down across the country he went to
florida he was all over the place that's
too much all right does that answer your
question lee well yeah he he very
definitely seemed that way as far as i
can recall from the troops he was
sitting in what we call the shotgun seat
and
another
one of the guys from florida and the
permanent personnel ford erwin's the
ground equivalent of top gun the whole
battlefield's on
laser and everything else right rugged
high desert terrain
we were very impressed that he uh
stopped by and checked on us humble uh
uh sergeants and corporals well i guess
so you don't see the secretary of
defense out there every day i'm sure
thank you for that call lee we're at
1-8665-0 jimbo 1-866-505-4626
and here's mark in monin pennsylvania
hello good evening excellent program
very typical
um i've been around both the vice
president and lynn cheney separately
but never together with them as a couple
i observe strength of personality
independence intellectual gifts my
question
how well does that relationship blend
any thoughts on the chemistry
well they're not you know this won't
surprise you and i did not uh i didn't i
spent some time with them together but i
did not spend a ton of time with them
together
they're they're not at least in my
presence outwardly you know showing
emotion they're not you know i think
when you think of bill and hillary
clinton for instance they're often
dancing or or uh you know or hugging or
embracing or something like that you
don't see that a lot with with the
chinese but but by all accounts uh they
have a very strong marriage he relies on
on her advice
on just about everything and she is you
know she is his intellectual match
and so i think they spend a lot of time
talking about
you know
world world events world issues um i can
believe that i've interviewed her and
she is very shy very sharp yeah she
doesn't you know just try to show it off
but if you if you go off into any area
of policy you see very quickly that
there's substance there they both they
both have such a tremendous grasp of
detail when you talk to them about
you start to engage on an issue or now
that she's you know spending more time
writing histories
her grasp of detail is is the kind that
would sort of blow you away there's
something else that you brought in the
book that cheney
that is to say vice president dick
cheney
is a big detail man and you indicated
there were times when during briefings
uh because george w bush is a reagan guy
he's an overview guy he's a big picture
guy and you said that there were
occasions when dick cheney would
pointedly ask detailed questions in a
briefing just to make sure that the
president the commander-in-chief was
exposed to the question and the answer
in
making his decisions right that was
particularly on their intelligence
briefings because cheney has an
intelligence briefing
first thing in the morning before he
goes to the white house he has it at his
residence in washington and then he goes
to the white house and sits in on the
president's intelligence briefings and
he will on purpose
you know ask questions about
certain issues that he thinks the
president should get a longer hearing on
and we'll come back and take a look at
some other aspects of
dick cheney in terms of intelligence
issues did that cover what you wanted to
know mark
excellent superb i noticed just one
little detail with him he was very warm
and personable especially with my
daughter really turned on the
grandfather button uh yet by the same
token
lynn seemed to stick with her love for
the policy wasn't that she was
indifferent to individuals it was almost
a flip of what you might normally expect
in a situation like that
but both tremendously gifted and we
enjoyed being around each of them
very good thank you for your call more
to come at
oh jimbo 1-86650 eight six six five oh
five four six two six and as family has
come up this would seem as good a time
as any stephen hayes to bring up uh the
sexual orientation of one of the the
cheney's daughters uh obviously uh it's
a private matter and yet of course when
you're vice president of the united
states it isn't especially coming from
such a conservative background as as
dick cheney
yeah it's it's um
interestingly a lot of things that
people don't know about and mary cheney
covered some of it in in her own book um
this summer she came out to her parents
in the late 1980s and and
said that that when she came out to her
father
as gay he he responded exactly the way
that you would want a father to respond
one thing that people don't know very
often is there was a a campaign
while dick cheney was
secretary of defense and presiding over
a policy uh
that this was before bill clinton's um
don't ask don't tell policy and cheney
sort of in his public appearances anyway
sort of half-heartedly in my view
defended a policy a more rigorous policy
that excluded uh gays from serving and
at the time
there were gay activist groups that were
threatening to out marry cheney publicly
and and
then secretary of defense cheney was
getting phone calls at his office making
these threats and and there were phone
calls made to uh
to lin cheney's office as well uh
threatening to out out their daughter so
it was one of these things that you
don't you know there you see them in
their public capacity you saw him as
secretary of defense carrying out his
duties there without any real knowledge
of just how uh you know what was going
on in his personal life at the time more
to come with our guest stephen hayes the
author of the book cheney it's published
by harper collins we'll be right back
here on the jim bohannon show from
westwood one
and i would like to thank brian lamb by
the way for publicly noting that among
the many people he listens to i'm on the
list i appreciate that thank you brian
brian lamb is an american hero yes he is
an american
most
most unassuming american hero you'll
ever meet but and and is rather
uncomfortable i was at uh what was it
was it a roast of him i'm trying to
think of the american news women's club
yeah i emceed that that night
and uh
and he did very well of course and
responded to
everything very well but you could see
that there was underneath there was a
genuine
uh lack of of comfort with the notion
that he should be put on a pedestal i
would think which i i found and
everybody else did found very very very
very appealing uh very becoming because
that's not no phony act that's the real
deal
so usually for the time i talk to an
author they've already got another book
in the works you got anything else
you're working on no i need to talk to
my wife
well there could be that i know i've
gotten rather busy of late yeah you
could you could talk to my wife about
taking on another project
yeah it's uh
this one took a lot of a lot of time so
i'm not sure she'd be enthusiastic and i
think you need you need a break well i
think unless you just are one of these
professional authors and i've never
fully understood
i've never really understood those
people uh
when your whole life
is it's one master's thesis after
another
i could never do it i mean i and i maybe
maybe it's because i really
you know threw myself into this and
you know i was
at the ford library for two weeks and
going through all the back bins and i
was too lazy i'll just flat out admit it
i really i wouldn't i wouldn't have it
in me to i mean i i would not i would
flag i would just see my i think my
problem was that i don't have
i'm not sure i have the best filter as
to what's interesting and what's not so
the ford administration stuff i i just
became obsessed with the ford
administration i thought it was
absolutely the most fascinating period
and i knew something of it from you know
studying in school but i didn't know as
much as i obviously had to come to know
well it was the healing administration
from the the most serious constitutional
crisis in the nation's history yeah and
and people can overlook that very easily
he served less than a term he was never
elected in his own right it's right to
dismiss gerald ford but right
but
many countries have
have changed governments and forms of
governments and lost their freedoms in
the aftermath of something as intense as
watergate and right
uh you got to give a lot of credit to
gerald ford
well in the end i think that you know
the controversial pardon
was so controversial at the time having
read you know read about
everything that all of the upheaval
now it's i mean it's not quite universal
but there is i think a general or an
emerging consensus that it was probably
the right thing to do
[Music]
welcome back this is the jimbo handed
show with our guest stephen hayes senior
writer for the weekly standard the
author of the book cheney from
harpercollins
at one point i gather cheney was almost
blackballed from working in the ford
white house how did that come to be yeah
well it was it was a result of his two
duis what happens when you when you go
and work at i mean you know this what
happens is you have a a full field
investigation done by the fbi which is
an exhaustive investigation in which
they speak with
pretty much everybody you've ever had
contact with and uh the fbi then went to
gerald excuse me went to donald rumsfeld
after completing the full field
investigation and said
hey we're not sure about dick cheney
we've got some issues with him and and
rumsfeld called cheney into his office
and said what is this i hear about two
dui's
and cheney told him the story and
rumsfeld's the most important question
for rumsfeld was
did you disclose it on the form or did
they have to find it out on their own
and cheney said no no i put it down on
the form and rums rumsfeld said
fair enough
walked in to see president ford then
managing a constitutional crisis and and
according to rumsfeld had a long
conversation with president ford making
the case that dick cheney uh should be
able to continue to serve in the white
house same issue came up when he was
being confirmed for the the job of the
defense secretary and uh i think it was
john glenn who's then an ohio senator
asked him why there wasn't a third dui
and he said i got married and stopped
hanging out in bars right exactly
i cut to the chase kind of guy it's
interesting to note
that
uh
cheney was not in favor of deposing
saddam hussein after the first gulf war
very interesting uh to go back and look
at the the speeches and the answers he
gave there was one in particular that i
quoted some length
from a question and answer session that
he had at the discovery institute which
is a think tank in seattle
where he basically runs through
some of the very problems that we're
seeing in iraq today he says
you know we would have difficulty
determining friend from foe in street to
street fighting and the ethnic the
potential ethnic tensions between kurds
uh shiites and sunnis could be could be
problematic as well
what can you tell us about how his view
changed in the intervening
dozen years or so well he was making the
same arguments um
really through the the 2000 election he
was defending the decision by the first
george bush not to uh remove saddam
hussein um and defending it quite
vociferously
i think that the change for him came on
september 11th when you know these he
had spent a good bit of his time
studying
the the nature of the threats against
the the u.s homeland and obviously that
that day turned these threats from
theoretical
into real life and and he said saddam
hussein is no longer an acceptable risk
and he was he cheney was i guess in the
room when the ford administration made
the decision that regardless of how many
times the north broke the cease-fire
agreements in vietnam that we were not
going back in we were out to stay he was
he was there do we have his input on
that decision on what how he weighed in
on that discussion no he was he was uh
at the time i believe he was chief of
staff at the time and and saw his role
as chief of staff more as a facilitator
not as someone to actually weigh in much
on on policy questions
one eight six six five oh jimbo is our
number one eight six six five oh five
four six two six we have a call from jim
in columbus ohio good evening thank you
jimbo yes sir um mr stephen hayes yes uh
it sounds to me as if you've written a
book to praise dick cheney rather than
to uh honestly assess his uh worth as a
public servant quote unquote
um i don't know that uh it's necessarily
i mean i don't know it seems me warts
and all were included but uh well well
sir i haven't read the book i'm sorry
jim no no go ahead i didn't know that
was you speaking but uh the thing is i
don't i don't want to criticize a book
that i haven't read but uh the thing is
i noticed a couple of uh strange things
about dick cheney number one he himself
never served in the military but he
apparently had no compulsions about
starting an unnecessary war which
resulted in hundreds of thousands of
iraqis being killed and three thousand
uh 500 and plus uh american soldiers
being killed and secondly he seems to be
as a neocon as a member of the famous uh
project for a new american century uh uh
uh always promoting democracy in the
middle east but he's absolutely fighting
for the opposite right here on american
soil well we'll put you down as
undecided sir and uh we must have a show
with some night when you can just sit
down and filibuster for an entire hour
but i'm sure that the views of jim are
not at all uh atypical of many out there
in the audience uh first of all the lack
of military service uh was he uh was he
a father early on and therefore deferred
because of that uh he was he was he
received student deferments actually uh
several times and
um
[Music]
he was he his
eligibility draft eligibility came
actually at a time
when vietnam was really just
starting to heat up i mean it was sort
of a you know the gradual escalation was
the time when when he was eligible he
wouldn't have been eligible to serve
later when really most of the casualties
took place but he made a comment uh at
his confirmation hearings in 1989 that
really has followed him around it's a
comment that a lot of people
remember when they think of dick cheney
because he was asked outside of the
hearing room i believe by a reporter
from the washington post
why he didn't serve and he said
something to the effect of i had other
priorities than serving at the time
and i think that's you know
stung a lot of people
who think he took it sort of cavalierly
so i asked him about it i said what did
you mean by that and he said what you
have to understand is as a phd student
i was focused this was at a time when
vietnam was was not yet sort of the
national obsession that it became
um and people weren't focusing on what
was going on in south asia they were
focusing on living their lives and in
dick cheney's case uh
you know finishing his studies and
briefly as we go to the breaker the
other point that was brought up by jim
in columbus would have to do with those
who feel that dick cheney is somehow an
authoritarian individual the deep down
inside he he like he does as the caller
says like freedom more for others than
for us you've got his support for the
patriot act and his support for the
guantanamo detentions and and what many
people consider to be questionable
methods of interrogation for those
people it seems like every time there's
a question of humane or uh or free that
chain is on the wrong side how does how
does dick cheney view his his thoughts
on such i think i think he
views himself as a
september 12th leader um you know i
think
a lot a lot of people uh including a lot
of people out in the country uh have
have um
sort of moved on with their lives after
september 12th uh after september 11th
and uh you know don't
probably we're not as concerned we are
living our lives as as as you know the
president and leaders of the senate said
at the time to do and and
uh dick cheney believes that he doesn't
have that luxury more to come with our
guest stephen hayes in the book is
called simply cheney we'll be right back
here at westwood one
oh i almost forgot if you would be kind
enough to sign this for me i'd like to
add it to my
personal library thank you
i love the uh
uh i love
the callers who are
so interested in that project for a new
american century do you get many of
those not a whole lot uh we get more on
the council on foreign relations or
fluoridation with water i think than
that right
it's uh pretty much the same colors too
yeah probably well it's it's it's funny
because our offices were for a while not
we were down the hall from
you know what's shortened as pinac
and you know it was two people or three
two two and a half people i think
full-time staffers uh
it's not nearly the
the global conspiracy that some people
think it is
well i know that there are some people
out there who whose lives would truly be
empty if they couldn't wrap themselves
around a conspiracy theory i mean
i i really think those people exist
right
i mean it fills a void in their lives
and i suppose this beats drug use or
any number of other
ways of
dispensing with anti-social views
thank you
well i can tell that i can tell that you
actually spent some time
reading the book which is not well it's
not always the case no it isn't always
the case i've just always felt that
uh that's what you ought to do i mean
yeah you know well your your questions
quite clearly reflect
that fact well thank you
we have delusions of adequacy what can i
do
it's so great you have the c-span
cameras just sitting here you know
basically it's your beck and call during
the break though
so brian lamb why don't you come on my
show some evening we'll just talk about
c-span i mean
this is like having his his private cell
phone number
the fact that a few million other people
are are watching in is irrelevant right
right make your plate naked exactly you
can follow up and say so brian exactly
one of the offer exactly yeah
so
[Music]
welcome back this is the jim bohannon
show with our guest stephen hayes he has
written the book cheney it's published
by harper collins how did he go about
the process of deciding that out of 300
million americans that he was the best
qualified to be vice president
well he initially wasn't so sure he was
best qualified to be vice president um
what was interesting in researching the
timing of of the discussions between
then governor bush and and
dick cheney was that
governor bush first asked
cheney about the possibility of serving
as vice president in november of 1999
which is even before the republican
primaries and uh
cheney said basically i'm not interested
i've got a commitment here at
halliburton i'm not interested in
going back into government
thanks anyway and
governor bush tried again and tried
again finally got cheney to agree to
serve as the head of the vice president
presidential search committee
and uh and
every time or not every time but but
often when cheney would come and brief
governor bush about the candidates that
he had vetted bush would end the
conversation by saying
dick you're the answer to you're the
answer to my my problems you can solve
my problem so it was it was sort of a
gradual process and when i interviewed
president bush he said yeah i really had
my eye on dick cheney the entire time
and
having him as
running the vice presidential search
allowed me to have more time with him to
sort of make my case what now for dick
cheney he's got a year and a half left
in this administration he has not uh
decided to run that left this is the
most wide open presidential race since i
guess 1928.
and uh what's he gonna do
i think a lot of fishing
um probably a lot of fishing and a lot
of time with his uh with his grandkids
he has a house out on the eastern shore
of maryland so that he can be close to
washington i think without being in
washington and uh and he's got another
house out in jackson wyoming which is
where i i expect he'll spend quite a bit
of time
any thoughts he ever might run for
public office again or rejoin a big
company like halliburton no i think he's
done i think he's i think he is looking
forward to spending time with his with
his grandkids interesting stuff well
it's it's a fascinating read i must say
about one of the more interesting people
ever to hold this office one that has
been derided as being insignificant
and i would only say
that depends i guess on who you are and
the opportunities you have and the
opportunities you make
our guest again is stephen hayes and he
has written the book cheney the untold
story of america's most powerful and
controversial vice president it's
published by harper collins i'm jim
bohannon on westwood 1.
we'll do this little five-minute
interview here for my morning show boy
that was fast well good we hated when
they dragged we have no desire for it to
uh to drag certainly
stephen hayes is also the author of the
connection how al-qaeda's collaboration
with saddam hussein has endangered
america
he's a senior writer for the weekly
standard
on the web at weeklystandard.com
they haven't done any of that
okay thank you caller thanks for
watching thanks for calling in well
this is a new book just hitting the
market this week it's called angler the
cheney vice presidency the author is
barton gelman who works for the
washington post on the side and just
finished writing this book mr gellman
joins us from our new york studio good
morning
hi how are you doing good mr gelman i
would like to start there there seems to
be some recurring themes in your book
about vice president cheney and i'd like
to i'd like to
have you
draw out on some of those themes and and
one of those is
vice president cheney's influence
he is
enormously influential everyone says
as a kind of a cliche he's the most
powerful vice president
in history i would say you cannot
understand the bush administration or
what happened these last eight years
without understanding that there were
important moments when cheney took the
helm either with
george bush's direction his tacit
consent or every now and then without
his apparent knowledge it's also true
that
the president stepped him back sometimes
and grabbed the wheel and turned away
from cheney's direction and that over
time chaney's influence waned
and mr government that kind of goes hand
in hand with a with another recurring
theme which is his autonomy
he had
a
blank check really from the president to
get himself involved in whatever area of
policy interested him
and
because he knew the levers of power so
well and because he's a detailed man
because he's extremely focused on
achieving his objectives
he had a way of sort of reaching down
into the bureaucracy where
he would be present
and involved at levels of decision
making that vice presidents don't
normally get involved in so
he would talk to a deputy assistant
secretary or a deputy chief of staff in
a cabinet agency he would attend
meetings of the cabinet principles when
the president was not there that's
something that vice presidents never did
before
he would sit in on the policy
coordination meetings at the white house
on economic policy or on
personnel appointments
and it didn't matter whether he chaired
the committee or not
the mere presence of a guy who everyone
stands up when he walks in the room has
a huge influence
another issue mr gellman in your book
and you give examples of all these but
another issue was his willingness to
expend political capital
yeah this is the thing about dick cheney
he's about as close a thing to an
anti-politician
as
we've had in high elected office
he
believes that
the purpose of a president and an
administration is to do the right thing
to do what's needed he has very firm
ideas about what's needed
and so if
it's going to be politically damaging
he's going to tell the president and he
did this on
in his advice for example that there
ought to be universal vaccination for
smallpox because he thought
that there was a terrorist smallpox
threat and despite the fact that it
would probably lead to hundreds of
deaths from side effects
he said to the president you will be
harshly judged by history if you don't
if you don't take that step and instead
there's an attack that kills thousands
and mr gellman
vice president cheney and secrecy are
what you refer to as stealth
yeah that's part of the reason that i
chose angler for the title it is of
course his secret service nickname and
its overt uh basis is his love of
fishing but i thought it was a good
metaphor for the way he approaches
power he tends to move obliquely he
prefers not to leave
obvious traces
a simple example
he is the
father and creator of the military
commissions that were established
to try alleged terrorists and to strip
them of
all rights under u.s sovereign law and
international law
he did so by having his lawyer david
addington draw up a four-page document
brought it by hand into a lunch with the
president
walks out an hour later
and then passes this document around the
chain in the west wing
so that it changes hands four times and
by the time an hour later after that
that someone brings it to the oval
office for signature
that person doesn't even know that it
came from cheney
and
almost no one else inside the federal
government had seen this order which was
highly consequential first thing that
happened
when it was announced was that
colin powell picked up the phone and
called his senior aide on this subject
and said what the heck just happened
except you didn't say heck
and finally barton gellman before we go
to calls about the cheney vice
presidency
is it fair to say that you you have a uh
grudging admiration for his abilities
and his capability
i look there's nothing grudging about it
i'm very interested in
what he did and how he did it and
what really happened and
anyone who studies management uh and
i've had a few people who are at very
senior executive levels you read it and
say
you know
good god this man was
astonishingly effective he he understood
organizational control he understood the
mechanisms of decision making he knew
when to intervene when not to
uh
to what ends uh is obviously a matter of
political debate and and dick cheney has
been
repudiated by public opinion in a way
that no other vice president has before
him he
surpassed uh dan quayle on the most
unpopular list some time ago
but his ability to make things happen is
extraordinary
and i'll just say one more thing
one of the reasons is the most
pedestrian and obvious and yet so rare
dick cheney just about always knew
exactly what he wanted if you think
about any group of people you've ever
been
around
even if the decision is as trivial as i
don't know
bowling or a movie tonight half the
people in the room are on on the fence
and dick cheney's not on the fence and
that's a huge advantage
and you write cheney's most troubling
quality was a sense of mission so acute
that it drove him to seek power without
limit his indifference to public opinion
and important constraint on most office
holders verged on contempt
you know take a look at
everything he's ever said if he uses the
word polls in the sense of opinion polls
he is explaining why they don't matter
and why politicians should not
follow them and especially why the
president should not be guided in any
way by public opinion
he
has a long-standing view that public
opinion and by extension also congress
which is which is much more attuned to
public opinion
is sort of feckless that people change
their minds that
they
are ill-informed contradictory emotional
and that the stakes
of big government decisions are so high
and in his own view
he understands so much better than other
people what needs to be done
that
he just can't be guided by what
the people think who hired him
barton gellman is our guest his book is
angler mr gellman did uh
vice president cheney grant you any
interviews for this book
none not for this book uh i actually
have talked to him quite a lot over the
years back when he was secretary of
defense and i covered the pentagon
during the first gulf war
uh as vice president he has
he i i think it's fair to say that he
has uh become disenchanted with uh his
his ability to tell his story he
believes that
most of the mainstream media is against
him and unsympathetic to the president's
objectives and as i say he's a very
focused guy if he has a specific
objective
that he thinks will be advanced by
talking
to the public at large he'll go for a
live unedited
program like meet the press
otherwise he's talking mostly to
conservative activists conservative
newspapers conservative
radio shows
he allowed me to
come on one flight on air force two for
this book and to observe him close up
but
when he decided to talk to a reporter on
that flight he took my seat mate
into his private cabin and my seat mate
was from the washington examiner do you
think that was a little dig toward you
i
think it was nothing personal only
business
let's take some calls los angeles you're
on with barton gelman of the washington
post and author of angler
yes hello i just want to say that um
cheney has worked with the jinsa crowd
and pushing us to go to war with iran
like he did with iraq for israel
mr gelman i yeah i
don't think that's accurate he certainly
is uh sympathetic to many of the uh of
the uh
jinsa uh
arguments and this i get the acronym
writes the
jewish institute for national security
affairs maybe something like that it's a
group of very conservative
israelis and israel sympathizers who
believe iran to be a strategic threat to
israel
i think that he certainly has a very
strong view that israel is an essential
ally and that iran is likewise a threat
to american interests i where i where i
differ with the caller is
i
looked very carefully at this question
and i'm not at all sure that the vice
president is in favor of actual war with
iran he understands quite well
how enormously costly that would be that
if if if anyone thought iraq would be
easy no one thought iran would be
and he
certainly is interested in regime change
i tell the stories in
this book
about secret meetings that he had with
iranian
opposition leaders i guess it would more
accurate to call them sort of would-be
governments in exile he was meeting with
the
the son of the late shah of iran he was
meeting with a grandson of the ayatollah
khamenei who has turned against the
government and is looking for american
intervention
this
has some parallel to his uh his uh
meetings and alliance with ahmed chalabi
in iraq but it does not mean
he was looking for to sort of send the
bombers off he's looking for any way he
can to pressure
the iranian government
so that it topples but that's a
different matter entirely fort worth
texas
uh yes looks like fair and scott palin
have have learned quickly that it's who
you know know what you know but
do you go into chinese little meeting
with these oil people
and um
the um
what am i trying to say the um
energy task force
that bush doctrine
uh yeah well i go i spend quite a bit of
time on the energy task force uh his
objectives
and
the impact that it had not
so much on production of energy
as
on deregulation as on as on uh
scaling back
uh decades of protections
of uh air quality water quality uh
and uh the uh sort of pristine condition
of national parks he believes that in
the sort of balance between
sort of public use economic use uh
recreational use and preservation that
the the scale had been tipped far too
much in the direction of preservation
and he believed uh
not only believed in but was able to
affect changes in
regulation that that made it easier for
example to build a coal burning plant or
to avoid
costly upgrades that would clean the air
more
i also talk about
his
impact on the doctrine of preventive war
which is which goes far beyond
pre-emptive war preemption is a
long-standing
and although it's controversial it's
it's
got a fair amount of support this
doctrine that if you're just about to be
attacked if you are under imminent
threat of attack you don't
have to under international law wait
until the blow actually falls preventive
war is
to ward off a potential threat that's
still some time down the road and that
was one of cheney's major contributions
next call for barton gelman comes from
peoria illinois
hello
please go ahead
uh yeah
as far as the
dick cheney vice presidency
the reason in my opinion uh
why uh mr cheney's so controversial
is uh due to the fact of his
um
his uh experience as a as a public
official i mean he was uh uh
he was a
head of the uh
head of the uh defense department
and you know
the things are that are uh
that our uh
you know our uh
international stand and whatnot goes
back to
back to then i mean
as far as when we went into iraq
uh he back in 91 the reason why we
didn't go into a rock chain he said that
it would you know cause
all of these different problems and uh
this would happen and and there'd be an
uprising and and we went into kuwait
instead of going into iraq because of
those those things and now that he's
gained more power now we're going into
iraq and now we're doing all of these
things it's just in my opinion public
officials don't need to
you know once they've served one office
i don't think it's fair for them to
serve in any other offices because of
corruption
mr gilman
i actually think that
dick cheney
at a personal level in terms of uh
questions of uh
venality or self-dealing that have
sometimes been raised you know the idea
that he's trying to enrich himself or
his buddies or halliburton i think
cheney is one of the most incorruptible
politicians i've known he is not about
personal ambition or personal
accumulation of special advantage he is
a guy who is principled
to
to the end and the thing about uh
zealous advocates of principle who are
unbending against
opposition and public opinion and
and other kinds of costs i mean
principal people over the years have had
a lot of had a lot more impact on the
world than uh
than hypocrites uh and uh for good or
ill
cheney has followed
what he believes and he's been quite
upfront about what he believes he has
been willing on a tactical level
to be quite deceptive i would have to
say in order to get his way
and certainly to
to
undermine
process that he used to say he believed
in the idea that everyone ought to have
a shot at the question that all ideas
ought to be vetted then and so forth
but what he's after the and what he
stands for the idea that we face a
mortal threat from
terrorists who might one day get weapons
of mass destruction and um need to have
uh warrantless
nsa surveillance need to have what he
calls robust interrogations
these conform quite closely to what he's
actually done in office in fact mr
gellman you talk about uh the
incorruptibility you you talk about when
he first came into office and the
halliburton stock and that brouhaha and
how he did not mention that to the press
what was that
well the thing about cheney he is he is
so secretive about uh
not only his uh
public affairs but also his personal
affairs
that he did not make public information
that would have been to his advantage he
was he was
it was a matter of
public record that
he received a large payment from
halliburton just before taking office as
vice president he never bothered to
explain that
this was uh contractually
obliged on on halliburton's part that
halliburton was unable to reduce or
increase
the number
and uh that jenny also had
big big stock options uh and he
relinquished them he gave the away
millions of dollars
in order to avoid any possibility that
he would have a motive while in office
to uh
buck up halliburton stock
so
the value of these these stock options
to him would have
risen or fallen based on the stock price
of halliburton in order to avoid any
possibility of a mixed motive he uh he
established a foundation to give all
that money away
and mr gellman you also talked about
deception and maneuvering could you tell
very quickly two stories one involving
uh former epa administrator christine
todd whitman and former majority leader
dick armey
yeah in the case of christy whitman at
the epa
she was very eager to make sure that
george bush kept his campaign promise
to regulate emissions of carbon dioxide
bush as candidate
embraced the science of global warming
acknowledged it to be a big problem
acknowledged carbon dioxide emissions as
a major part of it
chaney was the driving force
that persuaded the president to
uh reverse himself and and i'm able to
reproduce in the book a lengthy story
involving
memos from cheney's staff that explain
the strategy of how we're going to turn
the president around and bottom line is
he got bush to sign a letter again in
one of these one-on-one meetings without
anyone else present
just as he was aware that christy
whitman was on her way to the white
house to make the case to bush that he
shouldn't sign it and as she's arriving
cheney's leaving with the letter in his
hand and he personally delivers it down
in capitol hill
and uh
you sorry you asked about the army uh
dick armey who was then the house
majority leader republican uh
texan highly conservative
was nonetheless very skeptical of the
need for war with iraq uh in the fall of
2002 and in fact said so
that summer
this was a critical vote
for the white house because if you have
the majority leader of the governing
party voting against and speaking
against the war that gives a lot of
cover to democrats who wanted to vote
against but were afraid to look soft
and bush invites him to camp david uh he
arranges special briefings nothing is
changing army's mind and so
cheney according to army and he speaks
on the record to me at length in the
book
cheney invited army for a one-on-one
briefing and he told him that saddam
hussein had personal family ties to
al-qaeda and that iraq was developing
miniaturized nuclear weapons and so this
creates a scenario of a
suitcase nuke in the hands of a man who
is
pals with al qaeda and might hand it
over and that changed army's mind
and it was entirely false it's nothing
like the public accusations that cheney
made that were based on controversial or
uh or unvetted evidence this was just
flat made up and if he said to army what
what army describes then he was not
telling the truth and army says
flatly in the book that he he believes
cheney uh best him but he's he's spelled
out the barnyard epithet
round rock texas you're on with barton
gelman good morning gentlemen uh first
of all you know uh
do you write about uh
the way that cheney tried to use every
deferring he could to keep from going
into the military i'm a republican and
i'm an ex
i'm a vietnam veteran too you know i'm
tired of these uh people like bush and
cheney that don't really have the
military experience
sending people to war when they did
everything they could to get out of the
war
mr gelman
i focused very sharply on the cheney
vice presidency with uh with very few uh
side trips back into his past i didn't
have anything to add on this uh cheney
acknowledges that he got
multiple deferments
and there have been criticisms just like
the callers many times when he was asked
about this some years ago
he told one of my colleagues at the
washington post that he had other
priorities at the time it didn't go down
too well with veterans one of the lines
uh that you use in the book is that dick
cheney is a guardian against soft
sentiment
he thinks of himself as the ultimate
realist he thinks of himself as
being willing to
look hard truths in the eye to
keep his mind focused on things that are
scary and
dangerous that other people prefer not
to think about and so if you take a look
at his public remarks
he is
often talking about
the need for unpleasant choices and
unpleasant decisions
uh he is uh the sultan of the unpleasant
uh
that so when when he used the words
darkseid in the famous interview on meet
the press not long after 9 11.
he was
pretty clearly uh
stating where he came from
on this and and i think he knew very
well what kind of image he was invoking
the
2000 campaign like you know every
campaign before it had been filled with
the old uh star wars uh imagery of darth
vader and the force and the dark side
and and uh
in that it's been become part of pop
culture that the dark side is the uh
the sort of flip side of the force it
confers great power at the expense of uh
some humanity and
that's what he thought was necessary san
diego good morning
hello hi
yeah
hi i want to do uh i i think i have to
disagree with mr gelman about
romanticizing cheney whether he was not
corruptable or principled it led to the
same place
meaning is we went to war with iraq it
took the eye off the ball of pursuing
terrorists in afghanistan and now here's
the thing that's really important you
don't have to worry now about guys
carrying suitcase bombs around or yellow
cake uranium because now what has
happened because of iraq now you have a
restored soviet union or a republic of
russia
okay mr gellman
i i
think that romantic is about the very
last adjective i'd use to describe my
book it is
it frankly doesn't have a whole lot of
adjectives in it this book is a book of
storytelling this book of narrative this
tells you scene by scene
the vital events of the last eight years
and where cheney was in them i'm able to
reproduce meetings and dialogue and
you know you have you have a private
meeting in army's office you have a
midnight visit to the white house
council
at his home and he comes to the door in
his
bathrobe and pajamas you have cheney in
his undisclosed locations you have a
a
private meetings in the president's
private office and i'm able to
reconstruct
a narrative that tells what he did i
leave to the to the reader and the
viewer
to decide
whether that was good or bad my job is
to bring it to light mr gelman you also
seem to speak with uh several
disaffected former friends or colleagues
of dick cheney frank keating uh lamar
alexander
dick armey
were there were there a lot of those
people
look i did
hundreds of interviews for this book and
i also drew upon interviews that that
were done
back for the newspaper series uh
with my partner in that series joe
becker and
over time i was able to persuade people
to go on the record with their private
views there are a lot of people who
speak here either for the first time on
the record or
for the first time about
the most difficult subjects and those
include also the
the
white house chief of staff andy card and
condi rice and james comey at the
justice department i you know i spoke
with john ashcroft and karl rove
steve hadley josh bolton the current
white house chief of staff
and
frank keating as you mentioned was the
governor of oklahoma a very good friend
of george bush a shortlisted
candidate to be
bush's running mate in 2000 and he
believes that cheney
leaked confidential information from his
betting file to embarrass him and to
destroy his prospects of becoming
attorney general
what he said is that dick cheney coming
into his life has been like a black
cloud
barton gilman washington post reporter
and author of angler the cheney vice
presidency thank you for being on the
washington journal
what did you win the pulitzer for
was for the series on the vice president
called angler in the washington post and
it's available at washingtonpost.com if
you want to read the series from the
book thank you sir thank you
uh henry paulson treasury secretary
henry paulson will be doing a press
conference in just a minute or so that's
a live picture from the treasury
department we'll be bringing that to you
live originally we had scheduled a
mortgage options seminar from the
american enterprise institute that will
be over on c-span 2 and henry paulson
will be live here in just a second
again on booktv.org
you can find the entire schedule for
book tv this weekend which is on c-span
2 48 hours all about non-fiction books
history public affairs politics finance
all public affairs books you can see
right there if you want to go a couple
of things to note is that as a big new
brzezky and brent scowcroft two former
national security advisors
have a book out together and they are
featured this weekend on our afterwards
program
and our political block on book tv
begins at about 1 pm in the afternoon if
you don't get enough politics during the
week and you want some more the books
that we feature they could be about the
candidates they could be about history
uh you know past elections they could be
about issues and if you go to uh
booktv.org you can see on our political
block from 1 to 6 p.m eastern time
several different books a couple that
are featured this weekend includes
stephen mansfield uh he has a new book
out called the faith of barack obama he
wrote a book called the faith of george
w bush also and phil valentine the
conservatives handbook he's a radio talk
show host and that's his book those are
two of the books featured this weekend i
think coming up will feature one on the
1800 election and some other things so
booktv.org if you want to see that
barney frank is our guest this weekend
on newsmakers that airs at 10 a.m on
sunday and 6 p.m on sunday also and that
of course will be about the current
financial situation facing the united
states and the world henry paulsen enjoy
your weekend
good morning everyone
hope you got a lot of sleep last night
now
last night the federal reserve chairman
ben bernanke
so
good morning everybody
welcome to the american enterprise
institute i'm danielle pletka i'm the
vice president for foreign and defense
policy studies here at aei
let me first remind everybody please to
turn off their telephones or to put them
on vibrate
and ask everybody when this session ends
to please remain seated in order to
allow our speakers to leave the room
a final housekeeping note booksellers
are available with the book in the
reception after the end of the event
when aei president arthur brooks who
unfortunately couldn't be here invited
vice president joini chaney to join us
today
it was with a view to remembering the
attacks of 9 11 10 years later
and considering some of the lessons
learned
and those that were not
since that day
but the first thing to recall about 9 11
and about the long war that we are still
fighting
is the many who gave their lives
the families who sacrificed loved ones
and the awful loss
first and foremost
now is a time to remember those many
brave americans
who died at home
are fighting men and women who risk
everything so that we can live in
freedom
and our invaluable allies from too many
countries to name
who share our cause
as some of you know
vice president cheney has recently
published a memoir
in my time written with his daughter liz
cheney
we understand it will debut at number
one on the new york times bestseller
list
[Applause]
today he joins us with weekly standard
senior writer and best-selling author
steve hayes for a conversation about
that attack on our nation about
decisions made since then
and some reflections on an amazing life
in politics and
pretty much whatever else he and steve
choose to talk about today in the hour
that we have
in the time remaining after that
conversation we will have a q a session
moderated by steve
lynn cheney has been a scholar at aei
for many years
dick cheney is again a member of our
board of trustees
we're so glad to have them as part of
our aei family and we thank them and you
all for joining us here today
well thank you
i won't interrupt
yeah remember you're a reporter steve
that's right
look i i get my payback
i just wanted to say a word and then
i'll turn it over to mr hayes um
it it's uh the book i wrote is a memoir
uh covers
all 70 years of my life
uh the early years are short
wasn't a lot of good stuff to write
about that period of time
but um
the
last half of the book roughly
focuses on the bush cheney
administration my year as a vice
president and uh the book opens in the
prologue uh
with the um
recounting the events
uh as i saw them on 9 11.
and
then
much of that last half of the book deals
with
what we had to do during the course of
our
subsequent
seven and a half years in order to keep
the country safe some of the
controversies we were involved in on
things like the terror surveillance
program enhanced interrogation and so
forth so that's
a large part of the book is relevant
with respect to
9 11 and the aftermath although i don't
want to mislead anybody there's an awful
lot in there
other subjects as well too going back to
fact i guess i have been five republican
administrations since eisenhower i've
worked in four of them
i've worked closely with the fifth the
reagan administration is part of the
house republican leadership
and so i try to cover
all of that period of time and obviously
there's a lot we had to leave out but
there's enough there that steve's trying
to make a living writing articles about
me
so i'm going to turn it over to him
excellent well thank you and thanks to
danny and aei for having us um
just to give you an idea of what i
thought i would try to do this morning
i'm going to start with some questions
about 9 11 specifically and push you in
particular about your personal views on
these things because i know you love to
kind of put yourself on the couch like
that
public self-reflection
and then i'm going to go and
talk about a number of different ways in
which um
the the policies uh that emanated from
911 that you i think in large part
helped drive and try to fill in some
gaps i've spent a lot of time looking at
the interviews that you've done since
the book came out i've read it now twice
and some questions that i have remaining
for you so i think that's how i'd like
to proceed and then as danny mentioned
we'll throw it open to everybody for
some additional questions that will
probably be much better than mine
so i thought the first place we would
start is on the morning of 9 11.
i would be interested to know
when you first knew we were under attack
not when you first heard about it but
when did you know
we were under attack and what were your
very first thoughts at that moment
well the um
i was in my office in the west wing
working with my speechwriter
when my secretary called in
to report that a plane had struck the
world trade center in new york
we turned on the television and this was
after the first plane had gone in but
before anything else had happened
and um
immediate reaction was to think you know
how is this possible this is a really
weird accident
perfectly clear weather there was no way
to account for it and then as we watched
we saw the second plane hit
and that immediately in my mind
triggered the notion that this had to be
a terrorist attack you couldn't have two
airliners fly into the world trade
center within minutes of each other and
not have it be anything but a
terrorist attack
shortly after that
i talked to the president
down in florida and
we talked about a
statement he was getting ready to issue
a statement and that was whether or not
it was proper to talk about terrorism
within that context of that statement
and we both agree definitely was
and
i believe the words he used was probably
a terrorist attack on the united states
the um
within a relatively short period of time
people began to gather in my office
secretary rice then the national
security adviser was there scooter libby
my chief of staff we probably had seven
or eight people in the room
and then all of a sudden the door burst
open
and my lead secret service agent came in
and came over to the desk where i was
sitting
and he said sir we have to leave
immediately
say you know i'd like to take you out or
please come with me he said we have to
leave immediately put one hand on the
back of my belt and one hand on my
shoulder
literally propelled me out of my office
i didn't have the option of not going
where i wanted to go
and
the
cause for that the reason he'd done that
is he explained to me as he was taking
me down to the presidential emergency
operations center under the white house
was that if he'd received a report over
the secret service radionet
that there was a hijacked aircraft
out at dulles headed
towards crown at 500 miles an hour crown
being the code word for the white house
and um that turned out to be american 77
which of course came in and made a
circle and then went into the pentagon
at that point i was down in part way to
the piac i hadn't gotten to the peak yet
part way to the piac and
i immediately
used a telephone that was there to place
another call to the president
and that was our second or third colette
that morning and
to let him know that washington was
under attack as well as new york
and
the secret service had strongly
recommended that he not come back i also
recommended that he not come back
believing that it was very important for
us to stay apart so that we didn't
become a a riper target and we didn't
know
at that stage what was happening he
didn't like to hear that he didn't like
that at all for understandable reasons
but he agreed to it i think he saw the
wisdom of it
it's you ask what
our reaction that morning was steve we i
went from that spot after i talked to
the president went into the piac itself
and there
i was presented by norm mineta it was
our
secretary of transportation and
responsible for the faa
norm had a list of six aircraft that
they believed had been hijacked at that
point
actually had the flight numbers on them
and of course it was only four but for a
while we thought it was six
and um
there were
sort of two major drivers in terms of
what i thought about that morning and as
we worked through the the crisis that
day number one was we had to get all the
planes down out of the sky
so we could isolate whatever had been
hijacked and account for all the
aircraft including the list we had ones
we thought had been hijacked that point
would account for three of them two of
them in new york and one at
the pentagon
and um so that was a major part of the
effort and the other thing that was very
important
that i focused on was the continuity of
government
and some of you were probably familiar
with
over the years especially during the
cold war
we had developed
programs and procedures
for
[Music]
preserving the continuity of government
in the event of an all-out global
conflict with the soviet union that was
always the scenario
and we'd actually exercise that system
on many occasions and uh it focused on
um
having ways taking steps to ensure that
somebody in the line of succession
survived whatever kind of attack we were
under so that when the dust settled we'd
have a president and the government able
to function and that's what we referred
to as continuity of government that day
it took the
the
form basically i
one was to recommend the president i not
bunch up uh it was very important for us
to stay separated
but secondly was to uh get hold of denny
hastert of course the speaker hastert he
was out at andrews air force base where
his security detail had relocated him
and we arranged for him to be moved from
there to a secure undisclosed location
because he was next in line to the
presidency and if something happened to
the president and me then denny was in a
position to be able to take over and
function as president but those were the
two sort of major concerns that occupied
most of our time one was
as i say getting all the airplanes down
out of the sky and the other was
guaranteeing that there'd be somebody uh
in the line of succession in a position
to be able to take over right speaking
of the secure undisclosed location
um
much of the time when the media was
reporting that you were in a secure
undisclosed location you were actually
at camp david and that's where you went
the evening
of september 11th and i remember having
a conversation with you
much later in which you described what
that was like being at camp david late
that evening and the way you described
it to me was that the family gathered
around the television
you sat basically in silence for a
couple hours watching reruns
of planes hitting the towers and of the
horror that day
what was that like how long did you do
that and what were you thinking at that
point
well it was
after the president had returned we'd
done the
national security council meeting he
addressed the nation
and when we finished that then
lynn and i got on the white top
helicopter on the south lawn
and were flown to camp david
it's the only time i've ever taken off a
helicopter off the south lawn
without being with the president i've
done a lot over the years
but you don't fly off the south lawn
except in those extraordinary
circumstances
and when we got to
camp david
they
took us to aspen lodge which is the
presidential lodge up there
but again for security reasons the
secret service was obviously
totally focused on and concerned about
possibility of follow-on attacks and so
forth and aspen was the most secure
facility
at camp david so we spent a
couple of days there at uh at aspen
lodge
we sat in the
living room watched the television and i
was accompanied by my wife lynn and
daughter liz
daughter mary was out of the country and
rude back by then
but
i can remember sitting there focused
obviously like i think people were all
over the country
um
watching the towers come down
the fires of the pentagon and so forth
and
began to think about what we needed to
do by way of
policy
uh what steps we might take in order to
deal with this this new situation
and the thoughts that came to mind were
the
first and foremost that this wasn't just
a terrorist attack we'd had a lot of
terrorist attacks over the years we
tended to treat them as law enforcement
problems
we'd go out and find the bad guys arrest
them put them on trial block them up
this was an act of war we had 3 000 dead
americans
in a matter of minutes that morning and
we
needed to treat it as an act of war and
that meant
obviously you'd marshal all the
resources of the federal government to
be able to deal with to prevent a
follow-on attack and to deal with those
who were responsible for what had
happened
we had a pretty good idea the afternoon
of the attack that this was al qaeda
related
that was the advice we were getting from
the intelligence community
so it wasn't a big mystery about who was
behind it
by then
pretty well focused in on osama bin
laden
but
there was a lot we didn't know
about al qaeda
now you know we've heard so much about
it for 10 years there's a bit of a
temptation to sort of think we know
everything there is to know about al
qaeda but the uh the day of the attack
this was a group
of terrorists
but uh there was let's say there were a
lot of key questions that that we
couldn't answer right uh we didn't know
how big they were we didn't know who was
financing them we didn't know where all
they were operating uh there was a lot
we needed to learn
and that partly drove
our
our search for intelligence that
generated some of the the policies that
we put in place
and
but i sat as i recall and made a series
of notes on the legal tablet that night
as i thought about
uh what we were faced with and how we
might begin to deal with it and
i sort of chewed over in my own mind
what we needed to be doing
ultimately we all met up at camp david
paul was the national security council
that weekend
um the attack i guess was on tuesday
and that
by friday night
we pretty well gathered up at camp david
spent
saturday and sunday up there with the
president and
began to pull together what ultimately
emerged as our strategy for the global
war on terror
in the days after the attacks we saw
various public officials
in very public displays of emotion we
saw president bush
almost come to tears in the overall oval
office we saw heard about condoleezza
rice going back to the watergate and
breaking down at one point uh because of
the emotional toll that this was taking
on a personal note i remember coming
back from new york driving across the
roosevelt bridge hearing martin sexton's
version of america the beautiful and
i broke down crying did you ever have a
moment like that
not really
you understand that people will find
that it's very peculiar yes
well my wife and daughter were with me
that evening lynn was with me all day in
the uh
she'd been downtown that morning when
the attack started and the secret
service had brought her over to the
uh the west wing and then she
really sat beside me
throughout the day
and so she'd probably be the best
person to comment on
what my my mental attitude was i was
focused very much on what we had to do
i was thinking of it in terms of what
this meant with respect to
policy and our military forces and what
the targets were out there we might go
after how we might go after them and so
forth what kind of intelligence we were
going to need in order to be able to
cope with this new threat
but that's what i recall is wasn't that
it wasn't
a deeply moving
event
it clearly was
but the other thing that that influenced
me
personal standpoint was that i had spent
a good deal of time over the years on
the continuity of government program
and i'd been through exercises where
the
nature of the attack on the u.s
was far in excess of what we actually
faced on 9 11. i mean hundreds of
thousands maybe even millions of people
killed um
so i had the benefit of having gone
through those
uh exercises over the years and and then
training just sort of kicked in in terms
of thinking about what we had to do
that morning and the next day right
let's get to those policies um
specifically let's talk about the two
that everybody i think
thinks of as the most controversial the
terrorist surveillance program on the
one hand and enhanced interrogations on
the other can you describe i think
there's a general sense among the public
that you sort of brainstormed these
ideas you came up with them uh they were
your ideas you've been the most
uh
fierce public advocate
of them
can you describe
how the terrorist surveillance program
came to be
sure
well
it's important to keep in mind they
they
they were initiated at different times
the terror surveillance program is
something we moved to within
days of our time with uh
after 9 11 the enhanced interrogation
techniques really came in a year or two
later when we were in the business by
then of capturing people like khalid
sheikh mohammed who we i believe we
caught him in the spring of o3
and it was the capture of
certain kinds of individuals
that led us to the point where we needed
enhanced interrogation but coming back
to your basic question on the terror
surveillance program
the um
origin of the program
came really from
mike hayden and his people at the
national security agency
and
and george tenet was involved as well
too
there had been a conversation between
the two of them
this is within a couple of days of of 9
11.
as i recall the two of them had talked
and um george mentioned it to me
the basic question being are there
additional things we can do
with our our second capabilities our
capacity to
to
read the mail
that
would help us deal with the situation we
then faced
that led to a meeting in my office as i
recall
where
mike came in then general hayden
then the head of nsa later head of the
cia
and um and george tenet and the three of
us talked
and there were
things that uh
that nsa thought they could do if they
had additional authority
and
i took
that
package of that proposal basically and i
went to see the president
and sat down and went through it with
him
and
he signed up to it
but with the caveat that he wanted it
very very carefully managed he wanted to
make certain that he personally approved
it
each step of the way
and that they had to come back in for
approval on a regular basis
what emerged out of that was a
significantly enhanced capacity for us
to be able to intercept
um
uh communications originating outside
the united states
possibly from what we've referred to as
a a dirty number you capture uh al-qaeda
type he's got a computer a rolodex or
whatever it is he's got his group of
phone numbers on and and uh you wanted
to know who he was talking to in the
united states for example
and um
the safeguards that we built into at the
direction of the president
involved
the fact that every it was every 30 or
45 days it excuse me varied from time to
time
the i think the secretary of defense the
director of the cia
and the nsa all had to sign off
on
continuing the program it didn't get
renewed automatically they all had to
say in writing to the president that
they thought we should continue the
program
from the standpoint of the nation's
security etc
the attorney general had to sign off on
it all of that then went to the
president
dave addington who worked for me
was responsible for carrying it around
and he'd get all the signatures and the
president once he was
had received this input from his senior
advisors
then
he would sign up for it and extend the
program for another 30 or 45 days
and that's the way we operated it for
years
i briefed the
key members of congress i had the
chairman and ranking member of the house
and senate intelligence committees come
down every couple of months to my office
and
mike hayden would come in and george
usually tenant and
we'd brief the
the key for
members of congress who had jurisdiction
in this area over what we were doing and
what kind of results it was producing so
they were wired in from the beginning
later on when some controversy arose
inside the program and with the justice
department
we expanded that group of four into nine
we added the speaker majority and
minority leaders of the house and senate
and
had all of them in
briefed them as well
and then i went around at that point and
asked them all at that point nancy
pelosi was in the group
jay rockefeller
on the democratic side
asked them if they thought we should
continue the program they said
absolutely
then i said do you think we ought to go
back to the congress and get additional
legislative authority to continue to
operate the way we're operating and they
said absolutely not and they were
unanimous on both points they were
concerned that if we went up and asked
congress
for a vote on the subject that the
fact that we were doing it would leak
and uh we'd in effect be telling the
enemy how we were reading their mail so
it was was well noticed notified of the
congress there was
some controversy later on but
internally that the president dealt with
but it was
i'm convinced
a key part of our success in terms of
preventing further attacks against the
united states i think we saved thousands
of lives
by what we were doing i think it's one
of the great success stories
especially with respect to nsa how they
put the program together and develop the
capability and one of the great success
stories of american intelligence and
maybe someday it'll all be told you've
you've made the same argument about
enhanced interrogations you're a strong
believer that
the policies quote unquote worked um
let's go beyond that
uh part of the debate and talk about the
effects of enhanced interrogations and
the perceptions around the world
that it is torture that the things that
we did
amounted to torture
um and the sense that maybe the
moral position of the united states was
eroded because of the things
that we did
um here in this country
how do you respond to those arguments is
that a question or
the invitation to argue the
i i've always
offered you an invitation to argue
those are those are i mean i think there
are crazy there are there are sort of
crazy critiques and then there are more
thoughtful critiques i think that's a
more thoughtful critique
do you
i do not
i
am
persuaded
that the way we went about
seeking the authority to be able to
extract more intelligence from a handful
of individuals we're talking here not
about your rank and file
enemy troop or soldier
this does not involve the military this
does not involve the department of
defense this is a program that was
authorized
by the president signed up to by the
national security council
carried out
with all kinds excuse me of safeguards
by the central intelligence agency
we had a case
excuse me where
we had a handful of individuals
who clearly had
knowledge of what was in the works from
the standpoint of al qaeda
what they hoped to be able to do how
they functioned who the key members were
what their plans were it was people like
khaliq mohammed abu zabeda
a man named
ali nashiri
the notion that somehow the united
states
was uh wildly torturing anybody is not
true
and anybody who takes the time to look
at the program
i think uh
will uh will come to the same conclusion
obviously there are people out there who
differ
with respect to that perspective but
when we get into the whole area one of
the most controversial techniques of the
waterboarding
i think there's a protester out front
this morning when i drove in
commenting on waterboarding
um three people were waterboarded
not dozens not hundreds three
uh and the one who was subjected
most uh often to that was khalid sheikh
mohammed and it produced phenomenal
results for us
there are reports that the intelligence
community did of the results of the
program
which were declassified at my request
and are now available on the internet
that talk about the quality of
information that we got as a result of
our enhanced interrogation techniques
applied to a handful of individuals we
were talking about only a handful of
people who were
indeed
a part of the al qaeda organization
um and khalid sheikh mohammed was not
only the man who
we then had reason to believe correctly
had beheaded daniel pearl
reporter for the wall street journal but
also had uh
claimed credit for the being the
architect of 9 11. killed 3 000
americans that morning
another key point that needed to be made
was that um the techniques
that we used
were all
previously used on american military
personnel
not all of them but all of them have
been used in training
for a lot of our own
specialists in
the military area so there wasn't any
technique that we used on any al-qaeda
individual that hadn't been used on our
own troops first
just to give you some idea whether or
not we were quote torturing
um the people we captured now the the
way the program worked was the
um the agency came in
um
primarily george tenet and still
director of the cia came in he talked to
me
talked to a couple of other people uh
um
basically he wanted
uh to know how far they could go
in terms of interrogations of these
individuals that we captured
and
the
two you really needed two kinds of
sign-offs one was a sign-off from the
president and secondly was the
ruling from the justice department as to
where that line was that you couldn't
cross
and
we sought and obtained both of those
presidents signed up to it as did the
other members of the national security
council
some of my colleagues
may have forgotten that
but in fact everybody
who was a member of the national
security council
was informed about the
essence of the program
and
signed up to it so you had
proper governmental authorities agreeing
that this was necessary and worthwhile
we had the key people over in the
justice department um people like john
yoo who
has been severely harassed because of
the
fact
the legal opinion he and others issued
but they were legitimate legal opinions
from the justice department
said this is okay and appropriate this
isn't gave us a very clear guidance
that we could follow and the
folks out at the agency insisted
on that kind of guidance before they
were willing to go forward now they
one of the things that i found most
objectionable with respect to
the obama administration when they came
in
was the
initial decision by the president
and attorney general holder that they
were going to investigate and prosecute
the people in the intelligence community
who had
carried out this interrogation program
at our direction
and um i thought that was a terrible
precedent to set you've got president
united states to sign up to it he's the
legitimate authority in this case the
justice department has signed up to it
uh these guys have gone out at our
direction
and
and uh
used this authority to collect
intelligence that we badly needed to
have
and uh the next thing you know you get a
change in administrations and the new
crowd coming in says we're going to go
prosecute those guys who were
responsible for carrying out those
policies
um i well i came here to aei at one
point about two years ago
and
spoke on the subject
i will say
the administration appears to have
reversed course
all of those activities were
investigated by career
lawyers in the justice department
at the tail end of the bush
administration it all been looked at
before to make sure it was copacetic
and
the
obama administration did finally and i
think i hope the matters now resolved um
back off
and
those people that frankly i think
didn't deserve to be prosecuted i
thought they deserved to be decorated
for the work they did for us that
saved uh again many many lives let's
jump forward to that speech which as you
say was may of 2009 here
at aei and it was in part a critique of
the administration's decisions on those
things that that you mentioned but it
was also
at least the way i heard it a warning
by by stepping back from the kinds of
things that your administration had done
you were in effect saying we're putting
our we're choosing to put ourselves at
greater risk
and yet here we are uh some two and a
half years later
we had of course the attack at fort hood
but in spite of all the things that you
warned against
we haven't been attacked again
osama bin laden has been killed atiya
rakhman apparently has been taken out
you've had a series of successes on al
qaeda central
in afghanistan and pakistan that has by
i think most accounts been decimated or
pretty thoroughly taken apart
were you wrong when you made those
warnings in may of 2009
i don't think so
steve i would argue that the
the policies we put in place
back in those days that were available
to us and were utilized
over time
and i've seen some comment
to this effect from from current
officials of the of the government um
helped produce
for example the intelligence that
allowed us to get osama bin laden
that it was out of the enhanced
interrogation techniques that some of
the leads came that ultimately produced
the result when
president obama was able to send in seal
team six to uh to kill bin laden so i
think it's been a
continuum if you will
between administrations
focused especially on the part of the
career folks in the intelligence
community and in the special ops
community in the military that have
worked it over time
it wasn't just that
the new administration came in and see
all of a sudden we got bin laden they
had the benefit of all the work that had
been done sure but at the same time the
terrorist surveillance program isn't
operating as it was originally conceived
there are no more enhanced
interrogations we're broadcasting to
uh al-qaeda and others exactly how we
will interrogate them we read miranda
warnings to umar ferruk abdulmutallad
all of these things that that you and
others have warned against and yet here
we are we haven't been
attacked again we've had these major
successes and you know when you when the
bush administration came to an end i
remember you making the argument that
you should be judged by the fact at
least in large part that
that we hadn't been attacked again that
that was a sign of success why can't we
use that same standard for the obama
administration and say that things that
they're doing
have been successful well i guess i'd
make the case that
they've been successful in part because
of
the
capabilities we left them with the
intelligence we left them with because
of what we learned from men like khalid
sheikh muhammad back when he was
subjected
i think it's a mistake for example not
to have an enhanced interrogation
program available now
the president when he canceled our
enhanced interrogation program said they
were going to set up their own
for high value detainees but as best i
can tell i don't think they ever have
i don't know what they would do today if
they captured the equivalent of khalid
sheikh mohammed
uh probably reading these miranda rights
i don't know
um that's not
in my mind
it's a mistake for us to give up those
capabilities
uh i hope
that there are no more attacks but even
as we meet here today everybody who
drove to work with their car radio on
this morning heard that there's you know
a threat that's
of sufficient
credibility at least at this stage that
the authorities are saying you know we
this is unconfirmed but we're taking it
very seriously right um so i think
say i do think it was a mistake for them
not to stay as actively and aggressively
involved
charles krauthammer has written a
brilliant piece
on the notion that somehow we
overreacted i don't think we did i think
we did exactly what we had to do
and that the results speak for
themselves we'll do one or two more from
me and then we'll open it up to
questions from others um
you often made the case that iraq was a
central front in the war on terror um
looking back on iraq one of the things
that have that that people have focused
on
in reading your book and in the reviews
of your book is uh the fact that you
don't think that a lot of mistakes were
made that um
there's not much you would change about
the way that the iraq war was conducted
and i noticed in my reading of the book
that in the criticism of um
what the state department did you often
focused on
secretary powell and later secretary
rice but in the criticism of what the
pentagon did
you focused on generals casey and
abbazad didn't focus on your friend and
mentor don rumsfeld why is that
well i i thought i wrote a pretty good
book
yeah
i thought it was uh
relatively balanced i chose not to
um dwell at length
sort of on on what transpired
in the immediate aftermath of
our going into iraq i mean we had
there have been a lot of books written
some of them pretty good i think about
the
policy in terms of of setting up a new
government in iraq of you know jerry
bremer's written one
several other books have been written
rumsfeld's written
pretty extensively about it
i basically took the approach
uh that i could focus on a few things
and what i really wanted to focus on was
the surge
and the counter insurgency doctrine that
accompanied the surge that we put in
place
at the beginning of 07. so there's a lot
written about that in my book but i
didn't spend a lot of time uh going back
over what the state department did with
respect to managing um
situation in iraq or what the pentagon
did
outside normal military activities in
terms of that but if you read jerry
bremmer's book and if you talk to other
people i've talked to people on on your
staff and elsewhere who said that you
were asking questions about the us
military strategy in iraq during those
years that things
obviously weren't going well
asking tough questions what is our
strategy do we know how to win why are
we doing the same thing is the training
effective
and
i guess i'm interested on a personal
level
when did you start asking those
questions
well on a personal level at some point
we'll sit down and talk about it
i thought now is as good a time as any
now i uh
i i could have
you have to make choices in the book we
wrote about well a little less than 600
pages
uh and as i point out in my early
remarks
i had material for four or five books
what i chose was to focus on the
highlights
as i saw them and what i thought was
was vital in in that regard and
obviously
um i wrote it from my perspective uh in
terms of what i saw what i believed um i
exercised a certain amount of discretion
i didn't put down everything i know
about uh what transpired in a whole
range of different areas under did there
be a second volume well i don't know it
depends on how this one does
now i um
you know there there are things i didn't
talk about
uh not just on iraq but you know
throughout my 40-year career
i mean when you're chief of staff to the
president united states you you know you
there are things you're involved in
um where he expects discretion
and uh and deserves it
and um i didn't write about those things
um that's generally true of lots of
things i i in connection with my time
with
the president bushes
the
i think it's fair to say
in
both cases there are
confidences that they had in me and
certain issues and
i've honored those always would
on second term foreign policy uh you
write in the book quite a bit in a
chapter that you not so subtly called
setback
um about iran about north korea about
syria about
non-proliferation issues and you suggest
at various points in the chapter that uh
the bush administration lost its way um
had
essentially veered away from the bush
doctrine that was so well established in
the first term
and i wonder if you think
president bush himself sort of lost his
nerve
i didn't say that in my book did i say
that's why i'm asking you now
no i um
i did write a chapter called setback
and uh
i thought it was important
because it was
well it was a source of frustration for
me it also demonstrated pretty clearly
that i didn't win all the arguments and
i thought that was important
to convey that
and there were this was an area had to
do with north korea's
nuclear aspirations and activities
building a
nuclear reactor for the syrians in
eastern syria that would allow them
ultimately to produce nuclear weapons
and so forth
um
it was one where
there were significant differences
inside the administration i think many
of those were known but
part of my interest was in putting down
the history of that period and the
policy debates and i thought there were
lessons to be learned we weren't the
first administration that had trouble uh
figuring out how to get the north
koreans not to go nuclear
um
the clinton administration
faced similar problems i think the obama
administration will have similar
problems as well too but i thought it
was important to put down
the
record if you will of how we dealt with
that now
in the final analysis the president made
the decision
uh he had to make choices
that's why he got the big bucks and
lived in the big house that's that's the
responsibility that president united
states
obviously he didn't always agree with my
advice
and in this particular case he opted
pretty much for the state department
view of how we should proceed rather
than what i was recommending
um
it's not the first time i've lost an
argument with the president you think
we're less safe because of those
decisions well
i i think
it's a way to put it
would be that i believed i gave an
interview
before 9 11 it was actually long in
maybe april or may
of 2001
we'd only been in office a couple of
months
and uh
it basically it was an atlantic new york
new yorker
um where i
cited as the biggest threat the nation
faced
the possibility of a terrorist
organization acquiring
uh weapons of mass destruction
uh an al-qaeda with nukes kind of thing
that
i believe
deeply especially in the aftermath of 9
11 and i think it's important
on the 10th anniversary of 9 11 to
remind ourselves that that threat's
still out there still very real
and
one of the things i thought we did well
up to a point
was when we went in
and we took down
saddam hussein
obviously we eliminated one of the guys
who'd been a prime source of weapons of
mass destruction previously produced and
used the equipment whether or not he had
stockpiles at the time when it went in
uh he clearly was a proliferator a
potential proliferator of that kind of
capability so we got rid of saddam
hussein as a threat we um
five days after we went in and
and captured saddam muammar qaddafi held
a
press announcement that he was
surrendering all of his nuclear
materials he had centrifuges for
enriching uranium he had uranium
feedstocks he had a weapons design
um
and
he surrendered all of those and they're
now in our position possession the
united states has them so we took him
out of the the nuclear business pretty
good given what's happened since and in
libya it would not have been good to
have
the difficulties they'd had over there
if sanae if muammar qaddafi had had
nuclear weapons we also took down the aq
con
network khan was the
mastermind of the
pakistani nuclear program then he went
into business for himself
black market operation selling nuclear
materials uh his biggest customer was
libya but he also was dealing with north
korea and uh to some extent with iraq
so saddam muammar qaddafi aq khan all
put out of business from the standpoint
of having to worry about them
um producing
uh and or proliferating or using
those materials the one we didn't get a
handle on was north korea
and what the the chapter you refer to
that i call setback basically is a story
of how we did not deal effectively with
the north korean threat right and um so
i think uh you know if you're keeping
score
three out of four is not bad but
the problem is that threat is very real
and north koreans especially dangerous
because they've now tested two weapons
they have
we caught them red-handed
with respect to
their
providing
a plutonium reactor
to one of the worst terror sponsoring
regimes on the face of the earth syria
and
fortunately for us the israelis took
that out so we didn't have to worry
about that anymore but the north koreans
clearly established that they will
proliferate nuclear materials to
terrorist sponsoring regimes
and
the uh
problem that uh we're faced with is is
still
very much there and
we do not yet have a handle
on on north korea the other problem
obviously is still iran and we haven't
even talked about that but
we've got to be front and center as well
as the north koreans in terms of our
concerns about that threat and i do
believe still today as we meet that
that's the most dangerous threat the
united states faces is that that
technology will fall into the hands of
an al-qaeda type organization and then
nuclear weapons will no longer be a
deterrent there'll be an incentive right
well maybe we can take a few questions
and maybe we'll get a question about
iran um please when uh when you are
called on wait for the microphone give
your name and your affiliation and
ask a question rather than making a long
statement thank you yes ma'am
were you surprised when you found out
that assam bin laden was in pakistan in
terms of your uh talking with president
musharraf at that time the cooperation
that you had between both countries
did you at any point feel that the
pakistani authorities had been uh hiding
something from the bush administration
i never had reason to believe that
president musharraf was involved
in anything like that there was
i think there was a general view
that um
bin laden was in
remote
some remote section
of pakistan
not just
short ways from islamabad
i think what was
startling was to find that he was living
where he was he wasn't hiding in a cave
someplace like there was a lot of the
the imagery that somehow he'd gone
underground uh figuratively
um
i uh
but i had no reach in my dealings with
president mashar
and i dealt with him quite a bit
to question his
his commitment to the work he was doing
with us
to help us deal with the threat that had
emerged from pakistan i think he came to
believe that
al qaeda types threatened
him personally as well as his regime as
much as they did the united states and i
think that was true
two or three attempts on his life in a
matter of weeks by al qaeda and
where al qaeda affiliated uh
organizations uh
while he was still president
another question
yes sir
right down here in the front
uh mr vice president my name is jason
stern i'm a graduate student of middle
east studies at george washington
university say that
no matter who's in the white house the
arab spring would present a great
challenge both a challenge to protect
our interests and a challenge to uphold
our values
how well has the obama administration
respond to arab spring
and how would the bush administration
have responded differently if they had
still been in power thank you
[Music]
well i um
it's difficult to judge
um
the quality of the current effort
without having to speculate about what's
going to come out at the at the far end
process
and frankly
i i don't have
um
answers to a couple of key questions i
don't know who's going to be in charge
when the
dust settles and new governments are
established
what are these regimes going to be like
how are they going to look at the u.s
what kind of relationships are we going
to have in some cases
some of the regimes that have
been replaced
like president mubarak and egypt for
example have been good friends and
allies of the united states over the
years
uh worked closely together with them in
the first gulf war for example
so
i
if you're evaluating the outcome in
terms of u.s interest
i think there's a lot we don't yet know
about
about the outcome
in terms of whether or not we should be
supportive
i think
that it is
important for us
to continue to express our support uh of
certain values that we believe people
ought to have
the opportunity to live by we believe in
freedom and democracy um and uh i think
that uh needs to come through that but
again you've got to come back and be
cautious here i think in terms of uh are
we promoting
that process with respect to islamic
fundamentalists
to groups or organizations that may have
one election and then they'll
shut down the electoral process and
you'll have
you know the equivalent of hamas run on
gaza
we don't know yet and uh i think it's
difficult to make a final judgment until
we see how some of those things develop
should the united states be taking a
more out front role
in promoting the arab spring
well to do i'm
i'm cautious steve uh
partly
um
because there are things we don't know
um
but also i think it's important for us
to be a little cautious about lumping
them all together
and and um my experience over the years
with that part of the world is it's very
important to remember these are
different countries in some cases there
are linguistic differences in some cases
there are religious differences or
splits between shia and sunni
um
and in some cases you've got governments
that i think are probably viewed as
legitimate in the eyes of the governed
and others where clearly
syria comes to mind you've got a brutal
dictator who's uh in charge and uh using
violence to try to preserve his hold on
power and uh most of us could agree that
that uh
bashir assad ought to go
um so you need to make those kinds of
judgments when we talk about the arab
spring
i think i understand what that means and
and i think generally it's been welcomed
as a
fundamental
change in reform if you will in the
region but i do think it's important
to keep in mind as we evaluate
these developments that each and every
one of these countries
is different and
it needs to be
dealt with accordingly
next question
yes over there in the front
allison epperson i'm your average
citizen each year i have a question when
do we know we won the global war on
terror
when do we know we won the global war on
terror
well the uh
facts are obviously there's it's not
similar to
what we think of as a conventional war
where um
you know we get
the battleship missouri and steam it
into tokyo harbor and get all the guys
there to sign the document saying we
quit
um that's not going to happen
and um
i think there is evidence out there that
we're making significant progress
i think getting osama bin laden
very important
and uh
very useful
demonstrated part of that process
but i think also
it may be the kind of thing that just
gradually fades over time
um
but i don't think there's going to be
that there's likely to be a kind of aha
moment
where you can say ah there it's done
take a couple more
sure
vice president i could take you back to
your earlier comments about the middle
east
and bring it back in history the great
controversy at the close of the bush 41
administration was general norm
schwartzoff assertion that uh had we
continued the march was the phrase he
used it might have been a different
outcome what do you think that outcome
would have been
had his advice been pursued in that
regard
how would that have changed the course
of events well
um
john's talking about when he and i were
in charge of the pentagon
i was the secretary but he was the
comptroller who were all the money guys
and
the
it was i think back on that i i
careful here not to challenge
my colleagues from that era because i
think they all did
did good work but i um
my recollection of the close of the gulf
war
was that there was unanimity
on the part of the president
of his senior
civilian and military advisors
that
we gathered around the desk in the oval
office we had a secure line open to uh
riyadh where
our senior military commander general
schwarzkopf was
and
you know you could look back on it later
and say well we should have done this or
we shouldn't have let them have
helicopters or
there were things we didn't know at the
time
um but there was a general sense
that we'd done what we set out to do
said we're going to liberate the weight
that's what congress had authorized
that's what the u.n security council had
signed up to that's what we told the
coalition that's what we told our troops
we were going to do and i'd promised
when i'd gone over there initially to
get permission to put u.s forces into
saudi um i'd also promised him as soon
as we completed the mission we'd go home
we were not looking for permanent bases
in in saudi arabia
and um
so there was a general
sense
that
now should we have gone all the way to
baghdad then
um circumstances
were pretty dramatically different ten
years later
after we'd had
the events of 9 11 after we'd seen
saddam violate 16 out of 17
u.n security council resolutions and
produce and use weapons of mass
destruction against his own people
um
you know the the world had shifted 10
years later
and uh if we'd gone in
uh if if there was a way to
one thing i could think of that i would
like to have changed
um
it would have been to have saddam at the
table signing the surrender document
that one of the things that emerged out
of the way
it was dealt with was
he he was very creative
and
didn't have any qualms about
misrepresenting the situation but for
years afterwards he peddled himself
as
somebody who had defied and successfully
defied
the great satan the united states of
america
because after all we'd done to him he
was still standing it was the fact that
he was still standing
that he used to
demonstrate or validate the notion that
he'd won
of course he hadn't
but he was able to peddle that in that
part of the world and uh so if i could
think of one thing that i might have
liked to have seen differently wouldn't
have been to go on to baghdad at that
point but it would have been
to have him you know set his fanny down
in the chair and sign the surrender
document
another one i'm sure all the way over
yes sir my name is hyde erica from
malcolm's daily newspaper sorry from my
name is saeed erica from oakland's daily
newspaper but i also served in in iraq
for five years as a united nations
spokesman and i can tell you sir that
iraq is a disaster zone with a very
little chance to recover for decades to
come
iran has almost total hegemony and the
united states is about to cut and run in
retrospect wasn't it a mistake to invade
iraq
well i think it would be a mistake to
cut and run
i i don't think we should um
turn our back on iraq at this stage and
the efforts that we've
mounted there over the years i think uh
it's very important for us to complete
the mission
and
i
i think
my own personal view is that
there's a danger here the rush for the
exits
under the current administration
and um that would be really unfortunate
one more quick one sure
run with aei and washington examiner um
president bush in his memoir which
doesn't purport to cover its whole
administration
doesn't really mention iraq from the
spring of 03 to the spring of 06.
what do you say to the criticism that
the president was insufficiently
monitoring his generals and not
eliciting
early enough or as early as desirable
something on the order of
the surge strategy which was ultimately
developed at the end of 06 and osef
early 07. could that have been done
earlier well i
i'm inclined michael first of all what i
remember is
that the president was heavily engaged
during that period of time he was not by
any means ignoring what was going on
in
in the operations in iraq we had
fairly regular sessions
where
he would get on the
secure
hookup to to baghdad
not only with our own senior people but
also with
senior iraqis i've got a picture
well there's a picture i put in my book
of uh
rumsfeld and rice and i up at camp david
and uh doesn't show the president it's
because he's on the other end in baghdad
and we've got a secure hookup uh during
that period of time he's gone into
baghdad and is over there visiting with
having an important session with um
then prime minister maliki so i don't
the notion that somehow he turned his
back on or wasn't focused on wasn't
engaged
i i would i would challenge that i don't
think that's true
let me take uh the prerogative of asking
one last question bringing this sort of
back to 911 you've made the case that
911 changed the government i think
that's obvious to everyone
in many respects it changed the country
clearly changed the world
did it change you
did 911 changed me
well it it was
i i don't think
it changed me in the sense that some
have suggested
that uh you know i
i've got friends out there who used to
be friends
who uh
say uh i knew cheney when when he was a
nice guy he was warm and fuzzy but i
don't know him now
um
and uh
you know the other night i did jay leno
i don't know whether anybody here saw it
but um they have what they call a cold
open
uh and the program begins with the jay
in greeting his guest for that evening
he's wearing blue jeans and so forth and
got his suit on yet
and
he
asked me if i'm going to wear the suit
that's there on a hanger
on the show that night and at that point
i open the door
and come out of the dressing room and
i'm dressed as darth vader
which
he he was he was part of the joke but it
it didn't help my image in his
i i don't i suppose i don't
i can't say it didn't change me it's
part of my life and and it was
an important uh
milestone for all of us and obviously i
spent
the next seven and a half years working
with the president and
and our colleagues to try to make
absolutely certain that that never
happened again on our watch
and that meant we had to take steps and
enact policies that we're going to
guarantee the safety and security of
the american people
um i sort of see it as okay here's the
problem this is what we're going to do
about it and then we did it
um
the um
notion that uh
of change
mainly came to
a focus in my own mind and say i thought
before about this problem of
a 911 style attack terrorist attack with
deadlier weapons something other than
box cutters and airline tickets
but
the events of 911 really brought that
home
and
i i think it um
it heightened my concern
it would be a fair way to put it about
the uh
potentially devastating consequences i
mean we you know we we had anthrax
attacks at the same time turned out
those were probably domestically
initiated
we had uh
one night i remember being at the al
smith dinner up in new york a month
after uh 9 11. and
as we landed that day
to go down to the waldorf where i was
the guest speaker for the evening
received word that there'd been a
botulism attack at the white house
one of the detectors had gone off
suggesting that the president and i and
others had been exposed to botulism
toxin which is
deadly deadly and we didn't know for
several hours whether it was true or not
or a false reading turned out to be a
false reading fortunately
but um
you know so there was there was a level
of
of
heightened concern
uh in the immediate aftermath of 9 11
that we had to deal with it was like
on 9 11 you get a report that there are
six planes hijacked turns out there are
only four that was enough
report that there's a car bomb at the
state department turned out there was no
car bomb at the state department
um turned out there was there was a
report of a plane that had gone down on
the ohio
west virginia border
um no that was american 77 that it
simply dropped off the radar hit the
pentagon there was a report of a plane
down in pennsylvania
shanksville turned out that was true
that was united 93.
so
you know as we went through that process
in the immediate aftermath as we're
putting together policies and so forth
there's no question about what there was
a
significantly elevated level of concern
and i felt it like i think most of us
did but i don't know how i could have
done my job if i hadn't
and i felt that
part of my job was as
the presidents uh
was to uh make certain that we never
again
got hit
uh the way we did on 9 11.
well with that i'd like to thank mr vice
president and thank the american
enterprise institute for hosting
and thank all you for coming
thank you
thanks so much thanks so much stephen
vice president cheney aei is
extraordinarily grateful to have a
friend like you a scholar statesman and
man of action which represents aei's
ambitions so well uh we're so thankful
for your time this morning mrs cheney
liz cheney thanks for being here thanks
for all of the questions this morning
we'll let you get out of here i think
you've got some media interviews
right after this and then we'll excuse
the crowd thanks again
[Applause]
foreign
if you missed any of this conversation
with vice president cheney you can see
it again in the c-span video library at
cspan.org
video library also the former vice
president will be interviewed on book tv
this weekend talking about his new book
in my time a personal and political
memoir and that's saturday evening at
five eastern on book tv on z span two
this weekend the 10-year anniversary of
911 on the c-span network
and now former congresswoman elizabeth
holtzman argues that former president
george w bush and vice president dick
cheney broke several laws and
international treaties during their
tenure in office and should be held
accountable
the author contends that the bush
administration lied to the american
public in the lead up to the war in iraq
and permitted torturous practices in
opposition to international agreements
this is a little over an hour
hi everyone greetings and good evening
to the john jay community college
community my name is dr susan kang i'm
an assistant professor in the department
of political science and i'm very
pleased to introduce the honorable
elizabeth holtzmann to you all today and
she's going to talk about her book
cheating justice how bush and cheney
attack the rule of law and plotted to
avoid prosecution and what we can do
about it
elizabeth holtzman is a prominent
politician public servant public
intellectual author and pioneer for
women in politics
in addition to many news and magazine
articles and op-eds she has authored a
number of other books including who said
it would be easy one woman's life in the
political arena
and her second book was the impeachment
of george w bush a practical guide for
concerned citizens
and
um was published by nation books in
2006. this highly acclaimed book drew on
liz's experiences as a district attorney
and a former member of congress
during watergate in arguing for the
impeachment of george w bush
holtzman first gained national attention
when she was elected as a democrat
member to congress at the age of 31 and
served a prominent role in the house
judiciary committee during the
impeachment
of
president nixon she also chaired the
immigration and refugee subcommittee
holtzman served in congress for eight
years she she continued to break
barriers with her election as the first
woman district attorney of kings county
and later as her service as a
comptroller of new york city
in addition to her service in elective
office
liz has continued to pursue justice in
her participation
in other capacities president bill
clinton
appointed holtzman to the nazi and
japanese imperial war criminals record
interagency working group which is
overseeing the declassification of u.s
government secret nazi war crime files
elizabeth holtzman is currently the
co-chair
of the government relations practice
committee at herrick feinstein's llp
concentrating her practice in government
relations at the federal state and local
levels in litigation thank you elizabeth
again for coming to john jay college and
sharing your book with our community
this event is being televised by c-span
so during the question and answer period
if folks could please come to the
microphone in the middle we'd love to
hear your questions and there will also
be a reception after the event thank you
good evening everybody
can you hear me or do i need to speak
more loudly
let me begin by thanking first
president
jeremy travis for the invitation to come
here
to professor
susan kang for her
hard work and reading my book and she's
going to be questioning me later
interrogating me enhanced interrogation
and
to dan feldman professor dan feldman who
has been a dear friend and a wonderful
scholar and
distinguished public servant and of
course to the indefatigable mara nevis
whose wonderful work made this event
possible this evening
thanks to all of you uh for coming to
talk about a subject that's not really a
very pleasant subject and that most
people don't want to hear about
but that's really vital to our democracy
and that is the subject of
accountability for everyone for the high
in the mighty
as well as the low
and the vulnerable the poor
and the powerless
we just heard the president of the
united states
respond to the concern
that the banksters weren't being held
criminally responsible
for the depredations that they caused
to our economy
and he created a stepped-up and
beefed-up
investigative team an investigative unit
but accountability has not been had
for the actions of the bush
administration
and
for the serious abuses and misconduct
that took place
i want to start by saying that
i got hung up on the idea of
accountability
when i was first elected to congress
i didn't expect to be on the house
judiciary committee
and i didn't expect to be thrust as a
brand new member of the house into
impeachment proceedings against a
president of the united states i mean i
was brand new
my parents were immigrants
all of a sudden i'm sitting in judgment
on a president of the united states
i had to study
the impeachment clause and the
constitution
and understood something that the
framers felt was essential
to our functioning as a democracy
not only that there would be checks and
balances
not only that the highest and the
mightiest namely the president the vice
president and other top administration
officials could be held accountable
through impeachment or other processes
but that the criminal law would function
as well that as a democracy
no one was above the law
and it was an important lesson that the
country learned in that at that time too
because just i know many of you might
not even have been born in 1973
and four when watergate took place
but richard nixon won in one of the
biggest landslides in the history of the
united states which meant
most americans who voted in that
election voted for him
yet when facts came out suggesting that
laws were violated
the american people including the
overwhelming majority who had supported
richard nixon said
congress you have to investigate we have
to have a special prosecutor the laws
have to be enforced no matter what
and in the end when the house judiciary
committee acted
on a bipartisan basis to vote for the
impeachment of richard nixon
the country overwhelmingly supported
that verdict
and what did that tell us
that more important than any political
party
and more important than any president of
the united states and more important
than any single person and more
important than any ideology
was the bedrock principle of the rule of
law and the preservation of our
constitution
and americans united on that theme
regardless of how they had voted just
about a year and a half before that
we're not talking about
ancient history in that vote
people put behind them their own
partisan views and said what is good for
the country and the rule of law and one
standard of law was critical
so i said gee you know that's a really
important principle and i believed in it
too
and then
we got the bush years
the accountability principles
pretty much worked i won't say they were
perfect
hardly government doesn't operate
in a perfect world and in itself is
rarely perfect
but then we got to the bush years
and things changed
and so i and my co-author cynthia cooper
wrote a book about impeachment i was an
expert on it that's a very niche area of
expertise in this country
but 10 of us still
have had the experience of dealing with
the terms of the constitution and the
impeachment proceeding
that worked the nixon impeachment
proceeding
but
we
saw and we wrote a book and we saw
however that there was no accountability
through the impeachment process
and so then we said well let's look at
what else can be done because we knew
the framers of the constitution
understood and is clear in the debates
about the constitution that once a
president leaves office he someday maybe
she can be prosecuted
there was nothing in the framers debates
that said oh you've been president free
you get a forever free from jail card
nonsense the framers understood that
presidents could do very bad things
i mean they were human
they created checks and balances and
because they understood president could
do bad things they also understood
congress could do bad things they were
not
um idealistic about people they were
very practical and they were very
pragmatic
so we said okay let's do this book
about
what kind of accountability can exist
and to our
surprise as we began to look at what the
criminal statutes were
what we saw was not just
the possibility of accountability
but that the bush team
was
excruciatingly sensitive to the
possibility of prosecution
and had tried to erect barriers
in a variety of ways
including
slicing and dicing and rewriting
criminal laws
to protect themselves from
accountability
and to protect themselves specifically
from criminal liability
so i
um
the book
uh deals with
not only the idea of accountability and
the importance of accountability
and the possibility of accountability
but it also describes how they try to
avoid accountability
and i'm just going to give you a couple
of examples of that and then talk about
one of the areas that we discuss
in depth
after examining the federal criminal
code in detail
we
found that there were three areas of
potential criminal liability
one was the area
of the deceptions that
okay
one was the
area of the deceptions
that led to the war in iraq
the very tragic war in iraq
we examined in the book three potential
statutes we find that one
is applicable in terms of potentially
offering the possibility of prosecution
we looked at the area of illegal
wiretapping
wiretapping is a federal crime
and we looked at the area of
mistreatment of detainees
let me just briefly
tell you uh what we found in the area
of the deceptions
um
it is a federal crime
to conspire to defraud the united states
i don't think there's too much doubt
that president bush and his team
were involved in making statements
that not only turned out not to be true
but that the evidence suggests they knew
was not true when they said them
an effort both to defraud the congress
and the american people at the same time
conspiracy to defraud the united states
is a federal
crime
and not a we're not talking about
international law here we're talking
about u.s crime now i don't want to say
i've been a former prosecutor so i don't
want to say and i'm sure they're very
esteemed defense counsel in this room i
would never say that just because it
looks on the face of it
that there's a statute and it's been
violated that someone has committed a
crime you need to have a serious fair
prosecutor
examine the existing statutes and
examine the evidence and make a
determination
but on the face of it you have some very
startling
evidence
not all the facts are out about
even to this day
about
exactly what president bush knew and
when he knew it
exactly what the objectives were in the
iraq war
but as i cite in the book
chapter and verse
statements by him and president cheney
and vice president cheney to the effect
that there's no doubt
that iraq had weapons of mass
destruction
also the claim
and we of course know that that's not
true
of course the claim
that saddam hussein was in cahoots with
al qaeda
and they knew better
so
these are some
of the points
that
are
could be used by a prosecutor in
determining whether to prosecute
i'll give you some time in the question
period because i want to focus a little
bit more on some of the other areas
the other area of course is wiretapping
and let me give you a little background
to this
during the nixon impeachment proceedings
one of the grounds for impeachment was
that president nixon engaged in illegal
wiretapping
he decided he was going to wiretap
his staff
some of that wiretapping was done for
political purposes
and also journalists
as a result
and and that was one of the grounds of
impeachment
illegal wiretapping
as a result
of the
findings about president nixon as a
result of the findings about
other agencies illegalities in
wiretapping in 1978 congress passed a
law in response to these illegalities
and said it is a federal crime
to wiretap
and this applies to anybody without a
court order in cases involving
national security foreign intelligence
that's the law
very clear
president bush admitted this is not liz
holtzman saying it it's not some
professor making a deduction
president bush
acknowledged that more than 40 times
he authorized wiretapping without
obtaining a court order
on the face of it
a violation of the federal law
now his answer as to why he did this is
what we call the nixon defense
if i do it and i'm president
it can't be illegal
but that
argument is the essence of military of a
military dictatorship that's the essence
of tyranny because if a president is not
bound to obey the law
then he can commit any crime and do any
act that he wants
and that's exactly what the framers
never intended to have happen
so on the face of it you have
violations of the federal criminal
statute with regard to wiretapping this
also should be investigated
the third area that we look at
is the area of torture
and
this is an area in which
as i mentioned earlier the president was
exquisitely sensitive
to the possibility of prosecution
and we how do we know this
because
there was a memo that was sent to the
president
by his then counsel alberto gonzalez who
became attorney general of the united
states
and the memo said to the president in
reference to a federal statute called
the war crimes act
it reminds me a little bit of when i was
d.a and listening into wiretaps of
organized crime figures it was like boss
we got to worry about this
there's something that could happen to
us and basically
gonzalez's memo said as we discussed
the war crimes act creates a potential
i'm paraphrasing here
for
prosecution
and so
and the war crimes act let me step back
was
enacted by congress to carry out the
geneva conventions
the geneva conventions require the
humane treatment
of everyone who
everyone despite
the existence of a war during wartime
civilian populations
as well as
people who are armed and who are
combatants
and that statute was in that
treaty
which we ratified in 1954
under president eisenhower who led the
american troops
in world war ii and the allied troops in
world war ii
was adopted because eisenhower
understood
the importance of the geneva conventions
not just as a moral principle
but as a way to protect american
soldiers fighting in the war
and so
and the geneva conventions weren't were
adopted in response to the terrible
horrible acts that occurred in world war
ii primarily against civilian
populations but also the mistreatment of
american pows in japan by the japanese
and pows by others
so that was the background of geneva
conventions and under the geneva
conventions every country that signs the
conventions has to carry out has to
enact a statute that makes it a crime in
that country to violate those geneva
conventions
so tonight took us a little while 40
years but in 1996
a republican congressperson from north
carolina proposed the war crimes act
which made it a u.s crime
to violate the geneva conventions not
an international crime
not a matter of international law but a
matter of us law u.s criminal law
to violate the geneva conventions
so in this memo
to president bush
alberto gonzalez said
if we opt out of the geneva conventions
we reduce
the possibility of prosecution under the
war crimes act
since the war this is their logic i'm
not
going to subscribe to it but their logic
was since the war crimes act carries out
the geneva conventions if we say the
geneva conventions don't apply then the
war crimes act doesn't apply
so
the press in reporting about the widely
publicized decision
of the bush administration to opt out of
the geneva conventions for al qaeda and
for the taliban
mentioned point number one
in the gonzalez memo which said geneva
convention's a quaint that's why we
should opt out of them
but point number two
which i think was the real point
was that opting out of the geneva
conventions would in their mind make the
war crimes act like
a war crimes act less likely to be
imposed
and therefore in gonzalez's words reduce
the likelihood of prosecution under the
war crimes act this
is the chief counsel to the president of
the united states saying if you opt out
of the
geneva conventions we're less likely to
be prosecuted under the war crimes act i
mean that's an astonishing
memorandum
and it says in as we discussed so it
wasn't just a memo going to the
president they'd had a conversation
about it and of course president bush
opted out of the geneva conventions
in response to this memo
and what's very interesting
is that
they went merrily along
thinking that there'd be no crime no
liability under the war crimes act
and why were they so worried about the
war crimes act because the war crimes
act
not only made torture
um
a breach of the geneva conventions and
therefore a federal crime if you engage
in torture
but cruel and inhuman treatment
that's pretty broad and indignities upon
people
pretty broad
they knew what they were doing violated
the the prohibitions against cruel and
inhuman treatment
and against
fostering indignities on people
well at one point the supreme court
had to rule on whether geneva
conventions applied
to
the people who were detained
and the supreme court said
geneva conventions apply
well
i think panic struck in the white house
because of the geneva conventions
applied under their theory
the war crimes act applied
and that meant they were liable for
every person
who was
treated in a cruel and inhuman way
uh oh
very serious
federal
criminal
penalties
a felony
a crime
it carries the death penalty if death
results
and we know by the way
that president bush was personally
involved because he's admitted it just
like with the
wiretapping he's admitted that he
authorized
waterboarding of people
and other enhanced quote-unquote
enhanced interrogation techniques
so
this is very serious what were they
going to do
they were facing prosecution and as they
put it in the memo as gonzalez had put
in the memo the problem wasn't only
the justice department during their
tenure
but what about the justice department in
the next administration or the
administration after that they couldn't
control the justice department forever
they were worried panic struck the white
house what are we going to do with the
war crimes act we can all go to jail
well
they went to congress
and they engage in some flim-flam to
distract congress's attention which is
not always very difficult
and they slip through
a statute
they didn't abolish the war crimes act
they just
nullified it retroactively going back to
the very beginning there's no other
example in the history of the united
states
where a statute
was made retroactively invalid
so you couldn't prosecute anymore under
the war crimes act
that's what they succeeded in doing
to protect themselves
the other area in the in the area of
mistreatment of detainees and we believe
it's extremely difficult for any
prosecutor to prosecute under the war
crimes act as they have left it
mangled chopped up
sliced and
diced there's another statute that they
were concerned about
called the anti-torture act
that act was adopted
in 1994 to carry out the convention
against torture we're a signatory to the
convention against torture
that was adopted under president
ronald reagan
and the war cr the anti-torture act
makes it a crime
federal crime we're not talking
international law here we're talking
about u.s crime makes it a u.s crime a
u.s felony
to
engage in torture outside the united
states
well this also created a problem
because
a lot of people have thought in the past
for example that waterboarding was
torture including the united states
which prosecuted it when it took place
in arizona i believe it was arizona by a
sheriff
against american citizen
not under the anti-torture act but under
other statutes
and uh
they said well how we gonna get around
the anti-torture act that was easier
than the war crimes act
because if you could define torture
really narrowly so that nothing was
torture
home free
so they got a willing lawyer
to redefine the word torture now the
torture statute
the anti-torture statute says that it's
a federal crime
to torture somebody and torture is
defined
as causing
severe
mental pain
physical or mental pain or suffering
okay
well the first thing they did was they
were they were very worried about
waterboarding because everybody thinks
that waterboarding is torture so they
said
waterboarding's not supposed to actually
cause pain
but does cause suffering
so they said well you know pain and
suffering that's like
a phrase those words mean exactly the
same thing so we'll just say
suffering doesn't mean anything other
than pain right
i mean it could mean pain but it doesn't
have to mean pain
so they just
deleted wrote took an eraser and even
though the statute says
physical or mental pain or suffering
they just erase the word suffering this
is a lawyer who went to harvard law
school and clerked for justice thomas
and teaches his law
he just said well suffering we just
gonna
ignore it you know it's like that song
love and marriage that's a phrase that
goes together they mean the same thing
pain and suffering that's the same thing
so we don't have to pay attention to
suffering
then
they decided
to
define the word
the phrase severe pain
how do you find define the word severe
pain so that almost nothing qualifies
well they had a brilliant idea
they said i give them credit for this
they said
severe pain
means the pain
that's equivalent to the pain of death
now if you just look at it right you
know just mind reads over the eyes read
over the term pain of death you say wow
that's
that's really really
serious and severe pain my god what
could be worse than the pain of death
but if you think about it for two
seconds you realize
what is the pain of death
shakespeare once said it's actually in
hamlet
that death is that country from who's
born no traveler returns
so how does anybody know what the pain
of death is
right well when the guy who wrote this
this memo to the president was asked by
the justice department in a later
inquiry
what did you mean by the pain of death
what does that term mean
he said it's a quote
i don't know
i think it must be very severe but i
don't know
so what am i telling you
this is a cooked up
fake
definition
it's a meaningless
definition
but that was
what president bush
has tried to hide behind
my lawyers gave me this definition
and so what i was doing wasn't torture
well
actually his book is called decision
points
not my lawyer's decision points
so he can't exactly hide behind what his
lawyers say and there's not really a
defense
for what
advice lawyers give in general it's it's
normally
advice that can be followed in tax cases
because
normal people aren't expected to
understand the tax law so if your lawyer
advises you in a tax case you're
entitled to rely on his or her advice
but to some extent
in terms of normal human behavior we're
expected to understand
normal human events and what severe pain
is
and
we don't believe that defense is
applicable and we certainly don't
believe that the defense is applicable
when the president engaged and
authorized the enhanced interrogations
before he got a written opinion from his
lawyer
when you pick a lawyer that you know is
going to give you the definition when
the definition on the face of it makes
no sense and when another justice
department lawyer upon reading this memo
said this is insane
so we think there's no real reliance in
good faith by president or his team on
the advice they got from this lawyer
whom they
chose in a very
interesting way to
prepare their quote-unquote defense to
torture
we
describe this in detail the book goes
into detail about these three areas and
the criminal statutes that apply
but we have not
had
any effort at criminal accountability
and
the question you may ask is
is there ever going to be criminal
accountability
my answer to that is
that
you can't give up hope
because
if this president can commit acts that
on the face of it appear to be crimes
i'm not saying that they are but appear
to be without ever having a serious
investigation
then what's to stop the next president
or the president after that or the
president after that from engaging in
other crimes
and crimes not necessarily abroad but
here at home
part of the reason you have a criminal
law and you enforce the law
is not just to punish for bad acts
but to send a very clear signal
to would-be repeaters you can't get away
with it we're not going to get away with
it we're not going to let you get away
with it and it's also a statement by
society that these are acts that we find
reprehensible
now
accountability for heads of state
not always easy we haven't always seen
it by countries willing to look
internally and say
our leaders did something bad we have to
hold them to account
we did that in watergate
but we seem to have lost
the guidance
and
the center
that
watergate taught us about as a country
we're not focused on accountability
and so the failure
to bring about justice in these cases
trivializes the acts
of apparent violation of the law
and sends a clear message to presidents
in the future
don't worry guys or gals
you can get away with it no one's ever
going to hold you responsible
but i look
at other places and even the united
states to say that there will be
accountability if not now
in the
future we can look at
the case of augusto pinochet
the dictator of chile
took 27 years
to bring him to justice
but justice started primarily because it
was triggered
by a very fine spanish judge
balthazar garzon
who sought his extradition to spain
pinochet's extradition to spain
to be uh prosecuted
for mistreatment of
uh
spanish nationals in chile
we've also seen in the united states
an effort to bring
matters to a just result
we can just look at the civil rights
movement
in the south in the 50s and 60s and 70s
there was a serious reluctance to hold
people accountable for the murder of
civil rights workers
but people didn't give up and we don't
believe in the statute of limitations
for murder
and so starting in the 90s these cases
were reopened
and many people who were able to escape
justice and enjoy impunity
were prosecuted and convicted in the
deep south
i was involved myself
in an effort to bring nazi war criminals
who had come to the united states and
were able to live here
in peace and security for
30 or 40 years
to justice
so justice can be delayed
it can be detoured
but i don't believe it can be stopped
and as i said
it is an issue that goes to the heart of
our democracy is there going to be a
single standard of law
for the powerful
and the weak
or powerful people in our society
able to say we can get away with it
whatever that it is
even it's about even if it's a violation
of federal law
i hope that that won't happen and i hope
that you will be part of an effort to
demand accountability and justice for
all isn't that what this country is
about
thank you very much
[Applause]
um
[Music]
thank you so much liz for that stirring
presentation i really wanted to
encourage students if you haven't read
the book please do so especially those
of you who are interested in law school
the way that the bush administration's
legal team was able to engage in very
creative
legal interpretations is incredibly well
documented i think that you'll learn a
lot about federal laws when it comes to
accountability
and the way that international laws have
been translated into domestic laws from
this book so i think it'll be really
good preparation to learn a lot of
things for law school
um okay so i guess i only have a couple
of questions i really want to ask
because we're running out of time and i
think that the questions from the
students are probably going to be
more interesting than any questions i
might have i think you've done a great
job
documenting how important it will be to
hold the bush administration responsible
for
the many criminal activities that
they've engaged in um and i think that
it's your political argument about how
important it is to maintain
accountability in american democracy is
very well taken
but one of the questions that
i had listening to you speak as well as
reading the book
is this contrast between the reaction of
the american people when it came to
watergate versus the george w
bush administration
so why do you suppose that there's such
a marked difference
in the demand for accountability
is it because
when it came to bush administration
there were issues of national security
at play was it possibly because um
the i guess the theatrics of the clinton
administration's uh
i guess the attempts of accountability
by the republicans in the 1990s put a
sour taste in people's mouths i was
wondering if you had any thoughts about
this distinction
well i think that's a really
important question
about why the difference
i think
i think fear
and national security issues
can you hear are these working
just lean into them
can you hear me now
oh can you hear me now yes okay
i think fear and national security
were
important factors
we knew
in watergate for example president nixon
used national security
dozens of times to try to justify
what was happening the break-in was
national security
told the cia stay away i mean the fbi
stay away he didn't personally tell them
but he told the cia to tell the fbi stay
away from the watergate burglary don't
investigate it because it involves
national security he claimed national
security
but this is an ordinary break-in and in
the end the um the process went forward
the big difference in watergate
was that there was a special prosecutor
and we have no special prosecutor here
archibald cox was appointed special
prosecutor named special prosecutor by
elliot richardson and it was total
happenstance
and
once you had a prosecutor there like
patrick fitzgerald he had a a mandate
he had independence
and he was told to uncover the truth and
uncover the evidence without fear or
favor and he did he was ultimately
obstructed in his efforts to get at the
truth
but i think most americans think he did
a very professional job
we had no special prosecutor as a result
of watergate and i call for it in my
book in terms of what we can do
we created in congress a statute for a
special prosecutor
that statute unfortunately was so abused
by kenneth starr
that congress said let's get rid of it
let's let it expire
and as a result we have no mechanism
to create a special prosecutor
which means that there is no hope of
accountability
uh unless the president says
affirmatively this has to be
investigated and i'm going to have a
special prosecutor appointed or an
attorney general says that
so i think that's one difference i think
also
that bush did an extraordinary job of
scaring the american people
they were scared by the constant
emphasis
on the mushroom cloud most americans
thought they were in imminent danger
from
saddam hussein that we were going to
have
a nuclear weapon go off here that he was
going to give if he himself wasn't going
to hand off or wasn't going to use
nuclear weapons then he was going to
hand it off to some terrorist group
i mean even the cia said this was a very
unlikely scenario but the american
people believed it and they were scared
if you go through all the documentation
we have some of it in our book
you'll see that there was harping and
harping and harping not only by the
president but by condoleezza rice and by
others in the administration about the
mushroom cloud so people were scared
wiretapping is a very abstract point
how do you feel it
has how is your liberty affected
most people don't know
so they say well
first of all they're never going to
wiretap me i'm a law-abiding citizen so
what do i have to worry about it's them
some group of would-be terrorists not me
and so nobody really stops to think
about
how
um
illegal wiretapping
can
chill our liberties the framers of the
constitution understood it they
understood that's why there's a in the
bill of rights it says people shall be
free from unreasonable searches and
seizures and no warrant shall issue
except unprobable cause now why'd they
say that
because they had experienced the framers
with the british monarch who went and
bombed you know banged down doors and
went into people's homes
and and arrested them based on all kinds
of ridiculous evidence they understood
the danger and we should really
understand the danger
of what happens when people think
they're being wiretapped so
but it's too abstract for many people
and
the torture
was
repellent to many americans
but
it wasn't our own people who were being
tortured it was them the other
you can dehumanize the other
it's not the first time in history
that's happened it's not the first time
in the united states that we've
dehumanized um the other
so i think those are some factors
but it will
but those factors i believe can be
overcome i hope they can be overcome
because it's
it's a terrible thing to think that
we ourselves can't
hold our own
administration our own highest level
people accountable well let's put it
this way if you don't think
they should be prosecuted for a crime
let's change the law and say when a
president violates the law he or she can
do it without being prosecuted
okay
but we don't have that and most
americans wouldn't agree to that
so i i i think it's a very tough i think
tough time
the post-9 11 era and president bush
took advantage
of the fears of the american people
and americans trusted him
they trusted their president see they
hadn't remembered watergate
they hadn't remembered the vietnam war
where presidents lied to the american
people so they said our president is
going to tell the truth
and they were wrong
i guess i have um we only have a little
bit of time left so i have one short
question and i'd like to open it up to
the floor
so your book ends with a very passionate
call to action you've also urged the
students here to remain hopeful for
accountability
i was wondering if you could maybe give
some concrete suggestions about actions
for some of the students here that might
want to pursue this a little bit further
well
i'm going to say first read the book so
you can be armed with the facts
secondly i would go and see your
representatives in congress and say why
aren't
things happening why can't we have
accountability
i would join together with other groups
i would try to keep myself informed
there's some groups that are doing a lot
of work on not necessarily governmental
accountability but on trying to deal
with issues of
torture or mistreatment of detainees and
so forth
i think there we talk about changing
some of the laws for example enacting a
special prosecutor law that would make
it possible
for a special prosecutor to commence
investigations you know one of the
things i didn't really mention was that
statute of limitations is running out on
some of these crimes particularly the
crimes of related to defrauding the
congress about the war
the crime of illegal wiretapping
these are crimes that the statute of
limitations will run out on and in fact
some of the
torture
crimes
will
become subject to a statute of
limitations in the not too distant
future luckily
under the patriot act the one good thing
it did was to create
to abolish the statute of limitations
for certain kinds of torture
that create a risk of serious
bodily injury or death and since
waterboarding according to the cia
itself not liz holtzman but the cia
creates a risk of drowning
i do believe that there is no statute of
limitations with respect to
waterboarding but other kinds of
enhanced interrogation may be subject to
a statute of limitations so we have to
be
alert and i think
to call on the president write to the
president write to the attorney general
and call on your representatives and
your senators
to act what are they doing about getting
accountability and why not
so those are things i would definitely
urge that you do
thank you very much um
if you could please come up to the
microphone and ask your questions so
that everyone can hear it
are we still torturing torturing this
administration
i don't know the answer to that um
i don't know the answer to that
please come up to the microphone i mean
there i think the president said that
there is to be no torture
but
i don't know that we know everything
that's going on in various secret
prisons around the world that we still
have
um my question draws on someone on his
question but
i know other people were aware of the
enhanced interrogations that were
occurring
i think house speaker former speaker
pelosi
what would be your litmus test
for a criminal investigation for
for somebody who knew or
participated in it what would be your
limitless test for uh well
you'd have to ask
what the statute required in terms of
did they authorize could they have
stopped were they conspiring for example
those those are kind of defined
standards under the criminal law
probably
being in a situation where you could not
have stopped it
and you didn't authorize it
i don't know that there would be
criminal liability
i'm talking we didn't ex we didn't
look at anybody
other than the president and the vice
president
and the people closest to them we were
not trying to base liability on
um
we just focused on them we didn't expand
the penumbra i mean i'm sure there could
be a variety of people who could be
included but we really focused on the
main people who admitted
that they authorized i mean i don't want
to get into a situation
what are the disputes about facts nancy
pelosi said she did x other people said
she did y that's a factual dispute we
wanted to focus on situation where there
was no factual dispute and there is no
factual dispute president bush himself
said i said damn right when they asked
me if i was going to authorize
waterboarding of khalid sheikh mohammed
this is no question about that so now
the question is since he's admitted it
what do we do about it
that's so i think your point is
interesting but we didn't focus on that
in the book
i really want to thank you so much for
this book and for these provocative
words
um
the center for constitutional rights has
many of the guantanamo cases
and today they had a big session
on what is going on
and the kind of
failure to
not only failure to close guantanamo but
failure to release
89 of the folks in guantanamo who
everybody agrees should be released were
there a place to go that
so what's torture i mean is it still
going on well of course it is
um and then there are these super max
prisons where folks are in isolation um
and for me
things are happening so quickly the
the passage and signing of the national
defense authorization act
what does that do
and and given who voted for it that our
own senators our own liberal good new
york senators voted for it
barbara mikulski voted for it what does
that do to who should be
indicted and what does that this new law
do to your to the structure
well those are very important questions
i'm not talking about whether people
should pass law shouldn't pass a law i'm
talking about the laws that are already
on the books
and these laws have been on the books
the anti-torture act
the wiretapping law
the defrauding congress by the way
deporting congress is used in the
prosecution of people in watergate the
top aides to nixon and it was used in
connection with the iran contra
prosecutions so that's a statute that's
well established i'm not talking about
should they have passed this act
should they have not passed this act we
don't even have to go there i'm just
talking about the laws that are on the
books
right now
and why aren't they being enforced when
it comes to a president of the united
states
would we i mean their books there are
laws on the books right now about
bank fraud
and they weren't being enforced
and american people were very upset
about that
we're not talking about any new laws we
don't have to go there i'm not saying we
shouldn't go there i'm just talking
about
what message is sent in the future
if the laws we have that prohibit
torture
that prohibit
illegal wiretapping that prohibit a
president from defrauding congress into
going into war and not enforced
what does it say to another president
what's the next war we're going to go
into on a basis of fraud
or
the next
massive wiretapping or the next
torture and maybe the torture won't be
of them maybe it'll be of us the next
time
you know they said that that's a very
famous uh
statement about
how um you know in germany's uh pastor
said well you know first they came for
the labor union talking about the nazis
first they came for the labor union
leaders and nobody said anything i
didn't say anything and then they came
for the religious uh people and
religious the ministers and nobody said
anything and then they came
for the catholics and nobody said
anything no and they came for the jews
nobody said anything and then they came
for me
so are we all going to be the me's of
the next president or the president down
the road that's really what's at stake
here and so those are very important
questions that you ask professor but
they really are on a different point
which is we have laws on the books right
now that are not being enforced because
we're talking about enforcing them
against a president of the united states
and if we want to create exemptions for
presidents from our law
are we going down the road to tyranny
and dictatorship
how can we preserve ourselves as a
democracy if a president can say
i don't have to obey the law i'm
president the nixon doctrine
where does that line
end where do you draw that line and so
that's the great great great danger and
also i think
and the failure to look at this and to
prosecute
torture
is also a way of condoning it in the
future
people don't really understand you you
talked about
the um
you know we're not what is the torture
people don't really understand what
happened to these to the people who were
given enhanced interrogation if you read
the cia's manual about this
they took somebody
this is i mean they did it repeatedly
they took somebody they smashed him into
the wall they took his clothes off
they um hosed him with water
they kept him in freezing temperature
they didn't feed him
they kept him in stress positions he was
in a diaper
they'd stop that after about a half hour
or 40 minutes
then they'd do it all over again smash
him into the wall
douse them with cold water
i mean this was this is no joke what
happened
and it's pretty horrific
and some of these people are no longer
the same
as a result there's long-term mental
damage
as a result of the waterboarding one of
the people his lawyer said he had 200
seizures
i don't know so it's really i think the
american people have to be educated
that's one of the important things that
happened
i think this is a good answer also to
how we can
change the minds or the understand the
american people
watergate was a critical learning
experience for the american people it
was a way of getting back in touch with
what the constitution said
and about single standard of law and
about holding presidents accountable and
about abuse of power and how we can
correct it it was as
everybody's calls says a teachable
moment
but there has been no teachable moment
about the eight years of the bush abuses
and an effort whether it's prosecution
or even a truth commission
would bring out to the american people
and would educate them about the dangers
of this i mean the amazing thing is just
with respect to a truth commission
that's another alternative way of
accountability it's not as satisfactory
as in my view is having someone look to
determine whether crimes were committed
but
in england
they have a commission that's sitting
right now
on determining what happened in terms of
going to into the iraq war they called
tony blair to testify they called all
the top figures to testify they had
public hearings
and they're going to issue a report
in holland
they appointed a a former supreme court
justice who issued a report by the way
part of it is in english and you can
access it online
and he found that the war was illegal
under international law and he also
found by the way that the
dutch
par prime minister deceived the dutch
parliament
hello we've seen the same thing here
so it's very these are things that we
have failed to do that other countries
have done and it's just inexcusable
we have done this in our own past
but why are we stopping now and i think
it's very dangerous to continue going
forward without accountability
uh good evening i was just wondering is
uh justice best served if the
administration is uh prosecuted under
domestic or international law like which
carries more weight in your viewpoint
that's also an interesting question i
mean there are some efforts
to hold american officials accountable
in italy there was a prosecution
of some 23 21 cia officials they were
found guilty in absentia
there are investigations now going on in
spain
under spanish law
and there's an investigation it's not
clear if it's really going on but it
started in poland where there was a
secret prison and people were tortured
my view is
those countries are entitled to act but
it's a shameful thing
if other countries have to wash our
linen if other countries have to hold
our people accountable if other
countries are the ones who tell the
truth and that we can't do it we're not
big enough we're not strong enough we
don't have the courage we don't have the
commitment to the rule of law to do it
ourselves to me
it would be very shameful for the united
states yes it would bring
some
more truth to light it would show people
that these that crimes have been
committed
but we need to do it ourselves
not to say they can't or they shouldn't
but we need to do it ourselves
but we have a history of
american exceptionalism
where we feel we've always set the
standard and i would say over the last
20 or 30 years
there is a sense that we're not as
powerful as we used to be
we are not the leaders of the quote free
world
so given the historical reluctance to
follow others
i'm just wondering
if you can think of any internal hope
where we can be more reflective
where we can acknowledge our own
problems and still feel that we can't
for something in the world they're these
cultural tensions and i think they
create this
vacuum in which the bush administration
was able to act to show that america is
strong we can do what we want no it's
been a disaster
but i think that deeper cultural
currents going on in which we may make
the changes you're asking for the
enforcement of the law very very
difficult because then america would
look weak now i agree with you that we
do look weak we do look as if we're not
doing well
but
given the level of information we have
about what's going on
there just seems to be a retreat from
law a retreat from the standards you are
um talking about in the name of an
illusory we're strong and it's not
working well i think we felt
um
i mean i think america felt strong i
mean during the during the nixon time
it's true that we just lost the war in
vietnam
uh but maybe it was the lying of the
vietnam war
the anger that the public had about that
that made people feel that they had to
be accountability and they weren't going
to let anybody not be accountable i
don't you know i haven't really studied
that enough of that history
but i don't know that it's a question of
feeling strong vis-a-vis other countries
i think it's
our own view of the rule of law here and
i think it's a very terrifying thing to
think that if we expect people to obey
the law that that's going to make us
weak abroad and
of course that's nonsense
but
britain doesn't seem to be concerned
about that in terms of their inquiry
and we shouldn't be either how can we be
afraid of the truth how can we be afraid
of justice
what are we if we are that's a very very
sad sign and and
you know our moral standing in the world
will depend on our ability to deal
with uh abuses of power and criminal
conduct by our leaders and the failure
to deal with it will have a very bad
impact i think the the fact that we've
had that there's been no accountability
for torture has not helped us in the
eyes of the world has not enhanced our
power has diminished our power
so
uh
i i i but i don't know that that's what
people are responding to i just
maybe that's the case but i i just don't
know
you have to go to the mic
so uh
hi yes my name is scott lewis and
uh i just hope that
and this is a question is
do you think this will bring
but by will this attract
by
having this book out there to bring
justice
it's going to attract
will it attract harmony or
with the rest of the world or will it
attract
divisiveness
well
i don't see how accountability
done in the right way in a fair and
professional way
creates divisiveness
i go back to watergate i hate to harp on
it but that's a very concrete experience
and people said when we started on the
impeachment process that the country
could never stand it
that it would divide us it would destroy
us but it didn't it strengthened us
because we learned from the process
that we were as americans committed to
the rule of law that was the most
important thing that strengthened us as
a country as a people we took tremendous
pride even though our president did very
bad things
we took tremendous pride in the
institutions that were able to respond
to those bad things
well
you know so i think that the idea that
justice will
be divisive i don't agree with that i i
think that when you have fair and
effective prosecutions people have
confidence in the institutions instead
of lack of confidence in institutions
and that's a a really critical factor
are institutions working or are they
biased to protect the rich and the
powerful
politically powerful
politically rich
actually rich that's you know we can't
have institutions that do that because
then the american people lose confidence
in them weakens us
are there any further questions
okay i'll be available to sign any books
if you want we have one more question
okay
it seems to me that you're bringing up a
very very important moment in american
history
and we don't seem to be that concerned
about it
and i know we kind of talked about you
kind of referred to this before
but i mean the fact that there are these
people here it seems like there should
be hundreds of people here listening to
this
um i i was bothered by it personally
uh didn't do anything about it
um why
what is it about our american psyche
right now about our american the way
where we are in our own heads i mean you
look at the you look at the campaign
that's going on now and the and the and
the enormous hatred that seems to be
within parties between parties
what's going on and how do we get out of
this funk we're in
well i think of course
americans are very distressed
economically now
and many of them are concerned with
their own survival with keeping a job if
they have one with getting a job if they
don't
i mean this is a depressed time for this
country
and
maybe people think that enforcing the
law is a luxury
when it's really
essential it's as essential as bread
we can't this country
created the prosperity that we enjoyed
until very recently because we had a
rule of law that functioned yes it
didn't function always
whether it was against
minorities particularly
african-americans women indians and
native americans and so forth
but
it did you know overall we were getting
better we were making progress
and without
the democracy
what's going to happen to the economic
growth in this society what's going to
happen to our society itself so
i would say probably now most people are
worried turning inward because they're
very worried about their economic
circumstances but that doesn't mean
that we can't be terribly worried about
our democracy and
president addressed that
why would people care about prosecuting
bankers
because they don't want
a country in which the rich and powerful
escape justice even though they're
hurting they still believe in the idea
of justice well we need to have an idea
of justice for people who did what
president bush and and vice president
cheney did if you look at this war in
iraq that they took us into on a basis
of lies and deceit
and apparent on the basis of apparent
criminal conduct
what did it cost us now i just saw a
recent estimate three trillion dollars
three trillion can you imagine what we
could do with three trillion dollars
today not to mention
the
tens of thousands of americans injured
not to mention the thousands of
americans killed not to mention the
hundreds of thousands of iraqis killed
not to mention the upheaval and and
chaos and other issues that arose in
iraq as a result of our conduct
so
um
there were terrible consequences of this
and if people understood that
and
almost more if people had an awareness
that they had the power to make a
difference about it
then i think we could see things change
i mean they did have the power maybe it
was occupy wall street
that created the
feeling
that
something had to be done about the
banksters well maybe we need to occupy
wall street or the equivalent
to give the american people a sense that
we have to have
people
our
people in top political positions who
engage in criminal conduct
uh to be held accountable
that idea has to be put out there
and maybe all of us in this room if we
go forth from here
contact elected officials
talk to our friends write letters to the
editor
do stuff on the internet maybe
we can begin to make the difference
anyway if we don't do anything for sure
we won't
so i guess it's up to each of us
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you everyone.com book tv for more
news about the world of publishing and
what's happening on book tv
lynn cheney examines the political
philosophy and presidential tenure of
james madison
mrs chaney discusses her book with her
husband and former vice president dick
cheney at the nixon presidential library
in your belinda california
this is a little under an hour
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that was nice
as dick says it's almost enough to make
you want to run for office
almost
almost
well we're delighted to
be back here tonight i've had the
opportunity to visit
the uh nixon library and museum on a
number of occasions and served in the uh
nixon administration during the first
term
and uh
so i'm always pleased to come back and
and
visit this part of the world and be
reminded of a very important time in our
history i thought the president did a
superb job
and um i was happy to to be a part of
his administration
we're here tonight uh i probably should
explain at the outset why we're here
together
the
fact is
i was born in lincoln nebraska
and lynn was born in casper
wyoming and in 1954 when i was 13 years
old about to go into the eighth grade my
dad
moved the family to casper wyoming he
had a choice between
montana or wyoming he picked wyoming
and it was a good thing because
lynn and i grew up together
when i first took her out when she was
16 years old we'll celebrate our 50th
wedding anniversary come august
[Music]
but if dad had picked montana instead of
wyoming
of course uh i would never have married
lynn she would have married somebody
else and as she said the other night
then he would have been vice president
i i don't recall that that was one of
the jokes you were supposed to tell
i'm a freelancer now that i'm unchained
we're here tonight to talk specifically
about uh
a magnificent book that lynn has written
about james madison it's gotten some
great reviews and and uh we're on the
book circuit so to speak and i've been
to the
nixon uh
uh
events here before sponsored by the
nixon library when i had other books to
other books to write to
publish
and now we wanted to have an opportunity
obviously for lynn to present hers it's
a um as i say it's a superb book
about our nation's fourth president and
the plan is that i will ask her
questions and she'll respond and then at
the end of that period of time we'll
open it up and take some questions from
the audience as well too so
with that let me begin by asking why
madison what made you decide james
madison needed another biography
well before you get there i want to say
that i'm so grateful to dick for joining
me on this book tour and i started
referring to him as my arm candy
okay
well
you know i've known i've known i was
interested in madison for a very long
time i had the privilege of serving on
the bicentennial commission for the
constitution in 1987 and it was then i
first began to understand how
magnificent madison's accomplishments
were and yet how little recognized he
was in terms of
what he had accomplished in his
political life
it wasn't until five years ago that i
became serious about writing the book
and
it has been a labor of love and i only
hope that
you'll enjoy the book as much as i
enjoyed writing it
he was
the architect of the constitution
the architect of the bill of rights he
was crucial to the establishment of the
first government under the constitution
he was president
during the first war under the
constitution
and he performed
if not magnificently
in all those jobs at least very well
at the end of his presidency
john adams who was kind of a sour figure
and not given to making compliments
easily
john adams wrote that james madison's
administration
had covered itself in more glory than
any of his predecessors
which is a great compliment because his
predecessors were washington jefferson
and adams himself
so um i i do think he's been
underappreciated and it's been
really uh
so much fun i mean i know five years of
labor doesn't sound like fun but you
know discovering things being able to
put it into
a form that i hope would reach a wide
audience and uh
as the book is called um reconsidering
james madison's life
which was the most important
contribution he made out of it'd be
cited the contributions were enormous
obviously but
if one if you had to pick just one
what would it be well it would have to
be the constitution
i think he was a genius and the reason
is he was
the kind of genius he had is that he was
able to break through conventional
thinking
when everybody else was thinking one way
madison didn't necessarily accept it he
would think of
other possibilities and he did that in
the case of
the constitution in the case of
establishing a great republic which is
what we are
the conventional wisdom was that you
couldn't have a great republic you know
a great republic where people voted for
representatives for themselves
representative government
that it would be too loose over a long
and vast extent of land and it would
fall apart unless you had
monarchical power a king a monarch at
the center
well madison just thought that was not
true
he thought that in fact
the danger in a republic is that one
faction will dominate and oppress
everyone else and madison's genius was
to see that if you had
many factions as there would be in a
large republic then no single one was
likely to be able to become oppressive
and that was the rationale for the
constitution that was produced in
philadelphia
it was um his genius to see
through what everyone else believed time
and again and uh to transform the world
by doing it
you talk about his relationship with
the other founders um george washington
for example
you know we we think sometimes i i
of the founders is sort of sitting
around having a polite conversation
and uh you know all of them having the
greater good in mind at all times
um
it's much more interesting to realize
them as they were which was uh people
who firmly believed in their point of
view and were willing to fight
to see it succeed
in the beginning madison was
washington's chief lieutenant
when the first government under the
constitution began
now this will be familiar to any of you
in politics
washington had
an aide write his inaugural address and
the aid produced a 72-page disaster
so
washington wrote to madison and asked
him please come to mount vernon and help
and so madison did and he wrote
washington's inaugural address did a
very good job of it
after washington delivered the address
madison who was the leader of the
congress
wrote the congress's response to madison
i'm tim washington got it thank you you
laughed any though i got it wrong he
wrote the congress's response to the
inaugural address
and washington by this time thought
madison was so good at this kind of
thing he asked him
madison to write washington's reply back
to the congress
you know it's hard to imagine how his
voice was echoing off every wall
i'm not sure there's been another time
in history when uh one man has been so
influential um in at the beginning of
administration the way madison was in
the beginning with washington
but if you talk about the constitutional
convention obviously there were
battles over various provisions in the
constitution um we ended up with
with article one our section article one
two and three and uh
it took a long time
many many hours and days of work uh to
put it all together but can you decide
to sort of the the specific compromise
the most
important provision that they were
argued about then ultimately were able
to resolve well it was the thing we all
learned in history books about the big
states and the small states
and of course the big states wanted
states to be represented proportionally
according to their population the small
states wanted the states to be
represented as states and we all know
the compromise they got representative
states in the senate and proportionally
in the house
madison was appalled at that he really
thought there should be proportional
representation across the board
he had gone into the constitutional
convention thinking that the great
threat to the republic
were the states he called them the evil
states
because they had been
so irresponsible under the articles of
confederation
repressing religious freedom uh
churning out money rhode island was
especially guilty he it was called rogue
island
churning out money uh and then this is
what rhode island did passing laws
that made it um necessary for merchants
to accept that that depreciated money
for debts uh that had been incurred so
you know maybe you were getting paid off
at uh a penny on the dollar
the states were taxing one another
oppressing one another actually
they were conducting their own foreign
policy
so madison thought the states needed to
be controlled and when it turned out
that the compromise was to have the
states represented as states and not
proportionally in the senate he was
he was very disconsolate it took him a
couple of days to get around to
accepting that
what conceivably made them think they
needed a vice president
you know that's kind of an eternal
question isn't it
[Laughter]
well it it had to do with the electoral
college and every elector had two votes
they finally got to the electoral
college
when they couldn't agree on anything
else
so
the alternate at that point was to let
the congress choose the president
and just imagine how different our
presidents would have been if the
congress was choosing
you wouldn't have had a ronald reagan
you wouldn't well
nixon no i don't think you would have
had a nixon either you would have had
plenty of speakers of the house though
go on to become president
well the electoral college everybody
gets two votes
and again the big states and the small
states the small states are worried that
the big states will always elect the
president
so to assuage their concerns
the deal was made that you could only
cast one vote
one of those two votes for someone from
your own state
the other had to be cast for somebody
from another state which would give the
small states a better chance
but then they started worrying and
you've all played this kind of game
if you want that one vote for your own
guy in your own state to be really
important you throw away the second vote
you know you expend it on jim who
doesn't have a chance
to prevent that
we're finally getting the answer they
they invented the vice presidency
the idea was that the person who got the
second highest number of votes would
then become vice president
and that that seemed like a pretty good
idea but then they started worrying well
what was he going to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
and you know it's so interesting to see
how this thing just builds up
they decided that he needed a job and
that they would make him president of
the senate
by the end of the constitutional
convention there were two delegates who
were so worried about the vice president
a creature of the executive branch
being president of the senate part of
the legislative branch
about his
just
violating the separation of powers two
delegates elbridge gary
and
randolph of virginia two delegates no
i'm sorry elbridge gary and george mason
of virginia
specifically cited the vice presidency
as reasons that they wouldn't sign the
constitution they called it that
dangerous office so there you go
[Laughter]
during the
course of
his career in terms of implementing the
constitution would be the best way to
describe it i guess alexander alexander
hamilton became an important
player in all of that can you talk about
what it was that
led to their
major disagreements and and
confrontation
well first maybe it's important to
understand that he and hamilton were not
buddies exactly but they were friendly
colleagues they wrote the federalist
papers together with a little help from
john jay
and
the story of writing the federalist
papers is so if you don't mind i'll just
go right ahead
um divert a little bit here the story of
writing the federalist papers is so
interesting because it was done at such
speed in such haste
and i was explaining to a college
audience and you
from colleges and universities in this
area will appreciate
that what madison did during one one
period of time
during 40 days was the equivalent of
writing a 10-page paper every other day
now you could do that that doesn't seem
impossible
but
the papers became immortal
you know so writing writing
philosophy writing politics
writing
an effort to convince people to support
the constitution at that breakneck speed
this printer was putting the beginning
parts of essays into print before often
before they were finished
so that madison and hamilton you know
respected one another
until
hamilton became secretary of the
treasury under george washington
and began to make his financial plans
clear
madison was troubled from the beginning
but he eventually particularly when the
issue of establishing a national bank
came up
he was
deeply concerned he didn't think that a
bank was a bad idea
but at the constitutional convention in
fact he thought it was such a good idea
that at the constitutional convention he
had proposed
giving the congress the power to grant
charters which is what you needed if you
wanted to establish a bank
however the constitutional convention
had turned that opportunity down
congress didn't have that power and that
was madison's problem
hamilton was uh
simply uh
running roughshod over the strict number
of powers that congress had been given
there was no power to grant charters and
therefore madison thought you should not
establish a bank he lost the fight
but he went on to kind of win the war i
guess you would say
he established the first opposition
political party
now parties didn't have any better a
reputation then than they do now
so again this is counter-intuitive it
was against the conventional wisdom that
said that uh you know parties uh parties
were divisive they were noisy uh we
didn't want them in the republic madison
said aha yes we do
a government without opposition is
little more than a monarchy and so he
organized the first party in order to
change the way defeat the way that
hamilton was trying to carry the
government
to make it
so strong that
madison thought it was something the
constitution hadn't contemplated
and by founding this political party
leading in the founding of it
he managed to get jefferson elected
president in 1800 and jefferson like
madison was a small government guy
one of the most important
functions that
we've seen obviously in recent years
well throughout our history is the role
of commander-in-chief
who's going to uh who's going to run the
wars be in charge of the military
and uh of course madison as you
mentioned in the opening was the first
president ever to have to conduct a war
under the constitution
and
the the way that power was vested in the
presidency strikes me as a great story
because that's not how they started out
can you talk about that no the uh the
proposal at the constitutional
convention uh that was just about to go
through
was that the congress um among its
delegated powers
was the power to make war
and madison his mind was so quick you
know his uh his intellect just instantly
grasped
what would be the results of various
proposals he
leapt to his feet on the floor of the
constitutional convention
and changed the word make
to declare congress would have the power
to declare war
he did this in part because he had seen
what amassed congress made of things
when they were in charge of war
he
he had seen he had been a member of the
confederation congress
where you know there was no no executive
and the congress would decide you know
they'd
write george washington and say send
light horse harry lee south
and then they'd realize there was more
trouble in the north and they'd say to
washington send lighthorse harry north
and it simply wasn't um wasn't a way to
to run a war
so madison left to his feet he said
congress has the power to declare war
but what that did was make the president
the commander-in-chief
when once a war had been declared
how did he do as commander-in-chief
the british marched on washington burned
down the capital burned down the white
house
was he a good commander-in-chief
he was patient
you know like lincoln like lincoln he
had trouble with generals
in the war of 1812
the generals were people who had served
in the revolution and they were getting
a little bit long in the tooth
and they weren't you know as uh as brave
maybe as they might have been in their
younger years one one general who was
supposed to invade canada
um
near detroit go over the border um
became so alarmed
at the
rumors that turned out to be true
actually that the british had um formed
a strong alliance with the indians who
were great warriors that uh the
americans might have to face this that
he just turned around and and uh seeded
detroit
he not only didn't invade canada he gave
the british detroit so
generals as they were with lincoln
were a problem
not so with admirals
the
navy
been started under john adams with six
frigates they had eight or nine by the
war of 1812. the british had a hunt more
than a hundred warships or frigates
but the navy had trained all that time
and brought new and younger blood um as
uh to man the warships you can't you
can't just mothball a navy and then
build it up again so the navy kept going
all that time
and as a result there were magnificent
victories um naval victories in the war
of 1812.
and while people like general hall were
fleeing from the british and their
indian allies
isaac hall
who was indeed related to general hall
isaac hall was commanding the
constitution
and the constitution of course the uss
constitution
most famously encountered the british
frigate gurier
and
just
you know wiped her out
part of the reason was that our frigates
though they were far far fewer were
better built
and the cannonballs from the gerry are
just bounced off the side of the
constitution in many instances which is
why she uh gained the name of old
ironsides
but so there were splendid splendid
naval victories and toward the end of
the war
uh we were developing a new class of
generals and so when i say madison was
patient
he
suffered through those first generals i
don't know what choice the
commander-in-chief
has in that
and and absolutely helps celebrate the
the glories of
of the navy
he also changed his mind
and he was not afraid to do that when
circumstances changed he had long
regarded armies and navies as too
expensive
and as a threat to uh to the republic
too easily used against the citizenry by
the end of the war of 1812 he was voting
he was
suggesting to the congress that they
expand the navy and provide for a first
a standing army
how would you
evaluate him overall how was he looked
upon was he viewed by the public by in
the day of his
his
command as somebody who was successful
or
not very successful his contemporaries
madison was one of those fortunate few
that left the presidency um highly
regarded by all of his countrymen
they regarded we don't pay much
attention to the war of 1812 but it was
regarded by americans as
evidence that we could we should by gosh
be recognized on the world stage we
deserve to be recognized on the world
stage and in fact the rest of the world
began to do that especially as you
pointed out after uh andrew jackson just
beat the heck out of the british at the
battle of new orleans
one of the most intriguing aspects of
the research you came up with was
had had to do with madison's health
and i think it's a
a major contribution from a historical
standpoint some of the reviewers have as
well too
he had an affliction that was with him
throughout his entire life
and yet he was able to achieve these
phenomenal
objectives under extraordinary
circumstances and as a clearly one of
the
most important founders
can you tell us about that the but both
what to what his problem was and how he
dealt with it
you know it was one of those puzzles to
me in the beginning
um
people called madison shy which he
wasn't he was simply reserved and they
said he was sickly and indeed you know
you could see that he was sick from time
to time
but he also between the episodes of
whatever it was
um was enormously energetic taking
thousand-mile trips by horseback or
carriage with lafayette another one with
jefferson
traveling in days when travel wasn't
easy between his home at montpelier and
wherever the capitol was new york
philadelphia washington
undertaking just those routine trips i
have often thought um was something that
none of the scholars who've called him
sickly could manage
and
during the war of 1812 he was on
horseback for 60 hours
when washington was burned
so there was something odd here he was
sick a lot but between sickness he was
quite well
there's a letter that he wrote toward
the end of his presidency and hasn't
been published yet i certainly didn't
discover it but i think i was the first
person to really pay attention to it
it's at firestone library at princeton
and it's a draft of an autobiography
that madison wrote
in which he says he was subject to
then this is the quote sudden attacks
somewhat resembling epilepsy
and suspending the intellectual
functions
well i you know nobody taken him
seriously really um
i think people just wanted to shy away
from it because it's kind of a difficult
topic to figure out health in the 18th
century
but i decided i would take him seriously
and you know you can see the periods
through his life where he did have these
episodes
his description of his sudden attacks in
fact um fits quite well with what
neurologists today call complex partial
seizures which is a mild form of
epilepsy
and i think that was that was it um the
first he had
febrile seizures as a child
prolonged febrile seizures as a child uh
is often part of a syndrome
that involves
seizures
epileptic seizures as an adult
so he had he had you know fits right
into all of that
and
he
suffered the first at princeton when he
was at college and you know you can just
see it once you say well he knew what he
was talking about i'm going to take him
at his word
he fell into this period of deep
despondency when he worried about his
soul when he worried he wouldn't live
long when he worried that you know he
wasn't he wasn't good enough
and
he was lucky he found doctors his family
did that urged him to exercise
that that being fit would help it didn't
end the seizures but he was remarkably
fit you know which doesn't fit with the
sickly image he was very fit and i think
he decided once he had taken his
physical health
in hand he decided to take his soul in
hand
and he was not going to believe all the
things people said about epilepsy people
said if you if you had epilepsy or
seizures resembling it that you were
evil
that you were you were uh
you were full of sin that you were even
possessed by the devil
and madison finally just decided he
didn't want to
he didn't have to believe that
i really think this fed in to his strong
support
freedom of religion people can believe
in religious believe whatever religion
or no religion if they want into his
strong support for freedom of conscience
intellectual freedom nobody should have
to believe anything that he or she
thinks in himself is wrong
and that idea liberated him and i think
indeed helped liberate us all because he
led he led the way for freedom of
conscience for intellectual freedom for
religious freedom
more than any other founder even more
than jefferson
what happened to the autobiography he
just didn't finish it
he didn't
it's just a draft he
uh a man you know this happens to you
after you've been in political life for
a while people write and say would you
just tell me some things uh tell me some
things about yourself and this fellow
wanted to publish them uh whatever
madison sent him and so madison started
the autobiography but he didn't finish
it
and he decided subsequently not to talk
about his epilepsy i think
because it was so
demonized
that uh
that he decided it was just
more trouble than it was worth to call
all of that down on his head at the end
of his presidency
but he was still had this amazing
ability to perform as he did year after
year after year
and i really do think that that
seeing him as having um complex partial
seizures explains how he could be sick
sick sick sick time and again but
between he was perfectly well full of
energy the energy he expected at the
constitutional convention was phenomenal
dolly oh dolly don't you love dolly
well she was beautiful um
men stopped in the street of
philadelphia when she walked past
because she was so beautiful
she had dark hair and pale skin
blue eyes and ruby red lips the whole
package
and madison
was smitten when he saw her on the
street
and he asked his good friend and this
will be a surprise to you his good
friend aaron burr
they had gone to princeton together he
asked aaron burr this was before aaron
burr got in trouble
he asked him to introduce him to dolly
she received him in her parlor she wore
a mulberry red dress and yellow glass
beads and you know it was a goner
they married a few months later and and
she was a political asset
now i'm always kind of skeptical about
how important wives are now gail was
important uh
but
you know i'm not sure anymore that
that's the total it's as important as it
might have been or that we sometimes
think it is more and more wives have
their own careers you know so
they aren't central to getting their
husbands elected
but dolly was
because in those days the congressional
caucuses picked the presidential
nominees
they weren't you know there were no
conventions but the caucus in in the uh
on the republican side and on the
federalist side picked the nominees
and dolly made all of those members of
congress very happy
she they were miserable washington was
just getting started they all lived in
these boarding houses
they uh one one senator said we're
insensible like bears from talking
nothing but politics from morning to
night there was no place to go well
there was one club in washington it
specialized in rope dancers
now i know i'm not sure either but i
maybe
maybe tightrope walkers i mean that's
that's my story i don't know
so these men were so happy when the
madisons opened the doors of their house
on f street and welcomed them no matter
the party
they played cards
dolly took a little snuff alongside
henry clay they shared a snuff box
it was just warm and genial and they
didn't mind if you talked politics
jefferson was very different he didn't
like people to talk politics around him
he liked things smooth you know and uh
calm and he didn't so he didn't invite
people from both parties to dinner he
would only invite people from one party
at a time
but no the madison's mixed it up people
loved dolly
she loved them
and they began to feel not only great
respect for madison but i think great
warmth because of dolly's entertaining
there's even contemporary testimony
to her having been
in some uh not in significant measure
responsible for his getting the
nomination in 1808.
they
james and dolly were married for 42
years
not as long as us no
and in august as i mentioned we'll have
been married 50 years tell us what was
the high point of those 50 years
[Applause]
i'm going to repeat the question
what was the high point of those 50
years for you not
not the 42 years with dolly but no it
does
i knew it was dangerous to have you ask
me questions
well you know once one
event i can think of
dick really presents you in a light that
i think people don't often see you in
you know darth vader is the image and
but
folks let me tell you he's a real
romantic
and for the 50th anniversary of our
first date now what year was that it
would have been 1958 and so it was 2008
was the 50th
dick arranged a surprise party for me to
celebrate the 50th anniversary of our
first date
now all husbands in the audience try to
top that it was
it was very special we invited all of
our college friends he even had the good
sense
to tell me we were going to the british
ambassadors for dinner
now you don't want to take somebody to a
surprise party especially well i think
it is true especially a woman you know
if she doesn't have on a nice dress and
you don't want to take care of her hairs
and rollers or whatever the equivalent
nowadays is so he got me you know to
dress up and he told me this story weeks
in advance
and then the annual gridiron dinner
happened in washington
and
as vice president
president vice president spouse we
always sit at the head table in this
particular occasion after his having
told me we're going to the british
embassy that night
i was seated next to the british
ambassador
so as dick put it i had to read him in
he had to tell him the cover story or
and uh
the british ambassador didn't say a word
and the surprise was complete it was
really a wonderful night
he had a cake made
that
was
tall and had a little sort of you know
body sticking out of it with blonde hair
but the cake was red
and it was a skirt and he did that
because on our first date i wore a red
formal with a big red skirt
let's see
[Music]
are you blushing
no
[Laughter]
um
just like dolly madison
one more question and then we'll open it
up to the audience um and this this is a
difficult one obviously
what was
madison's greatest disappointment
with respect to the constitution and
those formative years of the republic
well you know he wasn't entirely pleased
with the constitution when it was
finished but he thought it was probably
the best human beings could do and so he
became a fervent defender but at the end
of his life well throughout his life he
hated slavery
he wrote a letter as a young man in
which he said i i'm going to do
everything i can to become independent
of slave labor in other words get off
his father's
plantation or farm as they called live
an independent life in which he wouldn't
be
dependent upon that dreadful institution
and he tried
but he didn't really have a long time to
try at it
because he became involved in public
life and creating the constitution and
so forth
so he didn't succeed jefferson also
hated slavery and he didn't succeed
either at freeing himself from it though
i don't think
i don't think he had such a
such a goal such a firm goal in mind as
as madison did
but at the end of long lives they both
died owning slaves and uh
you can see him toward the end of his
life clinging desperately to what the
only thing he could think of that might
help which was the american colonization
society
one of the problems by the
1830s was that if you freed slaves they
couldn't stay in virginia there was a
law that prevented that
neighboring states passed laws so that
freed slaves couldn't move there and so
there was this idea of finding a place
in africa and
paying the way for freed slaves to go to
liberia
the prob i mean the problems were many
one of which and major was that freed
slaves or slaves generally thought of
the united states as their home
the slaves at montpelier had been in
virginia as long as madison's family had
so it was a failed scheme from the
beginning but you can see him just
clinging to it not able to think of
anything else that could give him
the kind of hope he had had as a young
man that this awful institution would be
done away with
maybe just to
wrap up this part of it can you say a
word about
if madison were here tonight
would he uh think that we had been true
to the basic principles embodied in his
work
well i think he would be appalled at the
size and scope of the federal government
um he he would think that we'd move far
away from
the
limited powers that were given by the
constitution to the federal government
he might be somewhat gratified though
his disappoint would be much greater
at seeing the ways in which the
constitution does still prove itself
relevant time and again
i was earlier telling some people a
story that
it just occurred to me in the last few
weeks
the
supreme court is considering a case that
involves
whether
you should
whether the police should have the
authority to search
your cell phone
if they stop you for a traffic violation
there were two instances in which this
happened and those two cases are argued
before the supreme court and
well it's interesting you know when i
mention this to people they'll just say
well that's wrong
or they'll say well that's right maybe
maybe the guy who has stopped was a
terrorist
and what what's interesting and what i
try to emphasize is that's not how we
decide things in our society about how
you feel about it you know about whether
you think oh that's right or that's
wrong we we turn to the constitution to
make these decisions
and the supreme court justices
we'll go back to a constitution that was
formed so long before there were cars
so long before there were cell phones
but the justices will have to go back to
the fourth amendment which madison wrote
that talks about citizens not being
subject to um
to
what's the phrases unreasonable
unreasonable that's what i couldn't
think of unreasonable search and seizure
so he would be gratified i think that
the
constitution still lives though there is
an enormous effort to ignore it
well with that why don't we thank you
sandy's got a mic let's let's thank uh
lynn and
lynn and vice president cheney
they have agreed to a few questions
which we'll do before the book signing
and i'm going to start with this young
man who is from what school chapman
university
and your question is um you talked about
how
he was viewed by his peers um could you
maybe talk a little bit how he was
viewed by the public whether they liked
him or whether they didn't like him and
the way that he
kind of started the government
well madison wasn't the kind of person i
mean if he were alive today he wouldn't
be the fellow who elbowed everybody else
out of the way to get to the tv cameras
so i i don't think that you know all of
his deeds in the early republic were
fully appreciated uh by
his uh fellow citizens but certainly by
the time his presidency was over he was
he was deeply appreciated um his
contemporaries were most enthusiastic
about
his job as commander-in-chief i do think
that has really been lost side of
good question
from corona
high school right corona del mar high
school
janelle nguyen
uh what is madison's most significant
domestic president
i'm sorry his most
significant domestic president
his most significant domestic
achievement maybe
well the constitution
what we had was a country that was
growing increasingly unstable during the
articles of confederation
and what madison did with the
constitution and this idea that you know
uh
faction would be put against faction
ambition against ambition is create a
stable environment
alexander hamilton is often credited for
the economy that we have today for the
vital economy that the united states has
but madison's role
in giving businessmen and the rest of us
a stable environment in which to live
was a major contribution
kiera woods corona del mar high school
what presidents did james madison set
during his presidency
what precedence
um
well i think he
set an important precedent a really
important one as commander-in-chief
um there was a seditious movement going
on in the northeast they particularly
didn't like the war new england some in
new york they hated the war because it
was very damaging to that part of the
country economically
there was so much anger about the war
that there was talk of secession
and even some organization towards
success secession there was even an
effort to strangle
loans for the war by going after the
people of the big bankers in the
northeast and convincing them not to
fund the war
so i think
when madison refused to put down that
kind of protest you know it was free
speech you're welcome to stand up and
say whatever you want and you're not
going to be oppressed when madison let
free speech continue even though in my
opinion a lot of it was seditious i
think he said a very important precedent
it was certainly one that his countrymen
appreciated he he knew that in fighting
for the republic you didn't want to
you didn't want to suppress those rights
that the republic had been
created in part to protect
so that's it
uh
matt hollander corner del mar high
school
uh which president in the last century
would you best equate to james madison
[Music]
new question
you know
[Music]
it is a good question but i find myself
as a as an historian
thinking that you have to take the
founders
and abraham lincoln
and put them in an entirely different
category
not because they were you know different
people but because
the challenges they faced were so
enormous
it's hard to think of somebody like
franklin pierce maybe you could include
franklin roosevelt in there too
you look at presidents who faced
existential challenges you know if that
what they were doing didn't work out
there would go the republic
the founders faced that kind of
existential challenge and
i think have ingrained themselves in our
national story
because of their
overcoming the challenges they faced
lincoln faced that and i think you could
say franklin roosevelt did too
so i guess the last century would be the
20th century
maybe roosevelt in terms of the
challenges that he faced and overcame
from casper wyoming oh wow that's my
house
heading back there tomorrow
um
jan gray
mrs cheney lynn
about madison's height he was only five
feet four you know he was our
shortest president i wanted to know in
your research did you find that he had
any troubles because of that and
especially with regard to his
relationships with women as you know
you know he didn't get married till he
was a lot older and dolly was 17 years
younger than he was
and
mr vice president
i wanted to ask you about
bald presidents
bald yeah the
eisenhower in the last 150 years our
only bald president
and i was wondering
if you think there's going to be any
more
yourself as a partially bald vice
president well if i may go first please
i i've always believed in the
principle that my good friend al simpson
lived by pete gale known from the senate
al used to say we all have only so many
hormones if you want to waste yours
growing hair that's okay by me
[Applause]
uh
a young lady from redlands california
hi um you had mentioned how important it
was to madison
the freedom of conscience so i'm
wondering um how you feel about the fact
that john kiriakou the whistleblower who
exposed the torture program is the only
one currently sitting in prison for it
well
excuse me please finish
well i mean i think there is uh and the
supreme court has wrestled with this too
um you're welcome to believe anything
you want to you're welcome to say almost
anything but what you can't do is
violate national security ordinances
that
would endanger the country edward
snowden is a case in point i think he's
a traitor
and i feel um it's it's so
it does not bode well for our society
that he's being valorized for having
betrayed his country
[Applause]
no
no
i'm sorry you need a microphone i can't
hey gentlemen or maybe this is off point
[Music]
[Applause]
dr frank
well respect i respect your your right
to speak your mind but i also um reserve
the right uh for myself and dick not to
answer your question
[Applause]
dr frank cannon in the back of the room
here
you spent uh five years uh living with
uh in addition to the vice president
living with james madison can you talk
about writing the other 45 to dick
can you talk about writing a book like
this where are the papers uh where did
you go and visit are there madison
descendants and uh if you had could ask
him james madison today one question
uh that emerged from your research what
would that question be
well that that last is just really a
puzzler i have to think about that one
while i talk
um the madison papers are in different
places you do have to travel a little
bit you have to go to princeton for
example because there are unpublished
papers there you have to go to
philadelphia there are unpublished
papers about madison's family in the
presbyterian historical society
but 30 volumes of madison's papers are
online they've been digitized and done a
wonderful job of digitizing them dolly's
papers as well
has been done by the university of
virginia so think of that research is so
much easier now than it has been before
i think if you know i was chairman of
the national endowment for the
humanities for a time and i used to be
appalled at some of the things that we
funded
but if if they were to increase the
endowments budget so they can
make the funding of the founders papers
and digitizing them so that citizens can
have ready access i think that would be
a good expenditure
you know frank i can't give you a
serious answer i just have to think
about what i would ask madison
so my unserious answer is i would say
how tall were you
there this has been disputed someone
said 5'4 his favorite aide said no 5'6
confusion about whether the aid was
trying to be flattering you know i'm 5
feet tall i think even 5'4 would have
been just fine
[Music]
a young man who studied in singapore and
is a student at pepperdine university
yes my name is jacob young
pertaining to james madison's life is
there a particular piece that maybe the
history books are missing that you think
there's not enough information on or
you'd be most interested in learning
more about
well there were two things that you know
really stuck out to me as i went through
personal things this whole idea that he
was shy
is a 20th century invention his
contemporaries said nothing about that
they noted that he was a canny
politician who had learned the trait of
not speaking before you needed to of
being respectful to your elders when you
were a very young politician
of not speaking carelessly madison spent
a great deal of his life cleaning up
after jefferson who was prone to
speaking carelessly
so the fact that he wasn't shy you know
i spent a lot of time showing in the
book that in fact he wasn't
and then this sickly thing that that was
really important to to just to just get
rid of this myth that he was so
so burdened by his health at all times
that he could barely get out of bed you
know you just can't see this vital
politician as a man who was that way and
i think
the idea of him being shy and sickly has
damaged his reputation and i hope my
book will do something to restore it
a
gentleman from orange california with a
quickie yeah real quicky um mr vice
president where'd you guys go on your
first date
oh
well
we actually we went to a formal
thrown by one of the
high school girls
social clubs we went with some good
friends so we double dated lynn did wear
an amazing red formal gown
and
afterwards we stopped at what in casper
is referred to as c hill
oh stop now that's
no it gets better no
we hadn't been there very long when we
discovered that some friends of ours
including i think somebody who dated
lynn before i did had snuck up and let
the air out of the tires on our car
so we spent a lot of time creeping back
down to the filling station so we could
get air in the tires and by then of
course we were in danger of violating
lynn's curfew
and we had violated it
and
so we uh
i was very concerned at that point that
that we violated the curfew first aid i
knew i was going to be in trouble with
somebody but the great thing about it in
in retrospect was
that
lynn's mother was the secretary to the
police chief of castro wyoming
and we didn't make a move that night
that hadn't been reported to her at home
before
all right one one last one last question
from a student from chapman university
could you share some of the most like
influential authors or works do you
think would have influenced james
madison in his writings and opinions
i'm sorry you know the microphone wasn't
quite close enough i couldn't hear uh
could you share some of like you what
you think would be the most influential
works or authors to help madison shape
his opinions and beliefs and writing
federalist papers well he had a
classical education
and
in the run-up to the constitutional
convention he undertook a study project
of years
reading classical accounts of previous
attempts at establishing a republic and
he you know saw where they had gone
astray and that helped inform his
proposals at the constitutional
convention so classical sources were
important to him
but practical sources were important as
well he not only wrote you know
what had happened to past republics he
wrote what was wrong with the current
one and that he had learned from serving
in state government serving in the
continental congress
it's it's a nice
pairing you know he not only undertook
this philosophical exploration he
undertook an understanding of the art of
politics he was
a genius at both and so his reading was
part of that his reading and sources
like montesquieu but also his
his practical experience
was crucial to his successes
ladies and gentlemen let's thank the
cheneys for this great presentation
i want to
thank them
and
[Music]
[Applause]
you're watching book tv non-fiction
authors and books every weekend on
c-span 2.
book tv continues
on this weekend's afterwards james rosen
of fox news examines the political
career of dick cheney he's interviewed
by former bush administration press
secretary dana perino
all right james i've been waiting to for
this moment where i could interrogate
you
um it's a pleasure i've known you for a
long time when i was at the white house
and then being at fox and we're
colleagues and we're also readers and
authors so this is a real joy for me
because i've loved your writing
and what you put together in cheney one
on one
i spent an entire weekend thinking that
i knew everything i needed to know about
dick cheney because i worked under him
for
eight years but what you help provide is
just
peeling back the curtain
of what you call
america's most controversial statesman
and i wanted to start there do you think
that dick cheney as his role as vice
president and then even after the
administration do you think he's the
most controversial statesman first of
all it's great to be with you dana thank
you for doing this um
well i think that a certainly a fair
case could be made for that as i write
in the book
no one on the right has attracted more
vitriol from the left more intense
vitriol from the left than dick cheney
with the possible exceptions of the man
he served in the white house george w
bush or richard nixon and i think
there's very logical reasons for that in
a sense which is that here's a man who
stood at or near the pinnacle of power
in this country for really four decades
rather uniquely from the watergate era
right up through 911 and iraq and beyond
and you don't stick around at those
levels unless you're really good and
really effective and i think that's why
the left has had such a
such an obsession with dick cheney and
you see this even in barack obama's
comments today he called dick cheney in
response to this interview
and and reporting of it that was
widespread the worst president of his
lifetime now there's a joke there
obviously but it speaks to
a dick cheney's extraordinary influence
on our times and b the central role that
he occupies in the intellectual universe
of barack obama right he's in it
dick cheney is in the left's head and
under their skin for sure
um so
tell me about
getting the interview because having
been the press secretary in the bush
administration
at the end there dick cheney was a
reluctant
interviewer okay so how did this come
about that you had got actually a chance
to spend several hours with him longer
than even he had agreed to and he opens
up about everything
well there's a backstory here as you
know uh from our dealings way back when
i covered the bush cheney white house
for fox news in real time i traveled the
world with dick cheney on the air force
one blue and white fleet of airplanes we
went to europe together we went to the
middle east these are situations where
you're hitting 10 countries in eight
days that sort of thing
and we also went to iraq afghanistan and
pakistan on the last of those trips i
did with him in 2005 the end of 2005 in
pakistan
as is the custom fox news meaning me was
supposed to get an interview with the
principal the vice president on the
ground somewhere on that trip dana bash
of cnn got her interview
it took place on the side of a snowy
mountain in pakistan she was very upset
at the end because she felt that the
setting wasn't right
and then
steve schmidt who was running press for
vice president cheney at that time later
of game change fame
announced that they were cutting the
trip short because it was believed that
the vice president in his role as
president of the senate needed to cast a
tie-breaking vote in what was then a
50-50 senate um and
schmidt and the others assured me rosen
when we get back to washington we
promise you you're going to get this
interview with the vice president we
won't forget we won't let anyone bigfoot
you you're gonna do this and of course
as soon as the wheels of air force two
touched down at joint base andrews just
outside of washington everybody not
named james rosen promptly forgot about
james rosen's scheduled interview with
dick cheney the next time i wouldn't
have forgotten no no this was this did
not involve you regrettably um and the
next time the vice president sat down
with fox news was in february of 06 for
a very dramatic sit down with our chief
anchor at the time brit hume for the
purpose of explaining how and why
the vice president had come to shoot his
friend in the face on a hunting trip in
texas uh and as i sat in my office and
watched that interview i thought to
myself it's going to be a long time old
boy before you get to sit down with this
man if ever
fast forward nine years and i ran into
the cheney's at a party in washington
and after enduring some good-natured
ribbing from the vice president
about my recent notoriety as the subject
of an fbi investigation i said i've got
a bone to pick with you sir he said
what's that i said the pakistan
interview from 2005 i'm still waiting he
remembered i said sir if we were to
amortize the seven and a half minutes i
would have received with you in 2005. i
think today we'd be up to something like
28 hours of nixon frost style interviews
he said well talk to liz let's do
something that turned out to be lunch
just the two of us for two hours where
we sort of sketched out what an extended
oral history for dick cheney might look
and sound like in the end we agreed to
do six hours two hours a day for three
straight days no subject was off limits
he sought no control over the editorial
nor any reward from the enterprise
and in the end instead of six hours we
went close to ten hours
so let's go back to the beginning one of
the things i've always admired about
dick cheney and a lot of people think
that because i was born in wyoming that
i knew the cheney's growing up but i i
didn't i didn't have a chance to meet
him until i came to work at the white
house
but i've always appreciated
what i consider his western
sensibilities okay so he talks about
growing up out west and i wonder if you
could
talk about of all the people you've
interviewed uh and there have been many
do you
see a difference in somebody that grew
up in sort of the setting that he did
compared to others who may have grown up
with um on the on the coast
this is a really important point i think
that you've brought up which is that to
the extent that that dick cheney has
been
depicted as withholding
uh elusive enigmatic maybe even menacing
i think a lot of that has to do with who
does by and large who does the writing
about dick cheney which tend to be
easterners and to the eastern ear the
way that westerners like dick cheney
talk can come off somehow alien or
just come up as come up short somehow as
if they're being withholding or
enigmatic in fact what i what what has
been my experience is that dick cheney
tells you exactly what he thinks but he
does it with the the westerners classic
economy of words
and so he hides in plain sight in a
sense uh but as a congressman he amassed
one of the most conservative voting
records in the house and he proudly
notes that today in the book and says
that even today would be thusly regarded
but
he had a low-key style he was not a bomb
thrower this enabled dick cheney to be
able to talk not only to the opposite
side of the aisle the democrats but also
to various factions within his own party
and part of that has to do with that
western style of his which is low-key
not attention-seeking not bomb-throwing
but direct and clear one of my favorite
things about
being in meetings with the vice
president was how he was he'd be very
quiet and you know he that can be a
little intimidating when somebody is
quiet you think well you don't know what
he's thinking or doing and um
i saw an interview with him where he
said that he learned when he worked for
ford
he learned that it's better for the
principals
not to weigh in in the middle of a
discussion when you have a policy time
meeting where lots of different staffers
are offering their opinion because as
soon as the principal says something
then that will shut down conversation
and people won't offer their opinions
and that gave me a different viewpoint
about why he kept silent it wasn't that
he was being secretive i think that he
was listening he's a good listener
but he also understands that the action
sometimes doesn't take place in the big
interagency debate session but rather in
the oval office afterwards and
he's also as we have noted an avid
hunter and i think dick cheney knows
when to save his gunpowder
the other day i was talking to somebody
in preparation for this interview and
saying how much i enjoyed the book
because i think it is very good
and he was saying that back in the day
on capitol hill
when the wyoming delegation of cheney
wallop and simpson was there that they
were the most powerful delegation um
in the congress at the time and i don't
think that a small state like wyoming
has had something like that since ever
since well and they were probably pretty
well knitted up better than most
delegations
but yes for 10 years dick cheney was the
sole congressman member of congress from
wyoming
um
could you talk to me too about
his career is remarkable before the age
of 40.
when in in his late 30s he has his first
heart attack
from the age of 19 where he was kind of
a screw-up admitted screw-up right he's
doing he's he's not really knuckled down
like his wife lynn chaney was where she
was advancing and so tell me about how
does he get from the age of 19 to 34
that trajectory is is quite amazing it's
there's very few american stories like
it frankly but your your reference to
lynn shaney and her studiousness brings
up a fun thing which is that i i
interviewed her in the year 2000 for an
oral history project i did for the late
great talk magazine then edited by tina
brown where they asked me on a crash
basis to prepare an oral history of dick
cheney's life culminating with his
assumption of the vice presidency which
was just about to happen and that was a
fascinating project interviewed lynn
cheney gerald ford i think it's the only
interview gerald ford ever did
exclusively devoted to dick cheney and i
asked mrs chaney and i said
it's been suggested ma'am that of the
two of you you're the brains of the
operation is that true
and she said well i am the more
assiduous academic
which was a sort of a winking reference
to the vice president's um
undistinguished uh beginnings
um in terms of his his schooling he
actually secured a full scholarship to
yale university so remarkable okay for a
kid from wyoming right well nebraska
originally right originally born in
nebraska raised in wyoming that's right
and um he had never been
further east farther east than chicago
right he had a brief sort of stay at
northwestern in high school
and one of the things that that
disappointed him about yale was that
there was no big sky over his head
anymore he just felt ill at ease with
the actual physical surroundings and the
people to some extent and he fell in
with a high spirited group of people as
the dean later came to say
he tells me in cheney one on one about
how he and his college roommates had an
apartment situation where all of four of
the of the bedroom doors opened up onto
a common area but they decided to use
one of the bedrooms as a bar
and he drank too much beer and his
studies collapsed and he racked up two
duis by the time he was 19 years old the
second of which found the future vice
president of the united states waking up
in jail in wyoming and he tells me in
the book this was the wake-up call he
didn't have to completely give up
drinking but he knew he had to set his
path right he flunked out of yale
goes back to wyoming
builds power line as a lineman for the
county okay
and is paying his own way now through
the university of wyoming
alma mater is that right
96 bucks a semester at the time
and fines guess what when i'm paying my
own way and i'm invested in it in every
sense of the word
i'm a good student and he got straight
a's
and through a succession of internships
and
other visits to the capitol he
eventually found himself working for
a
congressman who later went to work in
the nixon administration named don
rumsfeld and that's really the beginning
of his path to power but by the time
he's 34 as you mentioned this this guy
who at 19 been waking up in a jail in
wyoming
was the chief of staff to the president
of the united states it really is a
remarkable story
did he form his political ideology
before yale or
after when he comes back
i think that
as of his time at yale he hadn't really
devoted too much thought
to politics at all
i think that he probably shared some of
the ingrained conservatism of westerners
and
his father as a matter of fact worked
for the soil conservation service
which is a federal agency
so he didn't start out with some
hostility to the state or to the
government his sister spent a career
working for the federal government
that's right
but i think his interest in politics
started to
accelerate once he met lynn cheney in
high school and was dating her
throughout college and then
after college he majored in political
science and as a matter of fact the only
even quasi regret that i heard dick
cheney utter in 10 hours across three
days of interviewing with him had
nothing to do with 911 or iraq or
afghanistan or interrogation or
detention or campaigns and elections or
any of those things he said that he
wished instead of political science when
he was in college that he had studied
history because he is a deep lover of
history and to spend time in his studies
to observe his great communion with the
discipline of history all those books
he's read a biography military history
diplomatic history is he trying to catch
up to lynn
yes
he will not assuredly but uh and he said
that he wished he had studied history
because in his experience and this is
someone again who has
been at or near the center of power for
40 years
he said government really is it's not a
science it's art and
it is the application of lessons from
history from past case studies to
contemporary problems that's what it is
and so the only real regret i heard him
really express was that he hadn't been a
history major that that part of the book
struck me too because i worked with
charles krauthammer when he did his uh
collection things that matter and when
he was asked by students you know if i
want to become a political pundit
or a columnist one day
what should i study in journalism school
and he said don't go to journalism
school you should study history and in
the book then the vice president even to
this day it sounds like is
reading history books and and seeing the
parallels and he talks a lot about
marshall actually yeah george c marshall
the the the interesting thing about that
is that i sensed a touch of despair
in dick cheney
by virtue of the fact that it's getting
a bit harder given the peculiar
circumstances of the 21st century to
find useful lessons from the past to be
applied today because of the unique
constellation of problems we face
not only the nuclear age
but unique 21st century features such as
stateless actors
asymmetric warfare and so on well that's
i
that caught me because we are talking a
lot about how to deal with
lone wolf
terrorists who might be radicalized by
the internet and using encryption
devices in order to communicate and so
that if you're looking to history to try
to guide you there's very little um
except for being uh being sure to act
and being stalwart and good intelligence
all of those things but it is that i
thought was very astute thinking and and
you know the fact is that uh even with
when we set aside domestic attacks like
we saw in san bernardino uh when we
become embroiled in overseas conflicts
like for example the iraq war
again we're having asymmetric warfare
practiced against our forces
and i think and i bet the vice president
would agree although i shouldn't speak
for him that the united states has yet
to demonstrate
that we can decisively win an asymmetric
war perhaps it's a feature of asymmetric
warfare that they can't be decisively
one i don't know so one of the
reasons that he is controversial is
because
after 9 11 the country asked our
intelligence community to do some very
difficult things in order to help
protect us i know that he doesn't have
regrets um
does he
does he know how controversial he is and
does it bother him yes and no okay he
knows
and the very last question i asked him
at the end of the ten hours we had spent
three days together in his study
i i finally allowed the words darth
vader to escape my lips
and i asked him if he believes that that
caricature of him
is going to prevail in historical memory
of him
such that he is popularly or widely
misunderstood
and he said in essence that he feels
very grateful and privileged to have
taken part in so many historic events
and that he doesn't feel sorry for
himself about the way people view him
but that in general he doesn't spend a
lot of time
dwelling on how people view him that's
right there was a part in the book where
he talks about um
it was on page nine it's in your
introduction
um and the question you ask is is it
fair to say
that your influence on bush's
decision-making waned in the second term
and i really appreciated his answer
because i thought it showed just such
humility that and by this time that
there's a second term a president
is more sure-footed yes and that his
experience that he brought to the table
was
neces more maybe even more necessary in
the first term than the second term is
that how you took that yes but it raises
a subsequent question which i posed to
him which was well here now then if we
accept your version of things we have a
president who in his second term has
greater confidence
in foreign policy and national security
decision making why should that greater
confidence on the part of the president
have led him to reject your counsel more
frequently rather than accept it even
more frequently
and he said in essence listen nobody
ever gave me any guarantees he would
always do what i wanted him to do
but it the strain between them can be
overstated that is most distinctly
evidenced in the their dispute over
scooter libby
but for example as the vice president
points out in cheney one on one he and
the president were on the same page
where the surge in iraq was concerned
even though
quite strikingly dick cheney and don
rumsfeld
and dick cheney and the joint chiefs of
staff were not on the same page about
whether there should be a surge or not
and cheney's advice along with that of
jack keane and many other people
prevailed with president bush and the
white house was a lonely place at the
time i mean the president had to
convince many people in his cabinet and
the congress
he's pretty open about his um
differences of opinion with secretary
condoleezza rice um
but i don't see it as personal and
that's what i took away from one on one
yes
look in all administrations as you know
there will be conflicts of personality
conflicts of ideology uh interagency
disputes and it's and it and it actually
is a healthy part of the process
um
there's no question but that dick cheney
clashed with condoleezza rice and also
with colin powell the difference as he
tells me in the book is that with
condoleezza rice he never felt it became
personal
and i think they still have
a a cordial relationship today with
powell it did become personal and there
is no relationship there today and i
think i i sense some regret on cheney's
part that it turned out that way the
irony is that a decade earlier when
cheney was defense secretary and powell
was the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff the two had served quite well
together uh during and helping lead the
country to victory in the gulf war a
decade later in the run-up to the iraq
war that relationship didn't survive and
does he express any regret about um the
first gulf war and how that ended
no absolutely not i mean i think he
rightly regards it as a as a perhaps one
of the last very clear-cut victories for
the united states military and it wasn't
for ordained that it would be so
one of the things he talks about in the
book is that
there was a culture within the top
echelons of the pentagon in the early
1990s where so many of the officers had
cut their teeth during vietnam
when the civilian leadership didn't
quite back up the military the way it
should have and so there was great
hesitation to act on the part of the
military amongst the senior ranks of
officers in the early 90s and one of the
things that cheney and george h.w bush
worked hard on doing was assuring the
military officers that they would have
their men in in the field would have the
support they needed from the civilian
leadership
what about on the personal side of
things with his family because
some politicians go through their entire
careers and they keep themselves
they keep their families a little bit at
a distance and i think that is true for
somebody like a speaker paul ryan a lot
of people
don't know that uh his wife is janet and
then their kids but liz uh well lynn
we've already talked about and liz and
mary were very active
in not only the campaigns but also liz
and the administration
i've always admired how close he is to
his daughters and does he talk about
that in the book
someone while i was writing this book
said to me
there's only three people that dick
cheney is really tight with and they're
all named cheney
[Applause]
but and again that may that may be a
function of their western roots in some
sense but um liz cheney as you know
served in the bush cheney administration
in the state department in a very
important role in the near east bureau
which handles the middle east
and she has been a co-author on two of
his books his memoir and his most recent
one a foreign policy book
i think he derives
comfort from having his family around
him i think it is a source of
anguish for him quite understandably
that occasionally
differences of opinion about
different things between his daughters
has seeped out into public view
um
and you know one of the most personal
subjects that we touch on in cheney one
on one
is uh his daughter mary's
decision to come out to him in an
airport
and this was really struck me as
fascinating dana because
i knew it would be sensitive to ask him
about it he's been asked about it before
it had been been quite improperly a
campaign issue that the kerry campaign
used in 2004 um
quite quite improperly uh but he is in
his own memoir which he titles a per the
subtitle it's in my time a personal and
political memoir so he's telling us he's
writing a personal memoir so i felt free
to ask about personal things
um i said there were only two sentences
in that whole book about this moment
when your daughter comes out to you in
essence she tells you this and you
respond simply to the effect that you
love her and whatever makes her happy
makes you happy and that's fine and i
said now that seemed to me to be a place
of great equanimity with this i read
between the lines that this wasn't
exactly a surprise to you when mary said
this to you
uh and that somehow you would you would
in thinking about it before that moment
made your way to this place of
equanimity where you could reply as you
did and a lot of parents out there
confronted with such news might not be
in that place and what advice would you
have for them to get to that place so
they could respond as you did
and he first made it clear that he
hadn't intended to write a book of
advice for parents of gay children
but he did then tell me actually it was
a surprise when she came out to him
it wasn't something that we all kind of
knew about and didn't talk about now i
found that striking because even in the
80s
when discussion of uh gay and lesbian
issues wasn't as prominent in in
everyday life as it is today
chances are if your daughter is a
lesbian you would probably have some
inkling of that the fact that he really
didn't
strikes me that he was at that time
someone who was deeply deeply immersed
in his career and elsewhere in the book
i proposed something else he does say
something that i thought bears on this
he said
there was a time in my life where
i thought that how well you did at
something it was a direct function of
how many hours you put into it or how
many cups of coffee you drank while you
were doing it
so i have the feeling that he was
putting a lot of hours into his work and
drinking a lot of cups of coffee such
that he was surprised by this yeah that
he didn't know um
and also if we could just touch a little
bit on his health because this is a
um a person who
runs a
has
an amazing career in politics then
another in the private sector gets
recruited back
into politics
and he really as far as i know he never
intended to be the vice president of the
united states so he tells jokes about
the best way to be the vice president is
to run the search committee right
well and because dick cheney led the
search committee for george w bush's nom
vice presidential nominee in 2000 and
wound up as the nominee
um
a lot of people have seen fit to ascribe
some sort of machiavellian
purposefulness
to the to dick cheney in that matter and
the fact is and and george w bush backs
him up on this he twice said no before
exceeding on the third try
um
but to go back to your question which
wasn't about the search committee was
this health yeah right so
you know uh in addition to having this
truly singular political career over
four decades
and and this man has
exercised tremendous impact on the way
we live our lives as americans today
particularly after 9 11.
there is also the fact that dick cheney
is a singular creature in the annals of
human medicine
doctors can point to other people
walking around planet earth today who've
had five heart attacks and a heart
transplant
doctors cannot point to anyone else
walking around on planet earth today
besides dick cheney who had his first
cardiac event in the 1970s and is still
around to tell you about
and so every advance that's been made in
cardiac medicine over the years
somehow sort of in a kind of cardiac
forrest gump way dick cheney was there
at needing that advance very badly and
benefiting from it everything you can do
to a hard patient dick cheney's had done
to him he's truly a singular figure
and speaking of the heart and not the
physical heart one of the things that um
as a press secretary you're always
frustrated with a political figure or a
boss that is reluctant to talk about
themselves is that i always knew that
the cheneys were very generous people
but they don't talk about it one of the
things i knew that they did was provide
the heart defibrillators to all the uh
places of worship in washington dc no
one ever knew about it um and so i've
always felt that he was a lot more
generous than he was that anyone gives
him credit for being you know you
mentioned his business career and of
course he was ceo
very well remunerated at halliburton and
that has given rise to just decades now
of of uh of completely baseless
speculation about
the for the vice president having been a
profiteer somehow off the decision to go
to war
it's worth pointing out that the most
prosecutorial book about dick cheney
that exists is one called angler that
was published in i think 2009 by a
respected washington journalist named
barton gellman it's the kind of book
that takes every sequence of events and
and and draws the most uh kind of
darkest conclusion about cheney's role
in each matter as it proceeds uh it's a
it's a well-reported book but it's very
tendentious
and
even barton gelman in angler came to the
conclusion after a vast review of the
man's career and documents that there is
no reason ever to think there's no
evidence to support the idea that dick
cheney ever ever did anything in his
political career to to profit as a
matter of fact took a substantial loss
to leave halliburton and go back into
government
um
you talked to him and maybe you could
explain
his decision that's been quite different
from president george w bush in the
post-presidency
to be
vocal and to be a critic
of the successor
why does he do that
i think he's a fighter by nature
dick cheney uh but also he is uh in a in
a setting where
um
the man he served
who was at the top of the ticket and the
top of the hierarchy in the white house
has followed his own father's admirable
practice of abstaining from criticism of
their successors in the oval office
so that leaves dick cheney to
venture into the arena time and again
to serve as the chief defender of the
bush cheney legacy yeah it is not simply
the case that barack obama has
uh in some cases deviated sharply from
the policies of of the bush cheney
administration he has continually
asserted that the problems he faces as
commander-in-chief are byproducts of
bush and cheney's decisions and so
the that calls out for a defense from
someone in that administration
uh cheney knows he carries
unique gravitas
that was the word that was banned about
in 2000 when he was brought onto the
ticket in the first place gravitas and
so i think he feels comfortable in that
role
in
talking with him um
what do you think he wants his legacy to
be or does he not worry about it we got
good insight into this just the other
day i had the privilege of attending the
unveiling of
dick cheney's official marble bust at
the capitol a ceremony that was attended
by vice president biden
uh former president george w bush
the speaker of the house
the senate majority leader and others
and cheney spoke last after the bust
which was a pretty good likeness had
been unveiled
excuse me and
at the end of his remarks cheney said uh
if anyone walking through statuary hall
and the capitol grounds should ever
pause to linger in front of this bust of
me for more than five seconds
i would hope they would come away
knowing at least this much that here was
a believer in the united states of
america
and so that i think is our surest
indication of how he wishes to be viewed
in history
and but does he worry about his legacy
no
i think one of the reasons why dick
cheney has been so effective over the
years is because he never had his index
finger
uh to the winds
he is never a politician who will change
his views just because suddenly public
opinion has shifted and it's politically
convenient for him to do so
yeah loyalty was an important part of
any administration and of course in the
bush cheney white house that was it was
prized
one thing i always think about
politicians is if you see people who
have worked for them for decades you
know that there's a strong amount of
loyalty there and that loyalty goes both
ways
did you talk to anybody outside of
that had worked for him over the years
before you talked to him for this book i
just signed a whole bunch of books for
someone who who bought 32 of them very
nice uh so that is that is a model for
you all to follow
this is a former staffer of cheney's he
is one of four people who are called the
old staff which is to say they worked
for dick cheney in the house of
representatives
in the department of defense
and the office of the vice president i
think there's four of those people
left today
and he does inspire great loyalty
amongst his staff but in terms of the
relationship between him and george w
bush and you talk about how how much
loyalty is prized by the president of
the united states
in cheney one on one
cheney tells me that quote and this is
the word he used central
to his relationship with george w bush
was the fact that cheney had foresworn
any attempt at running for the
presidency himself
such that the president when he received
advice from dick cheney always
understood
that it was being proffered without one
eye cast on how it may or may not help
dick cheney four years hence in the iowa
caucuses
and that was really important to george
w bush so had cheney seen that in
previous administrations and oh sure he
said that most of the reasons that
people become take the job of vice
presidents because they think it will
give them a leg up on a nomination
sometime down the road and so he said it
was central to his relationship with
george w bush that bush never had to
worry about whether there was a
political tinge to the advice that dick
cheney was giving how much did watergate
affect his thinking
more than he understood and i think one
of the aspects of our interview where he
came away understanding himself a little
better
was
how profoundly watergate shaped
his thinking and his future career dick
cheney made it his personal project when
he was vice president
to do everything he could to restore the
powers of the presidency of the
executive that he saw having been
improperly eroded during vietnam and
watergate this took concrete forms such
as the war powers act the budget and
empowerment act and various other
encroachments by congress on to the
powers of the executive and uh whether
it was his uh legal posture in the fight
over the notes from his energy committee
um or um you know war powers after 9 11
or other areas of policy dick cheney
always approached it from the point of
view that the executive has to be
strengthened it has to be restored
for the kinds of crises and challenges
that he and george w bush were facing
what about
the day of 9 11
um
i always am interested to hear all the
different viewpoints that for the people
that were there you know living in new
york um i meet a lot of people who were
here um that day some you know one of my
friends owned a bar at the time and
stayed open
continuously for several days
just to make sure that everybody had
what they needed but back at the white
house the president of the united states
is traveling
and cheney is there
in the situation room what did he tell
you about that
in cheney one on one he really narrates
his day of 9 11 almost on a
minute-by-minute basis with me and it's
really riveting
we have to understand that
all of us as americans shared in 9 11 in
some way or other my parents were bombed
out of their their apartment building
here in manhattan in manhattan um
we all felt a sense of
uh grief
shock of anxiety we felt terrified right
um but only one american that day had it
on thrust on his shoulders to run the
federal government in these hours of
crisis while president bush was sort of
hop scotching about the country on air
force one back looking for a secure
place to land
and that was dick cheney and he tells in
the book how he's sitting in his office
vice president united states on a sunny
tuesday his secret service agents bust
into his office lift him out of his
chair by the seat of his pants drag him
out of his office down to the
presidential emergency operations center
the peoc which is this bunker below the
white house
cheney was stunned he said the entire
senior staff was stunned and he used
dana a very
interesting phrase in describing this to
me he said we all felt a sense of shock
and awe
which of course is a phrase ordinarily
associated with the iraq war he's seeing
weapons get passed around the
communications facilities in that bunker
which were
established in world war ii are not up
to 21st century scratch
they've got a ton of things on their
hands like trying to ground all the
flights in the air right now and just
get their arms around this thing and
they're operating under terrible fog of
war conditions such that they're getting
false reports about pipe bombs going off
at the state department there being six
planes and not four planes involved in
the attack and so on for cheney what
kicked in immediately and helped him
assume that burden
uh and if you look at the photographs
that were taken in the peoc in the
bunker that day there's important people
there like condoleezza rice who was the
national security adviser at the time
others karen hughes a senior advisor to
the president but the body language in
the photographs is unmistakable that the
uh the lead person in the room the
undisputed authority is dick cheney
and what kicked in for him
was classified training that he'd
received as a congressman and a member
of house gop leadership back in the 80s
when it was contemplated that the united
states might face something like an
all-out nuclear exchange with the soviet
union
he took classified training sessions in
something called continuity of
government
the first precept of which
when you want to keep the continuity of
the government you want to keep the
government operating in a crisis
atmosphere like that is to preserve the
line of succession
from the president to the vice president
speaker of the house so the very first
piece of advice that dick cheney gives
george w bush on 9 11
and he tells me in the book president
didn't like it
resisted it ultimately listen to dick
cheney was stay out of washington don't
come back here until we know what we're
dealing with some people when they hear
that they think it's because dick cheney
wanted to assume the power of the day
and what you're explaining is that no he
was wanting to make sure that we had
a president to look to that's right and
he kept in in close contact as best as
those sketchy communication facilities
permitted with the president at all
points
one of the most sensitive things you can
ask dick cheney about and i went into
some detail with him on this
is the shoot down order yeah from 9 11.
this is something that dick cheney had i
don't think anybody had even asked him
about
since 9 11 with the exception of the
commissioners on the 911 commission
he conveyed an order to the secretary of
defense donald rumsfeld in those early
hours
uh authorizing instructing the military
to shoot down the airliner that
eventually crashed in shanksville
pennsylvania but which was thought to be
heading for the white house or the
capitol right and there's a tape
recording
of that conversation and a fairly
stunned don rumsfeld can be heard saying
who's authority dick
because after all the vice president
does not stand in the military's chain
of command
and he tells him from the president
president of the united states gave me
that authority in an earlier phone call
the problem is that in the eight sets of
official logs
that were kept of all the principles
discussions on that horrific day
none of them record in the appropriate
timeline or point in the chronology
any such conversation between george w
bush and dick cheney
and in an interview with evan thomas in
2001 cheney slightly shifted his story
about all of that so i was determined to
ask him about it
and i said i said to him sir do you
understand why
even people who are supporters of yours
admirers of dick cheney have a problem
with this because it places you
in what is for dick cheney a very
unusual position which is asserting
something for which there is no
evidentiary record
he said no
there's the one time where he really
gave me the cheney treatment uh he said
uh look there's there's been confusion
we've never been able to pin down all
the calls in the exact times
but
uh this was one of the reasons why he
said
the president and i were interviewed
jointly by the 911 commission which was
a unique arrangement
um fast forward then to iraq and
what does he say about the false
accusation that uh he
lied or that he was complicit in a lie
about wmd
intelligence
one of the harshest
uh assessments of dick cheney's
role in the run-up to the iraq war and
his relationship to the intelligence
surrounding wmd came from condoleezza
rice and her memoir we had staggered our
conversations these three days such that
the last day would be reserved for 911
iraq and something i called cheney
addresses his critics in history
and where and i just simply read to him
some of the harshest things have been
written about him by journalists
intellectuals historians and even some
of his former colleagues
uh and
he disputed what condoleezza rice said
about his uh handling of
classified intelligence and wmd
he but then went on to respond in kind
and and talk at some great length about
an instance where he felt that
condoleezza rice had mishandled
classified intelligence and it's it's
all in the book um but he also wants
people to uh be reminded of the work of
the silberman rob commission which was
the blue ribbon panel that president
bush established i think in 2004
to investigate how the intelligence
community had got it so wrong about wmd
stockpiles in iraq and that report
concluded that there was not a single
instance
where senior policymakers had pressured
intelligence analysts in the run-up to
the iraq war to come up with the
quote-unquote right conclusion on iraq
that's a very important conclusion of
this of this blue ribbon panel
bipartisan and respected
i think it's fair to contrast the
conclusions of the rob silverman panel
with what we see going on today where we
have the pentagon inspector general
actively investigating claims by up to
50 intelligence analysts that their
intelligence reporting and analysis on
isis and our effort against isis has
been routinely sanitized on its way up
the command the chain of command to the
president that is a far more serious uh
and apparently systemic
problem with the manipulation of
intelligence for national security uh
area uh than i think anything we saw in
the bush cheney era one of the things
that both bush and cheney were
determined not to do was to blame
the intelligence community for anything
which i think was the right thing to do
but does he talk about
how they decided to stand in front of
that bus for them well he didn't put it
in those terms but
um but he's not a press secretary
he's a westerner
although you are as well yes um
one of the things i did with cheney was
on day two i was very determined that we
should spend some time just talking
about
the intelligence community the
intelligence product
because not only is dick cheney famously
associated with the the intelligence
failure surrounding uh iraq and wmd
as a senior policy maker uh but he is
probably one of the longest running
consumers of american intelligence
product ever his first classified
intelligence briefings began for him
when he was deputy chief of staff to
gerald ford in the 1970s and continued
for the next 35 years and i asked him
specifically was there a point along the
way where you could observe that
intelligence product became politicized
we constantly hear about the
politicization of of intelligence was
there an era or an episode where that
came into being
and he talked about the evolution of the
intelligence community and the product
that he had the opportunity to
to review for so long
and so it changed when the world changed
after the fall of the soviet union
the intelligence community founded it
was very good at counting missile silos
and that sort of thing but not at
tracking non-state actors using
disposable cell phones
and so when we did talk also about the
eight months before the 9 11 attacks
and the claims by richard clark and
others that key warnings were overlooked
by mrs bush and cheney
one of the things he said was there was
no actionable intelligence that such an
attack was going to occur
and he asked you know at the time
how was the intelligence community
configured
were they how many people did they have
on the problem of al qaeda for example
and so on uh so we talked at great
length about
uh his his consumption of intelligence
product and the reverence in which he
holds
the men and women who the patriots who
work in that field and vice versa i
think um
switching gears
what do you think or did he talk about
what
what brings
dick cheney joy
his grandchildren
uh there were times where we were in
between tapings
and uh he would get an update from
somebody either his wife or
one of his uh one of his assistants
saying that the gift had been delivered
to the to the granddaughter and he would
say yeah did you like it and he wanted
to know you know uh i i would say that
his um he's very involved with his
grandchildren i know that um one of them
is involved one of the girls is involved
in the rodeo local rodeo scene and he is
the driver yeah he like has to hitch the
horse and in the sort of uh vehicle that
carries the horse
trailer yes thank you
did that come off as a touch new yorker
the vehicle
with that you know hitched up to his
truck
and you know sometimes i think from
washington to wyoming i think he's done
that drive
and i think as we talked about earlier
he's a voracious reader
and
and you know he there's probably an
aspect of dick cheney that still likes
being in the arena from time to time
sure
but i think he's he's made his peace
with his legacy
were there some
some favorite behind the scenes personal
stories that he told you that you liked
well just things that happened in the
course of the tapings that you know
one of my
chief aims in writing this book dana was
to rescue this man from caricature
the caricature of darth vader because
he's too important for that
you know here's a man who has had this
profound impact on the way we live as
americans
and
to caricature him is to do a disservice
to everyone who needs to understand
his influence
um and the way his mind works
uh there came there were several hours
during the ten hours we spent together
where he had this gorgeous yellow lab
named nelson
who sat in on the floor and on the
recordings the animal's heavy panting
can occasionally be heard
and at one point this menacing figure
this sinister darth vader character
rises from the chair in his study and
announces to me that we have to pause
the recordings because quote i got to
get my dog off to doggy daycare i love
that part and i marked it because did
you edit any of that out i mean
i thought that was hilarious that he
would take his dog to doggy daycare and
nobody in america would believe it well
and just use the term doggy dog doggy
alone
and and you know so here's a real flesh
and blood person dick cheney enjoys a
good joke dick cheney will have a drink
with you dick cheney's quite garrulous
if you know how to get him talking you
know and at the initial lunch where we
sort of sketched this out we were at a
steakhouse in uh northern virginia and
mindful of his epic cardiac profile when
he sat down at us and let's be clear at
the outset mr vice president i'm going
to be ordering a stake on this side of
the table it's going to be cooked in
butter it's going to be in a scene over
here and he said eat what you want and
he had a salad with demure pieces of
salmon on top of it
do you feel bad about that
i guess this is a there's a confession
of sorts occurring here
and uh
one stray mentioned by me of gerald r
ford launched him into like a 15-minute
disposition on the new class of gerald r
ford aircraft carriers and the new
suspension systems they've gotten and he
delved into the technical mechanics of
it and i confessed to being lost in them
but struck by
how garrulous he was
uh and and how engaging he can be you
know and he does have a sense of humor
but again it's this clipped
western laconic dry wit and sometimes
his eyes will tell you as much as his
mouth does
i always felt like he was looking out
for me
and i think
people might not understand what i mean
and maybe it is a western thing but
my grandfather i said i didn't grow up
knowing the cheney's um they lived in
jackson my family's from the other side
of the state um near the in the black
hills nearer to the mount rushmore in
south dakota and
my but my grandfather was very important
to me in my life was a republican county
commissioner
um actually and you know growing up in
wyoming like everybody's republican for
the most part so when you leave and for
the first time if you go
east of the mississippi
your eyes are
awakened to um a different line of
thinking and thought so when i get to
the white house and i'm junior birdman
you know deputy press secretary and
fairly intimidated but like trying to
put a brave face on it i'll never forget
that dick cheney in a meeting
turned to me and he said
i'd love to hear more about your ranch
it's in weston county right in newcastle
wyoming and what about the highway 16
which is where you get a great burger in
wyoming um and from there i just felt
like i had a really good personal
relationship with him and i don't think
that he knows that
well we will circulate this but we'll
let him know but i think i don't i think
that there is a reverence for dick
cheney in conservative circles that only
maybe now
is starting to surface and people are
being willing to even say this yes i am
a fan of dick cheney and i'm not afraid
right to announce that and and that is
true also of the political classes he is
regularly doing fundraisers and
headlining fundraisers for like the
national republican campaign committee
and so on um and again the frequency
with which barack obama sometimes
unsolicited
invokes dick cheney there was a time
where in june where the president went
on the daily show as his sort of paying
of respects to the outgoing host jon
stewart and uh was trying to sell the
iran deal the nuclear deal at the time
and he said you know i think folks have
some idea that if only dick cheney had
been sitting there we would have got a
better deal that's crazy now
at the next day i was at the white house
right and i asked josh earnest the white
house press secretary i said
why did he bring up dick cheney
unsolicited does he see himself as the
anti-dick cheney and of course josh
demurden said he doesn't think that
that's how the president would
characterize himself but i i do think
that obama sees himself
as kind of uh delivered by providence to
the oval office to undo the work of dick
cheney in large measure and it has been
dick cheney who has been his his chief
critic
in the obama era there was the period in
the the very memorable occasion in may
2009 where the two men gave seemingly
dueling speeches on national security
subjects and they're kind of carried
live with a split screen effect
that served in a way that president
obama couldn't have been pleased by to
assert a kind of parody between them
i remember that very well um
you gave an interview and i wondered if
you could talk a little bit more about
it here which is something i'm
interested in is
why should millennials
care about
dick cheney and learning about him
outside of the caricature sure
we will assume that and it may not be a
safe assumption that that students
millennial students are are receiving a
a kind of fair and balanced portrait of
people like george bush and dick cheney
um
and not a caricature uh but the answer
the simple answer the broad answer is
history always matters right um you
can't you don't you can't know where
you're going unless you first know where
you've been
um and so that's one broad stroke but
specifically george w bush and dick
cheney have had such a it was such a
consequential presidency
um and um the effects of it are still
being felt
uh perhaps not as profoundly as the two
men would like they feel that barack
obama has
as uh determinedly undone a lot of good
work that they did and they think that
the current state of syria and iraq is
is attributable not to the original
invasion of iraq in 2003 but to the
failure of the current president to uh
hold the line on some of the policies
such as the surge the withdrawal of
american troops and so on um and so
if you care about the middle east as it
exists today and how the threats from
the middle east are seeping into our
country as the residents of san
bernardino know so well
then it it you you you will want to read
cheney one on one and learn how the mind
of this very influential man really
works
what about his reputation overseas
especially with world leaders overseas
dick cheney is still in contact with a
lot of world leaders overseas he still
travels to the middle east from time to
time i think especially in the middle
east amongst our arab gulf allies like
saudi arabia jordan
uae
egypt
qatar
dick cheney is still very well regarded
and seen as the kind of leader that
those allies wish were still in power
this uh interview originally
ran in playboy magazine which i know
most people
pick up for the articles right of course
it was
it packed a big punch were you surprised
at the reaction a bit
um and very pleased by it um when i left
his house for the last of the three days
he gave me very high praise
i said to him i hope you enjoyed this he
said it was time well spent
which in cheney speak is very is
effusive praise
and uh
at that moment i had on my hands 80 000
words of transcript which is what this
book is it is the transcripts of our 10
hours of oral histories covering his
entire life
uh with an overview by me
i took
a small fraction about seven to eight
thousand words called from different
parts of the interview
and published it as the playboy
interview with dick cheney now the
playboy interview um is one of the most
venerated uh journalistic formats of the
last 60 years yeah i mean you've had
jimmy carter fidel castro martin luther
king the beatles the founders of google
we can go on and on and we're not even
talking about the starlets and the
comedians um
and uh and and playboy was very pleased
to have this
they even created a special
leather-bound edition of just that
month's issue
which was completely just brown with
gold embossed lettering that said dick
cheney it's very rare that hef does that
playboy has a department that tabulates
how frequently its content is being
picked up in other media
they tabulated that the playboy
interview with dick cheney conducted by
james rosen
had
uh occurred had picked up
650 million hits around the world and i
was in the audience uh at the washington
hilton in april of uh 2015
when president obama himself commented
on it
uh and he made the wisecrack we talked
about earlier which was i see where uh
dick cheney says that i'm the worst
president of his lifetime
which is interesting because i see dick
cheney as the worst president of my
lifetime what an insult to george bush
well probably i mean
a
point of personal privilege probably
probably intended right intended to hurt
president bush
in some respects
but it plays into a to a liberal
shivolith which is that dick cheney was
the malevolent power behind the throne
and pulling the strings and so forth his
brain and and nobody knows the falsity
of that with greater more painful
first-hand experience than dick cheney
with the possible exception of scooter
libby
i'm going to
ask you to wrap up with something that
he that dick cheney had not talked about
before really at any length in public
and that was his faith
and religion if you could tell us about
that
well the one subject that dick cheney
told me in advance he doesn't like to
pursue in any depth with interviewers
was religion
and yet even there we covered this
subject in greater depth than he has
anywhere else and he talked to me about
his sunday school experiences in a
methodist church in casper wyoming where
he grew up
his denominational migrations over the
years
uh and his innermost beliefs
about his faith and to sit in dick
cheney's study
surrounded by all those books and as
this man was soon to turn 74 having
survived five heart attacks and a heart
transplant to hear him say to me i'm a
christian i believe in a life hereafter
it's very powerful so if you love dick
cheney or you hate dick cheney or you're
a millennial and you're just starting to
learn about george w bush and dick
cheney and 911 in iraq if you read
cheney one on one you will learn how
this man's mind and his heart really
work
i love the book and congratulations on
the great interview and then being able
to put it together it's a really
important piece of history and i'm glad
that you had a chance to do it i'm glad
to spend this time with you thank you
thank you
entries
you can find more details on your
program guide
now here's james mann
good afternoon everybody can everyone
hear me am i good is this good i'm very
short
good afternoon hey
welcome to politics and pros everyone my
name is travis cohen i am a book seller
here and i'm also in charge of the sign
first editions club here at the store
i'm just going to do some quick
housekeeping quick intro and all stuff
and then we can just jump right in
between politics and process three
location at connecticut avenue the wharf
union market uh we host around 1 000
authors a year
yeah so if you need any help tracking
all that because as we do um and you
want the full list we have flyers up at
the front info desk we also have an
updated calendar on our website which we
highly encourage people to check out
um yeah and i also think i'm up to
please remind everyone to please silence
your cell phones that's always um not
fun
um as we open the floor to questions and
we have two standing mics right here or
is it just one that one right there i
think there's that one right there cool
so yeah just that one um
yeah and we also oh yeah we are both
recording audio and video today um so
that's good incentive to one silence the
cell phone also to ask succinct
questions um that way we can just get to
as many people as possible
and then also a good reminder too um
after we're done here um if you want to
go pick up a book we have them all up at
the front registers um so you want to
pay a book over there and then come back
over here for the signing
um
yeah other than lastly please leave your
chairs in place uh we have another talk
after this one it would be greatly
appreciated by the event staff
um but yeah today we are here to hear
from james mann author in residence at
johns hopkins university school of
advanced
international studies um a prolific
writer of u.s foreign policy james's
work has appeared in the atlantic the
new republic new york uh review of books
the american prospect and has many
previous books under his belt most
recently the the obamians rise of the
vulcans
china fantasy the rebellious ronald
reagan to name a few
his new book the great rift focuses on
the friendship and subsequent rivalry of
former vice president dick cheney and
former national security adviser colin
powell
the book examines how their relationship
served as a centrifugal force in
american politics setting the stage for
an erosion of political identity and
internal debate regarding uh global
security
it is also an intellectual biography of
two complicated men uh one that
emphasizes the human element of human
affairs um and how is it is the
predisposition of people that drive the
broader powers that be um let's just get
right into it everyone please join me in
welcoming james man of politics and
prose
[Applause]
thank you
um and before i
start just a word or two of thanks to
politics and prose because this
the store opened in 1908 in the fall of
1989 my first book came out a few weeks
later
and my opening event was at politics and
pros so this is my eighth
event here uh and i am
deeply grateful for not just for hosting
me but for being
such a great bookstore over the years
this book is about the the two men who
were really among the leading figures in
america's relationship with the world
at the time of the of the end of the
cold war and the two decades that
followed
if you take the period from say
1988
when really mikhail gorbachev was making
clear
that he wanted to end the cold war to
2008
and you look at the national security
council i don't mean the staff
but the
the body that meets
to decide american foreign policy at
least in non-autocratic presidencies
um
that is the the cabinet level officials
of um the various agencies and you say
who was there even the two-term
presidents
bill clinton george w bush
were there for only eight years
colin powell was there for nine he
served four american presidents as
chairman of the joint chiefs for two of
those presidents
and secretary of state
um and cheney served for 12
4 as secretary of defense and then eight
as vice president
no one had the kind of longevity they
did
and there are also strong personalities
to look at
there was a time
some of you remember when colin powell
was so popular that many people thought
he could have been
president
and on the other hand
dick cheney was so powerful that there
were many there was a time when many
many people thought he was the president
and they're great ironies i find uh as i
delved into this in in looking at them
um powell
thought of cheney
and cheney's uh partner donald rumsfeld
as politicians where he was not that was
colin powell's concept of himself
and yet it was powell
who was the charismatic figure who was
great with people and crowds i have a
uh the reminiscence
of someone who worked with both of them
during the operation desert storm the
gulf war that was paul wolfowitz who
said
that he traveled around
the gulf reed the area of the gulf um
during the gulf war and and the lead up
to it
and uh he did so with cheney and there
would be
troops and people kind of lined up at
the chain fences as the plane would land
and um
uh he would have to say uh mr secretary
would you like to go say hello to people
and cheney
hadn't wouldn't have thought of it on
his own
um but it would did go and would seem
would seem to be happy to meet people
powell
would have been there in a nanosecond
that's just who he was he really was
a people person and then meanwhile
cheney it takes very little time
to talk to all of the people around
cheney to say he to realize he thought
of colin powell as a politician because
powell in his mind wasn't a policy maker
uh and cheney's own definition of policy
maker was something he he believed
that the more unpopular his policies
were the more important his policies
were
and the more they should count
so cheney thinks of powell as a
politician powell thinks of cheney as a
politician
now the book um covers the full span of
their careers
uh both individually and with one
another uh it isn't just about
um
the invasion of iraq isn't just about
the two wars with iraq um it starts with
vietnam because vietnam
um is fundamental to both of them um and
the very they're very very different
reactions to it
really
are motivating forces
powell did two tours in the war
and he came away with away from vietnam
with a passionate dislike for
this is her his phrase slide rule
bureaucrats and slide rule bureaucrats
um was a another name i think for robert
mcnamara um the secretary of defense who
always had ideas that didn't seem to
translate on the ground of what could be
done in vietnam
and the the post-vietnam era was was
crucial to powell's rise
because uh and powell acknowledged this
vietnam had shown a a deep divide
racially between the older white
generals and the uh and african-american
troops
um and powell was a guy who could really
talk across this divide
and help bridge it now cheney didn't
serve at all in vietnam um i think you
all know the stories he there was one
quote uh in which he said that
he had other priorities during those
years
but in a way pal cheney
vietnam was a driving force in cheney's
career
because he served in the white house in
the immediate aftermath of vietnam
especially in the in the gerald ford
administration
when congress was passing a wave of new
laws
the war powers act is the best known of
them
um but there were a whole series
limiting the power of the presidency in
the executive branch
and and cheney um
then in the four years and even when he
became a member of congress was modified
was was motivated by an intense desire
to reduce
and eliminate congressional restrictions
on the power of the presidency
one aspect of the book
is to look at the history as it was and
and to explore the many myths
and shibboleths that have have arisen
about these two guys
so we all have a tendency to reorder
history so that it fits very more neatly
into what's happening and now to our
current preoccupations
to take one example and i heard this
several times as i was reporting the
book
these two guys always hated each other
now that that may be an understandable
impression
that people got
after the 2000s and after
the
george w bush administration when they
really did dislike each other
but you can't extrapolate backwards as
as many even even friends of colin
powell have have said that and when you
look at um
the appointment of colin powell
uh in
the in 1989
when cheney was defense secretary i had
even some of powell's closest friends
say
cheyney couldn't have done that must
have been the white house must have been
george bush senior and brent skokroff
well
this is not what the record shows um
first of all these two guys met
once in germany in 1986
when cheney was in congress it was a
codel congressional delegation
and he uh the the delegation stops in
frankfurt
and powell is a call a core commander
there
and they meet and they talk
and
before
very long
powell is pulled back
um
by his old friend and mentor frank
carlucci
who is becoming the national security
adviser in the wake of iran contra
and he he pushed he pulls powell back
um to be the deputy national security
adviser and then powell goes on to be
reagan's
um
final national security adviser and in
those years
cheney is in congress
and what the record shows and you can
find this in the archives now some of
the art declassified archives in the
reagan library
cheney was powell's go-to guy when he
needed something done and quietly
on uh on capitol hill cheney who was
uh very intensely involved in
intelligence issues was the guy he would
secretly go to to ask for favors
they became very close friends at the
end of the reagan administration as
powell is he thinks leaving to go back
to the uniform military
um he exchanges notes with cheney these
um
you know wishing you good luck for your
career and vice versa these notes are
signed your buddy colin
um the idea that these guys didn't like
each other just doesn't square with the
record
and then
the appointment of powell
as chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
the record shows and cheney himself
has admitted this in in
memoirs
um
cheney wanted
cheney becomes secretary of defense in
march
uh of the year that that george bush
senior takes office because the first
nomination john tower goes down
and they bring bring in cheney and from
the start
cheney's pushing
to
appoint powell as chairman of the joint
chiefs powell is much more junior
he's i mean he's he's not 35
but in military terms he's much more
junior than all of the other officers
cheney wants him
and there and
there's reluctance at the white house
he's too young does he have enough
experience even
bush
senior
says you know maybe we should give give
him a couple more
appointments first and cheney pushes
and even then he
in order to appease bush and scowcroft
um he goes down
and pretends he's not interviewing him
but talks to him about whether to see
whether he's ready
um to be chairman of the joint chiefs
uh and
comes back and and says that he is
there's a whole charade but
not only is bush opposed
but brent scowcroft in the white house
says another reason
um that he doesn't want powell as part
of the team which is powell has just
been
um the national security advisor in
reagan's last year
at which is to say that he was brent
scowcroft's predecessor
um as national security advisor and i
think many of you grasp that people
don't like to have
their predecessors in the job around in
a high high level
position
and so skocroft
was openly opposed
so
it's an example of the way people take
the iraq politics
scowcroft agreed with powell on iraq
sort of
we'll get to that uh
bush senior
um agreed with powell so it must have
been them and not cheney
history doesn't work that way
um
so
as defense secretary and chairman of the
joint chiefs they go on uh to run
not one but two
wars together panama and the gulf war
um they are the the first serious
military operations that are successful
um
uh since world war ii we can just i
think we can dispense with um the
invasion of grenada as as serious
and these guys are
they ride in victor in a victory parade
together
through new york they get their ticker
tape parade
they become national heroes
they're both mentioned as vice
presidential candidates
um you all won't believe this now but
the very the young marine dowd wrote one
piece in the new york times in 1992
reporting that that powell and cheney
were being hailed on capitol hill as the
most effective combination we've seen in
this country
since babe ruth and lou gehrig
now you might say what are these two
guys doing together with such very
different beliefs and backgrounds and
personalities
uh because they seem again looking
backwards so different on on the issues
and that's understandable but you're
understandably forgetting what the
issues were in the late 80s
that brought them together and
the issue one of the main issues was can
be summed up in the word peace dividend
the
democrats on capitol hill
were pushing for
large reductions in the defense budget
the cold war is coming to an end
and powell and cheney work day in and
day out
one testimony after another along with
the third guy paul wolfowitz they were
all basically on the same team
fighting um the dem the democrats in
congress
to not cut the defense budget too much
so not only did they work together on
two wars but on what was then the issue
of the day
what we now tend to forget
an issue that's understandably forgotten
they were allied on that issue as well
and it's true they didn't see eye to eye
all the time powell was more reluctant
than uh cheney or bush or scowcroft
um to go to war
um in response to the invasion of of
iraq
i'm sorry the invasion of
kuwait
and you know yeah it's true that cheney
leaves the pentagon without saying
goodbye to powell and powell was a
little miffed at that um but that's
basically cheney as powell himself said
but on the whole these guys they're not
uh in each other's houses
uh every day but they are up at night in
the pentagon sitting in one office or
another schmoozing as powell records and
um powell writes
uh as cheney is leaving we could finish
one in other sentences that's how close
they were
and this
amicable relationship
continues till right before
george w bush takes office
and thanksgiving of
2000
while the election is still undecided
cheney has his fourth heart attack
and he's going to be in the hospital for
thanksgiving
and so
someone brings him and his family
thanksgiving dinner
um
in the hospital and that someone is alma
powell cheney's wife
so now as we as i talk about the second
bush administration i need to
debunk
the one another big myth
one which is commonly held by all all
kinds of people which is that cheney
changed
cheney was transformed that cheney was
this nice
moderate guy
in the ford administration
and worked well inside the um well he
did work well but that he was a nice
moderate guy
in the
george h.w bush administration
um and now this is not just kind of
street myth this is a myth that's
propagated by people like brent
scowcroft
uh in the iraq war years he said i just
don't know cheney anymore cheney's
changed
uh and there is also what i call the
cardiology theory
everybody in this room knows must know
someone at a dinner party who knows a
cardiologist or is a cardiologist or
wants to be a cardiologist who says the
cheney's heart attacks and again he had
three before we ever get to the
beginning of the bush administration
four by the time he took office
that somehow they changed him and they
somehow transformed him from moderate
to hawk
not true
and
what i found really
uh if you the closer you look cheney was
conservative
he was always conservative
and it tells us something about
ourselves i think that we
we think he changed so let's look at
the reasons
that people think he changed one reason
is that cheney
chaney subscribed to what i call the
hired gun theory
he served as white house chief of staff
and the next year he went out
to wyoming to run for congress 19
um
uh
77 right
uh
and a washington post reporter
goes out to wyoming
to cover or do a piece on him running
for congress and he asks a very
washington question
he says
after you've been the white house chief
of staff wouldn't it be a [ __ ] isn't
going to be a come down to come back as
a freshman congressman
um
that's the pecking order of washington
as some see it
and cheney's answer was very i think
revealing of his entire
uh approach to things he said you know
when you're in a staff job
you're never yourself you're just
somebody's hired gun
and actually if you look
um at his service in the ford
administration
you find that
for example on foreign policy there was
a soviet issue should we
admit alexander solzhenitsyn
to the white house should we meet with
him kissinger was opposed and might mess
up relations with the soviets
cheney quietly
sought to
bring kissinger to the white so it was
sought to admit uh solzhenitsyn to the
to the white house
um
so he was taking in a sense a more uh
hawkish
and anti-soviet view than the ford white
house
when he was in the ford white house he
supported one of ford's
ventures
which was the panama canal treaty
and the next year as a freshman
as he's running for congress he opposes
the panama canalism treaty
so he doesn't treat what he's doing
in the white house as his as white house
chief of staff
as his own deep
beliefs he's a hired gun
and actually when this carries forward
in the george
h.w bush administration when he's
secretary of defense he does work
well with
um bush senior
baker
scowcroft
but he's also more conservative on the
issues
so
there's this
country or it wasn't a country yet
called ukraine maybe some of you have
heard of the ukraine
janie was the precise opposite of donald
trump the issue at the time was
do we
[Music]
push for the breakup of the soviet union
or do we
hold closely to gorbachev and not try to
push him on the soviet republics
and the
bush skullcroft white house was inclined
to stick with
gorbachev and cheney was over there at
the pentagon
in the words of one of his aides the
breakup of the soviet union was
something devoutly to be wished
and he was much more anti-soviet than
the bush white house
so once again you see cheney
there's his view of himself
uh his own views and then there's hired
gun ultimately i've got to sign on to
the policy of the guy
i'm working for and what happens finally
in the george w bush administration is
cheney has now
risen to a level where he has not hired
gun anymore
in fact he's being
he's his position as vice president he's
being encouraged
uh to guide the new president who is
unschooled
in policy and to help him run the white
house so he's not a hired gun he's
supposed to be
the tutor and effectively in charge
now the other reason we think cheney
may have we get the idea cheney's
changed is our preoccupation with style
over substance
sub style over issues
cheney's style cheney has as you all
remember the deep voice i call it a
voice that's almost seductive to ceos
everything is under control
everything is taken care of we have
weighed all
the past possibilities and this is the
best
option
as we learned finally in 2003 and on
that wasn't true but
it was
a
something he managed to pull off for a
long time
and so he became a favorite of the
columnists uh and i mean nice moderate
serious columnist i don't mean to mock
but david broder went to cheney over and
over and over again for wisdom and
cheney would give him the deep voice to
answer
um
and on the other hand so he he wasn't
uh let's put it this way let's compare
him to newt gingrich the two of them
were enter entered congress the same
year
um
gingrich was a we could gingrich was a
screamer chain cheney wasn't a screamer
but they had their voting records were
very much
the same
um and actually cheney got so frustrated
you know he
we think that someone with a deep voice
always sounds so reasonable it must be a
moderate
cheney actually instructed one of his
aides on the hill
will you call the washington post and
tell them to stop calling me a moderate
i'm a conservative i have a conservative
voting record how do they get me wrong
um well if cheney didn't change uh and
he didn't the times and the issues did
so one of the main
uh
things that changed between the two bush
administrations is the times and the
issues in ways that create distance
between cheney and powell
and that's
i've explored in the book in that in
that decade of the 90s
overseas
america seems all powerful china is not
yet a rising power
soviet
the russia the former soviet union's a
declining power
there's no
no competitor for the united states to
worry about and you really get two
different
mentalities that take hold one is
the united states should keep on
dealing with the world much as it has
with its alliances
and not trying to not try to change much
just preserve
the status quo the existing order
and the other was that okay
we have the power now if we want to
reorder things we can we should
and powell represents the first
cheney represents a second
um
during that decade sometimes
multilateralism seemed like kind of a
pain
even the united states kind of
sort of was more multilateral in the
clinton years remember that
clinton in the end didn't go to the u.n
for permission for military action
um in kosovo
but
uh as they carried out military action
um in the balkans
they had to keep on asking the french
the germans the italians and so on
uh to coordinate the military action and
to have a debate about each one and the
military people would kind of grumble
that it was it was a pain
um so the united states is all-powerful
um but multilateralism becomes more
irritating and meanwhile
also in the 90s there are events in
israel the assassination of yitzhak
rabin
brings in netanyahu and israeli politics
moves to the right
and cheney is very close
to the israelis and particularly the
military and intelligence and of the
israelis
so as israel moves to the right
that's another factor kind of
changing the equation for for cheney
and at home finally
our domestic politics changes
as the rise of gingrich to be speaker of
the house
indicates the republican party is moving
steadily to the right colin powell goes
to the 1996
republican convention and he delivers a
plea for immigrants
the relevant quote was this hispanic
immigrant who becomes a citizen
yesterday
must be as precious as a mayflower
descendant
and he got greeted by a smattering of
booze
um
that's something that would not have
happened at a republican convention
eight years ago but it's emotions that
are coming to the surface really for the
first time in the 90s
now
finally
um in the george w bush administration
let me get to um
cheney has a theory his own theory of
what changed when skullcroft is saying
cheney changed
skokraw i'm sorry chaney's response is
what changed was september 11th
september 11th changed everything poor
old brent scowcroft he wasn't
in office when
uh the united states was attacked and
that's his
self-image
of himself
the record shows that's not true uh
things changed
uh
and the the conflicts between cheney and
powell
began
really in the first weeks of the
administration they took different
positions on north korea
they took different positions on climate
change and the kyoto accord
the united states started moving to pull
out of international treaties that
powell really didn't want to pull out of
um
so it didn't start with september 11th
and what
developed was a battle between what i
call in the book the two tribes i mean
these guys this wasn't it wasn't just
two people
these guys each had tribes of of
officials that developed an intense
dislike of each other one there's one
commentator who called it bureaucratic
tribalism and i think that's right
um cheney's the the people behind cheney
had personal and
old work ties to him and yes it's
neoconservatives but it's more than that
uh they're the people who worked with
him in the pentagon this is the hawks
um and they had personal ties and they
did see each other a lot
outside of work
powell didn't have the same close
network of personal network
um but his ties uh were to the
professionals at the state department
cia he thought
and
the career military
and
if that sounds like a description of the
currently just description of the deep
state i think that's not
not far from the truth
that's who is behind powell why are we
moving towards this war that we don't
think based on our collective judgment
um
is is a good idea
and as i look and i'm going to
slow up in a sec but as i looked at iraq
i found two surprising things
the first
is
there was no formal decision you can't
find in the record you go through the
presidential the archives
the libraries
there was no
one meeting
directed to the question
shall we
um
launch military intervention against
iraq i know that sounds stunning
but the way it played out
all of the heat built up in 2002
the two sides
the two tribes form
and there's a huge debate a public
debate that summer
and inside the bush administration
powell deflects the debate
he deflects the debate by saying
we need to take this case to the u.n if
we're going to launch military action it
has to be with with un approval we need
to take the case to the u.n and after a
summer worth of discussions
um they do um
powell takes the case to the u.n
the u.n through the fall finally passes
a resolution which however doesn't
explicitly authorize the use of force
but powell wins with great difficulty
um a unanimous vote
for a u.n resolution on iraq which kind
of requires saddam hussein to
provide information about his nuclear
weapons programs
and if you look back
to november of 2002
you find big banner headlines in the
post um there's a bob woodward story
powell's triumph and that's that's not
just woodward that's the way it was
perceived he he fought off
um the hawks and he succeeded in getting
a united nations resolution
and the problem with that is that while
that was happening the troops were
moving
um
bush kept sending troops to the region
this goes on all the way through
until janu january february march so you
finally the u.s has um
you know
i forget the exact figures but 120 000
peop
troops lined up in the gulf
to the point where
he can't turn around i had an interview
with powell where he he said he admitted
you know
once there were all the troops were
there there wasn't that much he could do
um
and they didn't have you know there was
no last meeting should we do it should
we not it was
again there were focuses on another
resolution should we go for it should we
not
but
should we intervene in iraq what are the
larger issues here you can't find it
um and then the other thing that really
surprised me is this
um
and it came from one of the people
working for cheney who i interviewed it
doesn't really matter for these purposes
whether it was cheney or powell i
would say okay let's go through this at
the beginning of 2002
afghanistan is over and you're ready for
the next phase on the war on terror as
they called it
take me through it and he started
through it and then he stopped and he
said
you know
this isn't the way it went down you're
doing it as everyone does by focusing on
the lead up to the war in iraq
but it was a the two tribes the two
factions
were fighting two battles at once it
wasn't just iraq
the other one was israel and the
palestinians
the bush administration was trying to
decide whether it should meet with
yasser arafat
whether it should push for a peace
settlement there is a much larger debate
that goes goes back even years further
is the way to a israeli peace settlement
by
uh
with a show of force in iraq first or is
the way to in his iraq settlement
to get peace between israel and the
palestinians and the hawks definitely
won that debate
but that's the way they saw it it wasn't
just iraq it was iraq
and israel and palestine
as it played out at the time
and then finally powell goes to the u.n
and once again an irony here
um
powell's
people and powell himself
paul gets asked by bush to give the
speech explaining why we are going to
war in iraq
and he takes the job
he takes it on himself
and here's what he's afraid of
bush is looking for
the rationale and there's one point six
months earlier where cheney says
what's the casus bellai what's the cause
for water you know what's our reason and
this is a problem for the bush
administration all the way through as it
should be a problem now
but
by the end of december
the cia comes to him
with its evidence and they have the
deputy director john mclaughlin give a
presentation and it falls flat bush says
this is lousy
and he assigns
two people on his staff one of them is
cheney's
top assistant scooter libby to draft
a memo
explaining why to go to war
and
that's sitting there
and
bush decides that powell should give
this
presentation
and so what comes to him
is libby's memo and um
you know that that's the main thing he's
supposed to work from
and he says he's obsessed with not
wanting to take that
so that's his entire focus he's got six
days to prepare for this speech
um and he goes out to the cia
and goes over the evidence and he throws
out from the start the libby memo we're
gonna start fresh
and it's he's really working with the
cia and the irony to me is his entire
focus is on cheney which is
understandable
but he didn't think that the cia would
be as
unreliable as it was and so
um in the years after that speech
um powell ended up furious at the cia i
mean predictably furious at cheney
overall but furious at the cia for
giving him a bum steer with that speech
and i think i'm going to wrap up there
just to say
one last thing because we are in the era
of trump
and as soon as um
the question of war with iran broke out
uh came up
not too long ago
i began hearing the analogies this is
this is chainism all over again this is
you know this is like cheney
i have to tell you honestly
cheney and trump were two very
very different figures
um
i think
we can um
that that
chaney was no populist
uh and
um
pardon yeah
uh the example of the ukraine shows
there are very different places on the
issues which i think cheney uh actually
has
complained about um trump's desire for
personal diplomacy with iraq
so my own and i could go on at length in
questions but um really i think
uh to be honest the era of bush and
cheney has now
passed into history and we are now
um with trump in a completely
different era and milieu and thanks let
me take your questions now
[Applause]
okay
it sounds like a wonderful book
especially since we lived through the
whole thing
cheney and trump do have one thing in
common that i think is very important
they they were deferred all the way
through the vietnam war uh as was as
were some of the others
and i wondered
including bush
george w
and bill clinton yes
but at least he thought about it
bill clinton well anyway we won't go
there
um
we're all the same age
do you think the fact that all of these
people who men who never went to vietnam
do you think that influenced the way
they thought
powell did
and and there were people there were
people who simply got
deferments about they were in school or
they had heel spurs
uh not
that they i mean bill clinton tried to
work within the system to avoid going to
vietnam
um
i don't think it's the determining
factor on these guys became hawks you
know they
they
the hawks
some of them did serve
many did not
um
but i don't think that's the determining
factor it it was a factor however in
some of the tribalism
so
during the intense iraq debates
the issue came up of chicken hawks
yes and the remember the hawks were very
very touchy about that issue and very
defensive
so it that became an issue in the in the
2000s for sure
thank you
my question is
about the invasion of iraq
at no time
nobody was concerned about consequences
of that war
how many people are going to be killed
in iraq hundreds of thousands have been
estimated by international organizations
the american casualties how many people
are now going to hospitals throughout
the country with post-traumatic stress
disorder how many of them have committed
violence on crimes after they returned
it doesn't seem that
starting with vietnam and all the other
wars that nobody thinks about that
we go out there fighting a war in a
remote foreign country we destroy
the infrastructure we kill people and
then we come back and leave
the country worse
than when we went over that that never
seems to be a concern
which raises the question what kind kind
of country are we
um i will disagree with
the first part of your list of the
consequences
uh
because
concern about american casualties yes
intensely so it shows up throughout this
history
um
the
uh
you know
on both sides of the debate one of the
huge one of the biggest issues in the
gulf war was
um
uh were there gonna were were
thousands they're gonna be thousands of
people who came back in body bags and
then because the casualties were so
light and this shows the concern with
casualties
um
that
it became a factor in say in thinking
that there wouldn't be casualties the
next time
on the consequences the reason that they
didn't think there were consequences
uh in
uh in the second in the war against iraq
is very simply that they thought
they thought that iraq was going to be
like czech hungary or something
and that there wasn't going to be
resistance so the error to me
is a conceptual one they just didn't see
iraq as different from the eastern
european countries
we will be greeted as liberators
and therefore there won't be casualties
they almost willed them away
now the others um casualties in other
countries i think i tend to agree with
you that there's very little
uh thought given to casualties in other
countries
the last point that you made was
something i was just going to say was
there any thought ahead of time if we
win how do we run it i mean
people must have known that iraq was not
germany or japan and they had all these
they were all different groups the sea
shiites and the sunnis and so on did
anybody think about that and were powell
and cheney different have different
thoughts on that it seems to me that
they went from absolutely so
it's not true they didn't think about it
they had battles over it it became an
inten it was one of i didn't list this
as uh
among the tribal battles but among the
tribal battles
for two years before the invasion is
who's in charge of iraq after the war
the pentagon
through rumsfeld and with cheney's
support
wanted to control everything the state
department had its own future of iraq
project
there were
intense disagreements about
um governing iraq
um and the bottom line was uh none of
them
you know
they were too busy fighting each other
to come up with a plan that worked
would you talk a little bit about
cheney and powell's interview subjects
and how they
get you know how they get into
recounting their past careers and what
they view of
some of those events now gee i was you
know i was starting to think that this
wasn't a washington audience because no
one raised their hand and said
how much access do you have
and i'll give you my answer to that and
then the answer to your question my
answer on how much access do you have is
uh the biographer edmund morris um had
full and complete and unbelievable
access to ronald reagan and wrote one of
the worst biographies of reagan that
will ever exist and he had
zero access to the dead theodore
roosevelt
and had
wrote one of the best biographies that's
around
in my case
um i did have uh access to powell i'd
interviewed
powell for
two previous books
um he was at first a little reluctant
uh i can tell you the story of why
he
didn't like in my previous book about
this team rise of the vulcans
he was on the cover along with five
other people including cheney wolfowitz
rumfeld condi rice
richard armitage
and two years afterwards i went to
interview him for another book and he
said very good-naturedly
pointed to the cover i'd just given him
a book what am i doing on there
and i had to hold my tongue from say
meaning
i wasn't part of them and i had to hold
my tongue
from saying
you know that's really a good question
what were you doing on there
um
but this was good-natured and by 2015
it had become a source of irritation i
guess the book had gotten around more
and he was mad
i was never a vulcan um and we could get
into esoteric definitions of how i
defined a vulcan and how he was defining
it then but he thought you know vulcan
meant neocon and it didn't
but for a couple years um
he was
reluctant to to be interviewed
and then he did
he was he's a good natured guy and he
was willing to answer questions
even though he said he wouldn't
with cheney who i had also interviewed
before
negotiations went on
and on and on
uh all the way till the book closed and
he
i thought in the last weeks that he was
going to decide
uh to grant an interview and he did not
and as i say with my
edmond morris example i don't think it
hurts the book i talked
to
several of the closest people
in and around dick cheney and i don't
think i'm
missing anything and i've
met him i have a sense of him
personally i don't think i'm missing
anything
uh by not having interviewed him but i
would like to have
hi uh what are your thoughts on the
cheney movie the vice and do you think
it was
accurate
uh
no i don't i if i i actually did a piece
um for the post at the time the movie
came out but you can
not be faulted for not having read it
what i think
is
i i don't think it's accurate because
it misses
let me mention two things the main thing
is it misses dick cheney
cheney it portrays cheney as
interested only in power
and it has a scene at the beginning
where
cheney and rumsfeld are together
and
uh
they say they're talking to each other
what do we believe and they decide it
really doesn't matter what we believe
well my view of cheney is that he
was a guy with deep beliefs
that in some case that he was wrong the
problem with cheney isn't that he was
interested in power so much it's that he
was wrong
um and so i thought
the movie missed that and then when you
talk about accuracy i mean the other
thing that's consequential for these two
guys
um they had uh
steve carroll as don rumsfeld that i
thought was one of the great miscastings
of all time i mean rumsfeld is a heavy
it could have been played by george raft
rather than some kind of smiling
chuckling
lightweight that's just not cheney
um mr man you never got into torture at
all as far as dick cheney is concerned
no i don't think so oh you mean in my
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
and um
i just wonder
where
his
devotion or i'm not sure what to call it
to torture
and how he
continued with this despite everybody
saying no stop
um
i i mean
i don't understand it so i thought maybe
psychologically you did or something
um
two things first
he
believed wrongly that it worked he had
he dismissed
he didn't think
of the moral arguments at all and so
once he believed it worked
he stuck to it and he wasn't going to
change his mind
later on he he became
the defender of torture aft other than
donald trump
became the defender of torture after
they left office
um actually he was he to say the least
he was not against
torture or as they called it harsh
interrogation
um
at the time
uh
at all
but
on that one
he was i would i would rank that number
two on one on the post
9 11 issues on which he played a role
the one would the first one is
warrantless surveillance that was his
baby
on the torture
uh it did go to bush um so you know
yes
cheney but but really and and powell it
turned out uh this was briefed
to all the senior people
powell
was briefed as well
he didn't tell anybody including his
close friend and deputy rich armitage
so
he if cheney stands out it's because he
became the defender but all of them were
involved at the beginning
susan hi jim
um wonderful talk i'm very much looking
forward to the book
you just mentioned that
lovely anecdote about alma powell
delivering thanksgiving dinner i'm
wondering if you write more about alma
powell and lynn cheney in the book
they're both formidable women
i'd be very curious about how they
viewed each other how they viewed each
other's husbands
and if you talk to either of them for
the book
i will admit there's not that much
about the spouses
or the kids with the exception
of mary cheney
because
cheney is thinking of running for
president in 96
and changes his mind and one factor
was thought to be uh mary cheney was not
um out
as gay at the time
but but basically no this is i i admit
this is
a focus on their careers more than more
than their families
so i recall a time during the obama
years when dick cheney went on national
television and really took a
i took a swipe at colin powell and had
you know said doubted said that he
didn't know whether colin powell was was
still a republican anymore
and it's interesting to hear about the
comedy um that you talked about that
once existed between the two men
why do you think that dick cheney felt
the need after you know these legitimate
differences of opinion with respect to
policy
why do you think he felt the need to
convey that sort of animosity towards
powell so many years after they had been
serving together in the white house
um that's a good question i think i mean
the animosity that developed
just plain
held and lingered um
and i can't remember
if what powell had sonny said or done
uh that made that comment timely or
whether cheney just went out of his way
i could i guess i could see it either
way
but
uh powell
for him to say i don't know if it's true
that um that he palace whether he's
still a republican anymore
um
this is during the obama years by that
point colin powell himself
is saying
that i mean powell goes through
he's seen there's a point
uh in the 90s when people like george
will or howard baker are mentioning that
powell should be on the ticket
people are promoting him as a republican
candidate
and he goes through this very public
agonize should i run should i not know
i'm not a politician
and then
starting with that 96 convention he
begins to see
that his views aren't acceptable i mean
i remember i had an interview with him
in 03 where he's still saying
people understand
um
i'm a moderate republican i believe in
the right to choice i believe in
affirmative action he went down the list
uh and he said
comforting himself you know people
understand that
well
some people did
but not the base of the republican party
as we know it now and as it was then
anymore
oh one more okay last one final amusing
note i was sitting next to colin powell
at a dinner in the late 90s and uh
somebody at the end of the table said
you realize that jane's a broadcaster
and he shifted over and he said are you
a newsy and i said no i hate politics so
do i
[Laughter]
okay well thank you all for coming i
hope you like the book
i want to thank everyone for coming if
you're interested in purchasing this
book you can do that at the register
please leave your chairs where they are
and if you'd like to get your book
signed please form a line to the right
of the podium thank you
book tv continues now on c-span 2
television for serious readers
television companies as a public service
and brought to you today by your
television provider
good morning and welcome everyone to
this book launch webinar featuring dr
lynn chaney and vice president cheney in
a conversation about dr cheney's newest
book the virginia dynasty for presidents
and the creation of the american nation
i'm robert door president of aei
i'd like to start this morning by
reading from dr cheney's opening
paragraph
put the spike of a drawing compass into
a map of virginia at ferry farm george
washington's boy at home extend the
other leg of the compass so that it
reaches out 60 miles and draw a circle
within it not only washington but also
thomas jefferson james madison and james
monroe were born grew to manhood and
made their homes
from this small expanse of land on the
north american continent came four of
the nation's first five presidents a
dynasty whose members led in securing
independence
creating the constitution in building
the republic
what a great way to start a book
i've spent most of last night reading it
and it's a wonderful chronicle of four
major leaders and the interconnected
networks that tied them together at the
founding of this country it is a story
that evokes what the historian bill
mcclay called the spirit of hope and
perseverance that runs straight through
the american experience
dr chaney is a long time member of aei's
faculty so i want to take a moment to
acknowledge how much we all appreciate
her scholarship and her intellectual
contributions to ai
not to mention the service she's done
for our country
this is the latest in a series of
several works by dr cheney that examine
our country's history with consideration
and rigor her last book james madison a
life reconsidered became a new york
times bestseller in 2014 and shed new
light on the life of one of our most
under appreciated founders
i also want to thank dr cheney's
interviewer today vice president cheney
for his service to our country and great
friendship to ai
i'm so pleased that both of you here
with us for this conversation today and
we will be taking questions after their
conversation
so if you want to ask questions you can
email her research assistant at
catherine quigley and that's katherine
e-r-i-n-e with a k-quigley
ai.org or on twitter using the hashtag
hashtag virginia dynastyai
but before i hand things over i want to
say one last thing
a well-treasured piece of ai history
concerns the time that vice president
cheney conducted an interview with the
current vice president of the united
states mike pence during that interview
vice president cheney was polite but
relentless he asked tough questions that
challenged vice president pence it was a
great dialogue but there were some timid
souls not me of course who worried that
our questioner had pushed the envelope a
little bit
well i'm sure you will agree vice
president cheney that your adversary
today is far more formidable than the
one you faced that day at sea island so
i want you to know that our view
have at it give it your best shot we're
not concerned
and with that i want to turn it over to
dr cheney to speak about her new book
the virginia dynasty thank you
well thank you robert i think you really
did uh
lay out the context by reading the part
of the preface that you did
and it's where i started it was just
remarkable to me
that on this isolated part of what was
in a not very important continent
um and certainly not an important colony
well virginia was an important colony
but it was you know on the periphery of
everything that in that spot these uh
these four men would uh grow to
greatness
and so i think the prefaces as you read
it so well
really does set the context
i agree take it away uh vice president
or are you going to go to the questions
now
well i i was uh
usually she has more to say but we'll
keep going we'll we'll get there
i i was struck too and the
thing that lynn just mentioned when you
take um
the enormous consequences of what these
men did
and how they were able to achieve it and
what they were part of in terms of
building the united states of america
and all that it entails our political
systems and so forth
and at the time
it was
a real backwater as far as the world
goes uh you know and the circle around
what is now
washington dc but at the time it was uh
you can't help but think about it as an
out of the way spot
um
and just some remarkable accomplishments
for a handful of men who were
involved in the effort
is there a question
no
[Laughter]
well i have to forgive dick for that
because
as far as he knew for a very long time
like five or six years i disappeared
and you know i was riding away on my
book in the
far corners of the house and uh i i
think you must have wondered what i was
doing
i
that's been true many times on a 56-year
marriage
i'm going to turn it over to both of you
to continue this dialogue but i did want
to say your your presence was always
felt here mrs janey we knew we knew
where you were
and it was a great joy to have your work
going on inside our building and with
our with the research assistants you
worked with
and your your example that you set for
everyone uh who works here so
you may have missed their uh vice
president but we didn't so
you know it's a mystery to uh
people who don't write books how anyone
can spend you know five six seven years
uh writing a book
but um
i just love it i mean i love the
momentum that you build up as you learn
more and more of it and uh i love the
research now the writing i'm not so sure
about but uh
the research particularly when you have
terrific research assistance as i have
had at
aei it's just one fascinating question
after another
and this is what takes me so long as i
go down every rabbit hole
even when you know i'm pretty convinced
at the outset
that i will never put any part of what
i'm doing in the book
you have to love um as i do research
and i like writing a lot
but in order to spend this amount of
time on a project and you have to love
your subject too
one of the one of the questions that
comes to mind uh uh
is not only were these men you know
architects of our tremendous political
system and so forth the
freedom and liberty and and all that's
entailed in that
most of them also owned slaves
and
that was clearly a
a
significant
element as we go forward into our
history in the
19th century
but uh how do you
how do you reconcile on the one hand
the architects of our
historic
um
political system
the fact that most of the men most of
the architects were in fact
owners of slaves
well that's become a very big question
nowadays as you see statues of
washington being tossed into the river
um
i am not opposed to taking down the
confederate um soldiers the confederate
leaders
um they were um traitors to the union
and i think that to take those statues
down is fine
but i do
i mean i'm appalled actually
when statues of washington fall or when
the d.c government has a commission that
suggests that if we don't start
explaining
the washington monument and the
jefferson memorial better
then you know maybe they should be moved
to some other place
they can't do this because those statues
and those monuments are on
private land but i'm appalled at this
and
the hook for it is usually they were
slave holders
well they knew slave holding was wrong
they uh jefferson i think called it a
stain on virginia and others of them uh
spoke of it as a moral sin and jefferson
called it a sin against god
so they were fully aware of the
dilemma in which they lived the
contradiction in which they
they existed
but they found themselves unable the
circumstances were not such that they
could achieve the full emancipation
that justice demanded
that didn't stop them
once they understood what a unique
place
they were in
what a unique time they were in
they were all educated in the
enlightenment and the scottish
enlightenment
the ideas of freedom and liberty and
justice and equality you know we're
central we're central to that uh
this scottish enlightenment and they
were all well washington educated
himself
but the other three went to find schools
and learn this so they were perfectly
ready
to start a new nation based on the very
highest principles
and that's what they did and you know
you're right dick it is a contradiction
but um
i sure am glad they did it
i'd say
uh how long did it take you to write the
book you know i'm not sure hello
we're disconnected
there you go
robert we have no sound
the the producers would like me to back
aside back take a backstage seat so that
the two of you can just dialogue we're
all hanging on every word i assure you
so we can hear every word the audience
can hear every word but i think i'm
getting the cut sign for me so that we
just leave it to you
so i'm i didn't want to follow that
because i'm enjoying it so much and i
feel like i'm there with you but i
sometimes you got it you know i got to
listen to the staff so
i'm backing out so the two of you can
engage in a dialogue
um and we're all enjoying it so keep at
is
it is that every everybody okay with that
sure
okay good nick was just about to ask me
a very tough question yeah that's right
the uh
why did you write the book is this you'd
written a um your biography before on
madison i know
we're very proud of that and then
legitimately so it was a
uh on the new york times list
but this sort of rolled on out of that
uh that experience the time you spent on
madison
well it it was certainly the case that
i
saw when i was working on madison how
important the relationships were between
him and jefferson in particular i mean
they
they were committed to one another for
life but madison was also his life was
in entwined with monroe's
and everybody's life was entwined with
washington's
i really did quite a lot of research on
the synergy of groups you know what
happens when you
have
people of fine intellect well-trained in
one place and it turns out that what
happens is that uh
they inspire one another
uh their conversations uh
lead them to thoughts they might not
have had otherwise
um their disagreements are important um
out of the
disagreement and it was a huge
disagreement that washington had with
madison and jefferson and monroe to some
extent oh monroe for sure
out of that
quarrel came political parties
you know washington thought that the
government ought to be run in one way
and that was you elect your politicians
and then you leave them alone
and a great idea that's right the voters
should go home and just leave the
politicians alone
well that wasn't how jefferson and
madison in particular were thinking
about it they really believed that
politicians were as subject to criticism
as any other citizen
and that made washington crazy so
that's when the original divide between
washington on the one hand
and the other three the three younger
men
began which one did you most admire
now i like to think of it this way
which one would i like to have lunch
with
and uh
you know the answer has got to be
jefferson
um
oh you're looking puzzled with that i
would have assumed it was madison well
that's that's different
what kind of
an experience must it have been
to
have jefferson talk about his
experiments or to have jefferson talk
about his theories of government or to
have jefferson talk about anything he
was
such a polymath
and according to one woman who talked to
him early in his presidency
he was modest which all really surprised
me she had no idea he was the
president-elect
so um
he would be very pleasant to have lunch
with
now i think though i do admire madison
moore
he's uh
steady
stable
um
not subject to whim
um
very profound thinker
uh the most studious of them all
and plus he had a wonderful wife
uh dolly she was really an unusual
person in her time
she didn't uh
think twice about asserting herself
and you know she was she was how oh gosh
three or four inches taller than madison
and when they went out um to formal
occasions neither of them seemed to care
that she wore plumes in her turban
that they were probably a foot taller
than madison
no he loved her extravagance and i think
people generally you know loved the
incredible way she dressed
she had one outfit that was
pink velvet
and
decorated with many chains i think it
was sort of moorish
but everyone noted that there were some
women everyone noted how exciting a
dress was but there were some women that
were distressed that she showed so much
of her bosom
and it was the style at the time but um
one woman wrote to another why doesn't
she use a handkerchief and what she
meant was why doesn't she tuck a
handkerchief
in her neckline
if you look at the portrait of dolly
madison in the white house
it is certainly the most revealing
and you know doll that's a dolly she was
just out there
interesting
in the current
environment i i can't help it but
talk about something that's current
um
the uh
death of ruth bader ginsburg
[Music]
obviously has set up a situation for a
fairly
apparently fairly bitter um fight
in terms of picking a replacement
trump's rule and so forth
um
i
there were times when uh in your book
when there were conflicts between the
members but i think most of us most of
the
those of us who've read the history of
the era
uh have a tendency to think well you
know they're working hard doing good
things and and not spend much time or
even be very aware of the extent of
which they or there were conflicts among
them
and
i just i wonder how
that crew would look at
this whole question of appointing a
new supreme court justice
before the
election and uh
one of the first women to serve on the
court being replaced
that doesn't create some
well i'm just curious how that would
have been dealt with by uh by your four
presidents
could i just say a word about ruth bader
ginsburg sure
i think it's been deemed politically
incorrect perhaps because i haven't
heard a single person mention what a
sense of style she had
you know she was not only a great
justice she
a great lawyer a great intellect she
also had this sense of style she was
always wearing something a little exotic
there's a picture of the supreme court
members walking down the steps of the
building
and ruth bader ginsburg has on a long
longish skirt and it's so appropriate
for that moment she
she just had that so now my my
politically incorrect compliment
um
they would have fought uh just as hard
as uh i suspect um our uh senators um
and the country as a whole are going to
fight
one more thing about ruth bader ginsburg
though during the
merrick garland
nomination
someone this is in the new york times
asked her
if she thought that
the
president should wait and not appoint in
his last
year before the election
or if she thought that the senator
should hold off voting
and her answer was look the president is
still the president in the last year
and the job of the senators is to vote
so
i i think it shows the
kind of
the kind of changes
that people in public life
sometimes undergo madison changed all
the time
you know he
was the father of the constitution
he
was the
man who got the bill of rights through
but after he had
struggled to make the constitutional
convention work
he wasn't sure that the constitution was
any good
but within three or four weeks he was uh
promoting it
and uh uh
he promoted it on the basis that you
know we really needed a more powerful
government
in the end he changed his mind about
that too
and became worried about
a very powerful central government
um there's a
a british politician i wish i could
remember his name
who said once he said
sir
speaking to someone i don't know who it
was
sir
when the situation changes
i change my mind
what do you do sir
so you know i think that um
part of the back and forth about who's
supported what when
it's just a natural part of politics
and certainly uh
washington madison jefferson
had a
very fraught relationship with john
marshall
who by the way had gone to school with
monroe
the world of the
late 18th early 19th century
is so little you know you keep coming
across uh connections
i think bernard baylen once said it was
like
it was like a little country of cousinry
you know everyone was related to
everyone else in a way
so i i think they would have thought it
out hard
i was intrigued by some of the debate uh
discussions on the court
uh with uh
talking about
justice ginsburg's contributions and so
forth a personal friend of mine of
course was
nino scalia
we knew each other well we used to hunt
fish together
and uh
but i was always struck
by the relationship between nino and
ruth bitter ginsburg
because they were such opposites in
terms of their uh
the
positions they represented with nino
being conservative and ginsburg being
the lead liberal
um
but they were very close personally and
in terms of families and time spent
together and so forth
and i can remember um
justice scalia talking about uh ruth
bader ginsburg and
in glowing terms how much you enjoy the
relationship well that's interesting it
it always appeared to me and obviously
you were much closer to it than i
that it was
based mostly on opera
you know and their love for uh classical
music and uh
judge uh justice ginsburg said at one
point you know when i go and listen to
the opera
the voices inside my head stop
and i'm just i'm i'm just relieved of
the feeling of conflict
and uh
uplifted by it and i i have never heard
you know talk about why he loved
opera so much but i suspect it was
probably the same with him
but the um
one of the things that uh
you touch on book obviously is that
the extent to which there was conflict
between these these
men who were in some respects all
involved in the founding of the nation
um
the
my my feelings
and obviously i wasn't there then but so
much more current time
but um
there is a feeling i think in the
country today that the
relationships
politically
um
[Music]
are
have evolved in a way that uh
it's not uh
what you would expect or that the
feelings between the uh
the congress and the private white house
the president and so forth
the relationships are pretty severely
strained
the battles are
pretty significant
and um
my own sense of it is that just in the
some 50 years since we first came to
washington
that's evolved to many many
it's a significant extent
that there were periods of time when the
relationships were
better
friendlier
more collegial as they often are on the
court
than is the case today
um i know
just because i know you
that you had some experience with this
that working across the aisle and no one
ever really condemned you for doing it
but but talk about um
talk about jack martha or
well he was a significant ally of yours
jack was a democrat from pennsylvania
sure well
when i arrived here in
1966 to go to work on the hill the first
time
the um
um over the years good relationships did
grow up i mean i i look back on my time
four years i spent a secretary of
defense
as a republican secretary of defense
my
strongest ally in the house the man that
i did the most work with
was jack martha
he was a marine he was the first vietnam
veteran ever elected to congress
um
and uh
he was my closest ally when it came time
to put the defense bill together he
chaired the
defense appropriations subcommittee of
the house
while i was secretary of defense
and so there were
and uh relationships like that that were
i'd call them significantly different
than a lot of what we see today
happening on
capitol hill and i've always anticipated
some degree of cooperation
among the founders uh neglected and
collectivity
um
but your book shows that it was
sometimes
down and dirty there just like it was
from occasions now in congress i think
that the steadiest and probably the most
rewarding relationship for both men was
jefferson and madison
and they didn't always agree jefferson
jefferson tried to undermine the
constitutional uh ratification he sent
letters out uh to friends who then
showed them on the floor of the virginia
assembly where they were undertaking a
crucial ratification uh criticizing the
constitution and suggesting that they
not ratify it so that you know there
could be more discussion and maybe uh
some changes that should be made
madison
as i say the steadiest of all
didn't get mad or at least not so that
he showed it he just quit writing to
jefferson for a while jefferson was in
paris
at this time so um it took madison a
long time to send jefferson a copy of
the federalist papers or the federalists
and uh
well i just love it as an example of you
know jefferson sort of winging it you
know i think i'll criticize the
constitution now or the constitutional
ratification
and madison just holding fast and not
losing his temper i think that
jefferson must have been a very
difficult friend
now i it's uh 11 30.
why don't you ask me a couple more
questions and then we'll go to the
questioners on the uh
[Music]
english literature this is true and uh
obviously you drifted quite a ways away
from that once you've gotten involved in
history you spent a lot of time on
american history
and on political history
uh i always felt i should have had more
history
than i did political science had been
more valuable and more useful for me
but um
how did you account for that transition
you made from
from literature to uh
to
politics to the founding fathers etc
i couldn't get a job as a literature
major really yes i
began writing um
and there were some very nice people
along the way who allowed me to do
historical writing for for different um
different magazines and outlets
and i wrote history
it just i just drifted toward it you
know there's a
sense in which i don't think i
understood you could major in history
you know that it was just it was not
political science and you could do that
i don't know why
i missed the idea that you could
possibly get a phd in history but i did
and
when i got a chance to start writing it
was really quite wonderful and this one
job i had allowed me every month to go
take one aspect of washington
dc
and uh
describe it explain it you know really
uh get to the underlying basis of it
subjects from
arlington cemetery
to
the columns that are all over washington
the c-o-l-u-m-n-s
maybe both columns are spelled the same
i don't think so anyway um the columns
around washington and why why we had all
these columns so it was
the kind of assignment that simply
went my appetite and
that's just the direction in which i had
it
would you like to turn it over to the
folks i would you should i'm sure
they've got some questions but i like
yours
i'm coming
back
just to say thank you that was just
lovely and we hung on every word and to
turn it over to jay our historian in
residence at ai to uh continue the
questioning and sort of monitor the
questioning from the audience but i just
couldn't resist uh coming back on and
saying thank you to both that was just a
wonderful conversation so jay for us get
from here
well thank you robert um my name is uh
for those of you don't know my name is
jay koss i'm the gerald r ford visiting
um scholar at aei it's a real pleasure
uh to be with both of you today dr
chaney vice president cheney and we have
some really interesting questions um i
guess the first one that i want to ask
you about is the quality of
statesmanship
among these men and i'm really struck
that it points in all of their
professional lives they wanted to go
home or they wanted to stay home
washington didn't want a second term
jefferson carried in virginia rather
than take the secretary ship of state
madison was back in montpelier with a
wife and a and a young stepson monroe
was in europe and he wanted to go home
but they all sacrificed
for the sake of what of the the good of
the country
and can you tell us your thoughts on
what
qualities of statesmanship or leadership
that set these these four men apart
well certainly a sense of the importance
of the task that they were about
it was
enormous it was such an opportunity to
build a country based on freedom
and it was an irresistible
calling to them
now you're right it also was punishing
and so madison went home washington
whenever he could
but i think it was six years that
washington was gone from home
during the revolution
and at one point madison spent far more
time at a boarding house in philadelphia
than he did at home and you know i think
that reflects the feeling that they
each had that they were about a great
task
and a great task feeling as though
you're part of something bigger than
yourself that
that was
very attractive to them so while they
nearly all went broke um in the end
and no doubt that was part of the fact
that they had been
absentee landowners uh for so long there
were many many reasons
but i don't think you know if you'd ask
them the choice would you rather have
had a life in which you
died
you know well off
then have had a life where you could
create a great nation i'm pretty sure
they would have chosen the latter
yeah interesting um so another reader
points out that you know the the sort of
network of
men
that you discuss in your book right
these four
titans of the virginia dynasty there
were other networks as well you know the
bostonians
adams and quincy and the hancocks and
you know you can also look in new york
and philadelphia
um with hamilton governor and robert
morris philip scheiler
how
would you describe the relationship of
these different networks especially in
light of the fact that the eastern
networks were more focused on commerce
while the virginia network was obviously
much more agricultural in its economic
background
well they didn't see the world quite the
same way
and there's a wonderful quotation
um
gosh i can't remember who wrote it maybe
you can help me jay
in which uh person a
said of john adams you know he's
wonderful he's entertaining he's smart
but he's half mad
and there
washington was appalled when he became a
commander of the continental army and uh
and went to boston
at uh money grubby
you know now in virginia you didn't
money grub partly because you had
slaves who you know
didn't in the end in the end slavery
just didn't work
in the end it did not allow
for a profitable enterprise
but they were much more polite
uh than adams was he was just out there
picking up dust and stirring up trouble
yeah
very well put so that's just you know
one example right i think the
northerners and the southerners from the
beginning were very different
and part of the reason that the civil
war happened is that uh they never
really reconciled those differences and
certainly uh the north could not
um by the middle of the 19th century um
reconcile itself to slavery
yes
what about can you speak a little bit
about monroe because you know the
the first three the big three all have
these grand titles you know the father
of his country author of the declaration
in independence
um
the uh you know father of the
constitution
monroe is often underlooked but you your
your book sort of you know by choosing
to focus on somebody like to choosing
marshall over monroe what do you think
he added and and what what are we maybe
as a
200 years later what have we as as sort
of
society what have we missed about him
well we missed a lot for a long time
because there was not a
comprehensive edition of his papers
and there is now and you know so i
expect in the years ahead we'll see a
lot more monroe scholarship he was such
a curious man he uh
angered perhaps uh
more than any other of the dinos you
know washington had a formidable temper
but monroe and one of the people he was
angry about most of the time was
washington
monroe would sit down and write these
scathing letters
memos to washington telling him you know
what a worthless person he was and how
he was leading the country into monarchy
this is fascinating and i don't think
we've been able to pay enough attention
to it before but to see this aspect of
his character
and then realize that despite you know
what seems like a grievous flaw
this ability to anger so quickly and
deeply
he was a good president
he
didn't
preside over great
great events
like the louisiana purchase though of
course he was there at the louisiana
purchase
doing some part of the negotiating
but his achievements were great
nonetheless it was jefferson i'm sorry
it was monroe with
john quincy adams help that made the
united states a continental nation
and
the era of good feeling people always
make fun of this uh description of
monroe's um
terms and term in office his two terms
um was in some sense real
there was a calm in the country and
there was a calm in the presidency
he had the most stable cabinet of any of
the presidents
and i think you know that's sort of a
kind of security and continuity that
people felt
interesting thank you um i want to talk
a little bit about the revolutionary war
and how it shaped their character
because all four of them
participated in some sense right
washington and monroe in a military
sense jefferson
governor of virginia and you know fled
from the capitol much to the delight of
patrick henry um james madison of course
being as short and slight as he was was
not cut of military cloth but was in
philadelphia struggling through
the problems of public finance
especially can you talk about the ways
in which the war
shaped their character shaped their um
understanding of the union just how did
that affect them
well in madison's case
he could not become a warrior
because he had epilepsy
and this is a a
theory that i think i
pretty much
substantiated in my madison book
he would simply have a complex partial
seizure every once in a while and as he
described it the intellectual functions
would be suspended
and
it seems as though he had uh such an
event
when he was uh practicing to be a
soldier he was out on the field and
the story's not told entirely but uh it
sure seems as though that's what
happened and he then of course didn't
feel he could serve in the military and
the military probably didn't want him at
that point
so that was madison's story i think a
feeling of being a little left out
but then turning to what he knew best he
began studying
governments and constitutions he was
interested in it even as a very young
man
and that study became
more and more important to him
let's see so jefferson well jefferson
spent his whole life trying to prove
that he wasn't a coward for having first
fled richmond and then fled
charlottesville
and the charlottesville exit was
very humorous in a way for us looking
back so
far
um he
basically tried to act like he didn't
he wasn't worried
you know and so we went to
charlottesville he was at his home
i believe
and
invited legislators to stay the night
and you know applied them with food and
drink
a young man came to warn him that the
british were coming and he offered him
some madeira
and finally people began leaving and i
jefferson was certainly one of the last
to leave and he tried to do it very
casually but in the end he took his
fastest horse and and galloped away
right right very good
i forget washington
jeffrey well monroe's argument with
washington and i think with washington
in particular
his big argument was that washington
didn't appreciate what he had done
monroe was nearly killed at the crossing
of the delaware
um
taken out of action
uh not given the commission he thought
he deserved and i think all of those
things uh
made him feel as though uh
you know washington was turning his back
on him
so the war did that to monroe um and to
washington of course it was an
opportunity for glory
but it was also a tough slog
and one of the things i've admired about
him is that no matter how tough the slog
he conveyed
an heir an aura of competence
um
not at the beginning it's very
interesting at the beginning his troops
were worried about his indecisiveness
but
as it as the war went on and people came
to
maybe understand him better
it was that uh
rock hard
confidence or
the ability to appear confident
that was very important
right
um you know it speaks the this idea of
projecting confidence
just more broadly
um
all four of them
had a a very distinct
ethos i don't know what the right word
is but
their public appearance
and you know washington obviously having
to lead men in what was a very difficult
you know situation but you know even
madison uh you know one of our one of
our viewers writes in and points out
that madison participated in college
debate societies um you know he was in
the wake society at princeton
and and prepared them in ways for public
life and how they comport themselves in
public and you know in this age where i
personally am so chagrined by seeing
politicians just pop off on twitter all
the time just with such a lack of
decorum
how do
is there a way that we can recapture
that particularly preparing you know
young young people
for engagement in the public sphere and
and expectations of what it means to
participate
in those because our though the
virginians certainly had very distinct
a sense of public dignity which seems to
be lost today
well i do think that the atmosphere in
virginia encouraged people encouraged
men
from a very young age to participate in
public service
and so when they were 24 25 26 when they
were very young they became members of
the house of burgesses
and took part in actual legislation and
you know saw older men who
who impressed them
greatly so i think that
helped them
probably we
shouldn't
overestimate the amount of
composure and politeness
that they um
you know where i'm going
they later demonstrated with their
debating societies which often involved
very raucous uh
lyrics that you would not want repeated
in front of children
so you know they were they had a lively
time at princeton as well as uh learning
a great deal from a great man named john
witherspoon
good um a pres a question um for you uh
mr vice president so um
uh john uh thomas jefferson
was uh you know among his many
accomplishments who served for four
years
as vice president how would you assess
his tenure as vice president
well
he didn't do a thing
i i don't think he did much
and uh
the uh
he did get uh squared away set up so to
speak to be president
no no mean achievement no mean
achievement and uh i think
you're speculating that that is a
hoped for outcome for an awful lot of my
predecessors not many of them made it
but uh
it's um
there's a sense now that you know that
it's taken on
more significance and so forth than that
that um
the jobs uh
is a legitimate job i mean you're
earning your pay so to speak and i think
that's true in in the last uh
um
back uh
probably at least at john nance garner
um
but the uh
uh that's an interesting question i've
i don't think of jefferson as vice
president and uh
the way i thought of myself as vice
president you know
but um
it it
you know the the history is such that
it's clear that uh
the job didn't amount to much for an
awful lot of the people who held it over
the years
right well and i guess as a follow-up of
course because jefferson became vice
president
uh having finished second in the
electoral college to
john adams
if you could
re re-envision american history in this
in a way in which the second place
finisher in presidential elections
becomes vice president
how would you react to that and you know
there's another way of saying do you
think the 12th amendment was a was an
improvement
i uh well i don't know that's an
answered question because the uh
you know
i think most recently obviously harry
truman
and what a tremendous president he made
um
even though
he you know he was the haberdasher from
missouri
and
[Music]
is
involvement though when he took over
uh his lack of um i mean roosevelt
hadn't really included him in anything
in the period of time when he was vice
president and uh he came in and
ended world war ii uh won the cold war
and it kind of started in a significant
sense i mean truman was in my mind a uh
a democratic
but a
strong president
and
it was his time as vice president
um that really set him up to perform
that task on roosevelt's death
i have just interjected a note here
because it always
makes me laugh
um
the vice presidency
from the beginning
was an afterthought
in order to establish voting in the very
first instance
as you pointed out everybody just ran as
a pack
and the person who got the most votes as
long as it was a majority was president
and then the person who got the second
number of votes was the vice president
and that was really an afterthought you
know the question was well
what are we then going to do with him
you know we've got this vice president
now now what and so they could only
think of one job
they gave him uh the presidency of the
senate and they did that largely because
they wanted to keep him out of trouble
right
i like being sure dick remembers this
i remember when i was the president of
the senate
i had to sit up there in one of the
chairs in front of the house chamberlain
didn't you cast a tie-breaking vote at
one point oh yeah seven or eight times
oh
interesting i was busy
yes you were
well we're just about out of time but i
i have one one final question um because
you know we talked a lot about the
history of these men and and and
especially in your your questions vice
mr vice president talking about
contemporary politics and it's you know
i think everybody agrees this is a very
unsettled age
um difficult times for our country what
do you think
would be maybe one or two lessons
that the virginia dynasty can we today
can take from to sort of guide our
politics moving forward
gosh you know they were a raucous bunch
um
fighting with each other um they were
smart that may be a very important
element uh
jefferson was smart in a kind of flighty
way
monroe was smart in a kind of practical
way he looked at other people like
madison and said hmm
how do i how do i succeed in the way he
did
um uh
washington had kind of innate natural
intellect and i think that kind of
attitude that kind of interest toward
intellectual issues um helped make them
uh successful
actually i do have one more one more
question a late arrival somebody's
running late um what so they asked what
do you think about the musical hamilton
and the way members of the dynasty are
remembered therein
well i loved hamilton
we saw it a long time ago when it was
still off broadway
and i i had heard about how excellent it
was so i got his tickets had the hardest
time in the world persuading dick to go
uh to a rap musical
but then he did and he he really admired
it as well fantastic
i i can't
well i thought washington was well if
humorously done but um madison was the
one i found most disappointing now i
know you weren't even supposed to try to
look like the fellows um that you were
impersonating but madison was kind of a
big old hunk of a man who you know
walked uh
bent over and that seems to me so far
from uh
that that one caught my attention and i
thought i might have changed that a
little bit
right well wonderful thank you so much
for your time this has been such an
educational
enjoyable uh
opportunity for me to speak with you and
based on the questions i think our
viewers enjoyed it good luck with the
book publicity
just best wishes to you both thank you
so much thank you
the presidents available in paper